learn how to create a fully functional
hotel management site with nextjs 13
react sanity iio tailwind and stripe
Larry brgh created this course he will
help you understand how to fit all of
these Technologies together in a real
world full stack project Hello friends
and welcome to another project video
where we are going to be building and
deploying this hotel management system
so let's have a demo of the application
we are going to be building this
application is going to be using the
sanity CMS so if I copy over this URL
and I open the new tab in my browser and
I just go to/ Studio you see that we
load our CMS so our CMS is embedded
inside of our front end code here and we
have this navigation um section we have
the header we have the user profile and
you can also switch between the light
and dark team here and our application
is fully responsive for mobile devices
and also for desktop
devices all right so let's have a demo
here so over here we can search through
a room and we list out a room so let's
actually start in our CMS here in our um
content management
system let's try to create a hotel room
so we can click on this hotel room
section and here we click on this
tab all right so we need to give this
hotel room a name I'll just call it test
hotel for now and I'm going to generate
a slug and for the description I'm just
going to copy and paste this description
in here and for the price we can give
this a aot of price of 1,000 and say we
are currently on a 10% discount and for
images I will click here and I will just
fast forward and add so um images from
unsplash here okay so once we have added
these images for the cover image I'm
also going to copy this um add URL from
Splash or you can as well add a file and
you see by default the room type is
basic we can choose the different room
types I'm just going to choose luxur and
we have the special note um I'll leave
the dimension for number of beds I will
just say two and for off amenities we
can choose an an amenity for the icon
the icon has to be um a font or some
icon so I'm just going to come here and
add this icon fa bir and for the amenity
I would just say
king king sized
bread like this and that should be it so
it's saved we can obviously add more all
right so after this I'm not going to
make this U is not booked so by default
a hotel room isn't booked and I will not
make it to be a featured hotel room and
we can go on to publish this hotel room
so we gave this hotel room uh name of
test hotel and if we come over here to
the to our application we come over to
our rooms section we see that we have
our hotel room here in real time so as
we make changes to our sanity Studio you
see it reflects in our application and
we can go on to book this hotel room so
I'm going to click on this book now and
these are the images that I uploaded for
this and we have this nice looking model
over here for the different images so
that's the user can swipe and see it in
full screen all right so you see what we
chose here the Kings siiz bird the City
View and the coffee maker with the
respective icon I just happen to choose
the wrong icon for the City View with we
see the description we see here they
offered amenities safety and hygiene and
this hotel room doesn't have a review so
let's go and book this hotel room and
you have to be authenticated so if we
click here you see this comes the user
profile page and we can obviously sign
out of the application and we are
redirected back to the homepage and we
need to authenticate so we can
authenticate via um email and password
or we can use GitHub or we can also use
Google I'm going to click on Google over
here and I'll sign in with my Google
account and I should be redirected back
to the application great so let's go and
and book this our test hotel room that
we just added so you see here we have
this um filter here and we can filter by
luxury and we see the hotel room because
this falls under that category and I'll
just click on this book now and here
I'll choose a checking date so I can
choose today as a check-in date and you
see a later day as a checkout date and
you see the price updates accordingly
because there's a 10% discount we see
that the price here is 900 bucks and if
we choose a date that is way ahead of
our checkout date we have this error so
that the user cannot book you know a
date that is where iead our checkout
date now I'm going to choose this
checking date and I'm going to go and
book this hotel room now once this loads
up stripe because we are going to have
stripe for payment if we come over here
so we see sessions that we have used now
because this hotel room is following a
payment first approach a booking is only
going to be made if payment is
successful so I'm going to fast forward
through and fill out these details over
here and once you fill out these details
you can go on and click on pay and this
is processing payment now on successful
payment we can just come back to our
stripe dashboard and let's let's reload
this um sessions that we have here I'm
just going to reload this and you should
see our new web hook now this web Hook
is called because so this is our new web
hook that we just triggered now now
because this event is called we go on to
create a booking and if we come over
here to our sanity studio and we come
over to our booking section you will see
here that we just booked this hotel room
so this test hotel room here the number
of days and all the details that we
filled out wise we were booking this now
if we come back to our hotel application
you see here that we are redirected to
the user profile page and here the user
can see the current bookings and the
user can also see the amount spent so
this is the test hotel which was the
highest amount spent at 900 bucks so if
we come back to the current bookings and
we click on rate we shall be able to
leave a rating on this hotel room so we
you can say great
experience like this and click on submit
now this is going to go on and submit
the review and we come back to the test
hotel room we should see our review here
we're just going to reload this and our
review should pop up so this review that
we just gave on this hotel room and you
see this hotel room is booked and the
user cannot go on to book this hotel
room so we can come back to the user
profile page and here where we have this
hotel room we just booked if we want to
leave on that rating here and we click
on submit and we come back to the test
hotel room so here I'm just going to
reload this and you should see that the
hotel room you know updates so we have
this functionality to leave a review and
to also update a review and only
customers that have booked a hotel room
can go on to leave reviews on that hotel
room so this is the application we are
going to be building and the application
is fully responsive now we have this
crazy looking parenthesis here because
we didn't provide a dimension so if we
come back here to the test hotel room
and here where is it this test hotel if
we just leave a dimension over here so
we can just say 30 or whatever and
publish and if we come back here we
should see here the
updated just reload this we should see
here 1 so for the dimension so this is
the application we have our review and
all aspect of this application
is fully much responsive as you would
expect and to achieve this we are going
to be using Tailwind CSS here so this is
the application we are going to be
building together if you like this
project please do go on and leave a
subscribe it helps the channel and don't
forget to give it a thumbs up as well
and I have already left time stamps in
the description so in case you come back
for later you should be able to continue
with the project and the source code is
already in the description so you can
get it on GitHub now let's get started
building out this project together let's
start our project and I'm navigated to
my desktop from my terminal and I'm
going to run the command to create a new
nextjs project and the command is MPX
create next app and I'm going to be
using a template of typescript so I'll
zoom out a bit so you see the entire
command so MPX create next app with a
template of typescript I'll execute this
we are prompted to give our application
a name and for this project I'll just
give it the name of hotel management
like this so I'll just add e so hotel
management and say yes to all these
promts and say no to customizing default
input now once next GS CLI is done
building our project I'm going to CD
into the created project project which I
called hotel
management and go into Visual Studio
code so this is the default files and
folders that we get by default and if we
run mpm run there so that we can just
preview the application that we get um
from nextjs as you can see we are
running on next GS
13.5.3 so this is the current version of
next GS we are working with
and we come over to
the browser and we just go to Local Host
3,000 you'll see the file or our
homepage so Local Host
3,000 so let's go and make changes
already to our
application and I'll get started in our
layout our layout. TSX which controls
the entire layout of our nextjs
application and for the title I'll give
it the title tool of hotel management
app and also update the
description you can give this any title
or any description of your choice but in
this case I'll just say discover the
best hotel rooms like
this and this is going to update our
header title and description for the
font I'll be making use of font Poppins
so I'll import Poppins from next phon
Google and use it over here we have an
error but before we come to that the in
variable here I'll change it to popins
all right popins with uh lower case
P okay so configurations we can pass to
this Popin font is the font weight so it
can be a string in this case I'm going
to pass an ARA of strings for the
different font weights where Us in the
application so we're going to making use
of a font weight of
400 also a font weight of 500
and also a font weight of 700 and lastly
you're going to make use of a font
weight of 900 okay so I'll just type 900
like
this and for The Styling I'm going to
give this a style of italic as well as a
style of normal so this style over here
normal and lastly we need to pass also a
variable okay so we're going to pass a
variable and the convention is to go
with double hyphone like this and then
font another hphone and I'll just go
with font Poppins as the
variable and to fix the error that we
have in our body tag over here right and
go with inter class names we are going
to go with poins do class names like
this so popping do class
name all right
and I'm going to cut this children here
and I'm going to wrap our layout in a
main tag like this in the main tag so
here we have a main which we can give um
class name and the class name I'm going
to give to this main tag is font normal
so font normal like this and lat room in
our application we're going to have a
header component as well as a footer
component so here I'm going to have
header so this is a placeholder and I'll
comment it out and just after it we're
going to have children
and after which we are going to have our
footer
component all right but before we go on
and have our header component so before
we go on and have the layout for our
header component I would just like us to
you know discuss briefly about the meta
description so let's go over to the
browser and here in the browser if I
just reload and you see here we have
hotel management app if I open the
elements um tab over here so here where
we have the elements Tab and I just
collapsed the head so here if you check
down so here you see here that we have
the meta so description and we have the
content and the same for the title so
this object that we have over here so
this uh metadata we just have the title
and it renders it as we normally have in
HTML in our head tag where we have the
title and there we just write without
the title of our application so this is
the work of this meta data we can pass
you know these headings that we would
normal normally have in our
HTML okay so I'm just going to rever the
changes that I made
here and we can go on and create a
header component so in the source folder
I'll create a new folder I'll call
components and in here so inside here
I'm going to create a folder I'll call
header and then another file which I'll
call header.
TSX okay so I'm just going to boot strap
this header
component and remove the react
input and we can already import this
header component in our layout so here
we have the placeholder I'll go and
import
header so header will be coming from
component header header like this and
I'll just rearrange the order of inputs
here so for HTML semantics rather than
use a div I'll be making use of um the
header
tag and obviously I'll be styling this
header so I'll give it a padding on the
Y AIS of 10 padding on the x- axis of
four give it container and to position
the items in the center I would use m XX
auto text
XL flex Flex wrap and on medium devices
I'm going to go with flex no wrap so
flex no wrap here and after that we are
also going to use uh position the items
in
center and justify between so I'll zoom
out a bit so hopefully you can see the
entire class names uh styles that we
have applied here
and I'll Zoom back in okay so inside
this header tag we are going to have a
div okay two two sections actually sorry
about that we're going to have a div and
we're also going to have an on that list
so let's start with the div and this div
I'll give it a class name of flex give
it item center with full and medium
devices we won't take the full width
we're just going to take two3 of the
width like this all right and inside
this div we are going to have a link so
this is where we are going to have uh a
link that we pointing to our homepage so
this link component we are going to go
on and import it from next link okay and
for the h we are going to go to slash
which is our
homepage and for the class name I'll
give this a class name of font black and
also
um text let's see this um hex code this
color I provided this hex code before
now so F2
745 which is more like a an orange color
and here I'll just give you the name of
hotels like this okay so after this link
we are going to have an on that list
where we will have the icon to take us
to the authentication page and also
another icon
to tole the team so here I'll give this
another list a class name of flex item
Center and margin left of five for the
icons we are going to be using react
icons so mpm install react icons like
this I'll wait for it to install and
I'll restart the application so mpm run
Dev all right so let's use the before we
can apply the um icon we're actually
going to have a link
okay so this link will take us to the
user authentication page to the off page
and for the icon I'm just going to use
fa user ccle so fa user
CLE and for the h RI of this link I'll
just take this off yeah and for the h
this link is going to be pointing to
slash
off all right so let me import the
fle and let me uh give it a class name
so for the class name I'm just going to
give this a class name of C pointer so I
allow the IDE help me with this input
Noe it doesn't so I would have to import
it manually so let's
import buot the structure every us
Circle coming from react icons for/
FAA great and actually this link that we
have here we need to wrap it in the list
item so in an Ali and this Ali needs
some class names so I'm going to give
this uh class name of flex items Center
okay and then we're going to have
another list item and the idea is for
this other list item to hold the toggle
so it's for our lights and dark team so
I'll just give it a margin left of two
to um have some space from the user
Circle and for the icon I'll use this um
MD dark mode like this okay
okay and I'm just going to duplicate
this so that I will D structure this
coming from react icons MD okay for
material
design and also I'll give this a class
name so I'm going to give this icon a
class name of cross pointer
here all right and for these other list
items which would hold um links so I'll
just give this a class name of flex over
here also give it a class name of item
Center justify between give it a width
four and on medium devices I'll give
this a width of 1/3 1/3 and then imine
top of four and then we're going to have
list items and for this AI I'm also
going to give this um some animation on
Hover so I'm going to translate this uh
on the y axis so netive um 8 pixels and
I'm also going to give this an animation
duration of 500 and I'm going to
transition all like
this okay and inside this list item we
are going to have a link so we already
have this link component imported which
will go to home so the hre is going to
be pointing to
slash okay and I'll bring this down
let's say to more times we are going to
have that link going to um slash rooms
so we have this rooms here and the H
will be pointing to slash rooms and this
will just you go to the homepage is um
contact so just have the link contact we
don't have any contact page so we'll
just leave it to go back to the home
page like
this and we going to save this file and
then we can visit um the browser and I
just quickly reload our application so
that we can see our styling um take
change our changes take place already
yeah so we see our changes we see our
link and we see our different icons you
know and you see you see the animation
that we have on this
section okay so let's come back to the
IDE and I'll just remove this so that we
can take uh the full room and let's
configure Tailwind CSS so I would come
over to our Tailwind um config dots file
and I'm going to get rid of this um
background image we're not going to be
configuring the background image we are
going to configure first the different
colors that we'll be using in our
application okay so we're going to have
our primary color and our primary color
is going to be this hex code so
hash
038 um
c7f and this is our primary color and we
are also going to have our secondary
color okay and our secondary color is
going to be this um hex code so F2
[Music]
c641 and then we are going to have our
tary
color and our tary color we are going to
have different variants we're going to
have the dark variant and also the Light
variant and the dark variant is going to
be the um has code so F2
745 and the light variant is going to be
this hex code so F2 c64
one okay so these for our colors and
apart from the color we are also going
to be configuring our font family and
here we are going to use um Poppin
name and we have this array and this
variable has to match the variable we
Define in our layout. TSX okay so this
variable I'm going to copy it come to
our layout it has to match you know this
variable over here all right so come
back to the T config and we also need to
spread out the font family so I'm going
to import the Fone family using the
required statement so con Fone
family is equal to require and this will
come from telling CSS and default team
so here we are going to spread out the
fun family and access the sence
property great so we can come back to
our header.
TSX and where we made use of
the
um the shary color so I'm just going to
copy
this and if we come over to our header.
CSX I'll replace this so this this is
going to be you know text and now we can
use text T Shar DC and you see this U
yellowish color this icon or we can use
text tary light here we don't get the
icon that means there should be you know
a typo somewhere and we forgot to
actually add the hash here so add this
hash and there we see the preview great
but I will go back to the dark um
variant which we are using in this case
and we see
everything um works as
fine so up next after the header we are
going to be working on our footer
component so I'm going to create another
folder which I'll call footer and then
another file for our
footer.
TSX okay so I'll get rid of the header
and the telling
config so I'll bootstrap uh put
component and remove the react
input and rather than us a div I'm going
to make use of um the footer tag and let
me style this um footer give it the
class name and the class name is going
to be margin top
16 okay and here we are going to have a
div with the class name of container and
MX Auto
and for padding give it a padding of
four on the x axis and then we're going
to have a link which will import from
next link and this link will still take
us to the homepage so the hve is going
to be
slash and the class name is going to be
font
black and for the text we're going to go
with text tary D here and we'll just
have the makeup brand name
hotels and then we're going to have a
hphone a H4 that would say contact like
this and for the class name of this um
H4 I don't to give you the class name of
font let's see
font semi board and a text uh let's see
I'm actually looking for 40 pixels do we
have no so I'm going to use 40 PX like
this and pattern on the Y AIS of six
here okay so after this H4 we're going
to have a div and this div I'll give
with a class name of
flex and give it um Flex wrap and give
it a cap of
16 and position the items in center and
justify between as well and inside this
div we're going to have another div
which we are just going to give Flex one
with different paragraphs for this um
madeup address which I'll give one two
three Road and then we're going to have
this div with a class name of
flex and item Center give it a py of
four and this div is going to have this
icon so this icon BS f
um send VI okay and after the icon we
are going to have a
paragraph and this paragraph would have
a margin left of two and I'll just say
code with Larry here and quickly import
this BS send F BS F send F from react
icons for slbs
here okay so after
this I'm actually going to copy and
paste
this um two more times we're going to
have get rid of this
py4 and for the icon we are going to use
in this
case another icon which is BS t phone um
out Bond and I'll just have this made up
um phone number here
and after this we are going to have this
and we'll still keep the brand name code
with Larry but we are going to use uh a
different icon so here we're going to
use bi message detail and we need to
import this from react icons
forbi and I'll remove this BS send uh F
send
F okay and get rid of this um py rather
use a p um padding top of four so after
this div with this Flex one we're going
to have another
div and this other div we are still
going to give Flex one and we are going
to give uh from medium devices and above
we're going to position the text to the
right so align the text to the right and
we're going to have a pattern a
paragraph with a pattern bottom of for
and here we see our story and I'll just
bring it down and say get in touch and
next we're going to have
our um our privacy our privacy
commitment I'll bring this down and next
we're going to have our times of
service and I'll bring it down one last
time and here we are going to have uh
customer assistant without any class
name so this last one is not going to
have um any class name here great okay
so after this div we are going to have
another div which we're going to give a
class name of Flex
one and on medium devices and above
we're going to go with text right like
this and this div we have different um
paragraphs this paragraph we're going to
give a pattern bottom of four and we
just go with the text of dining
experience and next we're going to have
another text with
Wellness bring it down for fitness and
next we're going to have another with
spots and we're going to have another
one with events without any class
name okay so after this div we are going
to have another div this div actually is
going to be um a self closing div
because we're not going to have any
content inside it's just for styling so
I'll give this a background of
background tary light give this a height
of 10 and on medium devices and above
I'll give this a height of 70 pixels and
give it a margin to the top of 16 a
width
full and I'll give it a bottom of Zer
left of
Zer and we come over to the left layout
I'm just going to import the footer
component here okay so footer from our
component footer footer go and save this
file and we visit the browser we see our
footer over here and let's see if our
application is
responsive I just going to you know test
this out to see if it's responsive and
use the response
um points that we have here
and we don't see our text that's
because come over to our app and in our
page. TSX I'm going to get rid of
everything we have here okay so for now
I'll just return return empty fragment
with the text of home so I'll just type
home in
here and remove the input from next next
image and I'm also going to use an arrow
function so con home is going to be
equal to this AR function so I'm going
to save this and if we come back we have
an error because we are not exporting
this um home component actually we have
to export it by default so export
default home like
this and if we come back to the browser
we see our
application and let's test out the
responsiveness of the application and we
see that our application is um
responsive so we can just test this out
here and I would also love to you know
get rid of this background color that we
have here and to get rid of it let's
come over to our global. CSS and I'm
just going to remove these predefined
stylings that we got by default and yeah
we have our white background up next we
are going to be working on our teaming
feature so I'm just going to close
all and let's work on our teaming in the
source folder I'll create a new folder
I'll call
context and here I'm going to create a
new file for our team context so a file
call it team contact. TS and let's
import this patch from react
we're also going to import set State
action and we're also going to import
the create
context to create a context we're going
to have this constant over here and
we're going to call it team
context and this is going to be equal to
create context so to create a context we
make use of create context from react
and for typescript let's define the type
that we are going to need for our
context so the type for for our team
context type is going to be equal to
this object so we're going to have that
team which is going to be of type
bowling and we are also going to have
set duct team and set du team is going
to be of type dispatch so the type of
action we're going to dispatch is a set
State action which is of type bowling
okay and I'm going to pass this type to
create context we're going to have
errors because now we have to Define
some um um default values so for that
team by default is going to be false and
set that team the initial value is going
to be this function that returns nothing
all right so let's export our team
context so we're going to export default
this team context here so this is the
first step we create our
context and in the components folder I'm
going to create another folder which
I'll call
team provider so we're going to wrap
this team provider with our entire
application and here we have our team
provider. TSX so first I'll be making
use of the use client directive that we
get from
nextjs and I will import use effect and
I'll also import use state from
react and I would also import the team
context I actually want this to be
and ope T So rename it here and also
rename it in a team context file so this
I'll use an uppercase t here and also
export default team context like
this and then I'll come back to the team
provider okay so here let's have our
component jsx so I'm going to have this
Con team not context so team provide
then which is going to be equal to this
Arrow function here okay so for props
this is going to receive children and
the prop is going to be of type object
where we have
children and children is going to be of
type react do react node like
this okay so first we're going to have
this Con where we set our state so t
team
and set du team which is going to be
equal to UST
State like this and UST state is a
generic type that is going to hold a
bulling value and for the initial value
we're going to get this from local
storage so we can call this team from
local storage and first we need to check
that we have local storage so we're
going to check if type of local storage
is not equal to undefined okay so if
this is the case that local storage is
set then we are going to get an item
from local
storage and local storage dog item the
item we're going to get would have a
name of Hotel team so Hotel team like
this and we're going to check if we
successfully get an item so if we have a
value there then we are going to
Json do pass that value okay cuz it will
definitely be a string because we say
string in local storage so we're going
to pass json. get item Hotel team and
I'm just going to have this exclamation
sign here to tell typescript yes we are
sure we're going to have this otherwise
we are going to be using false okay so
if um local storage is defined we get
the hotel team and then we go to json.
pass and once we json. pass we if we get
it otherwise we use false so I'm going
to pass this team from local storage and
for typescript types this team. from
local storage is going to be of type
bowling and I'm going to pass this value
as our default value to use States
here okay so this is the first step in
achieving our teaming and after this we
are also going to go on and have our JSA
for our team context and in our team
context we access do provider okay and
for values remember our team context
will be holding a du te value which is
the value from our set State and set du
te which will be referencing this value
from our use States sorry and in here
we're going to have a div okay a div and
we have um some conditions for the class
name so we're going to be using uh uh
brackets and then back tick so we're
first of all going to check if D te so
if D te is true then T CSS gives us this
dark variant we're going to append it to
this dark variant otherwise we are just
going to use an empty string and then
we're going to give this a minimum
height of
screen so in here we're going to have
another div and this is the div where we
check if D te is true we going to use uh
apply some class names so here we're
going to check if we have dark team
we're going to give uh have a text white
and if we have dark team so we have this
dark variant we are going to give this a
background of black and for the text by
default it's going to be a black text
okay so for the white team case where we
don't have the black team so it's going
to be 1 e 1 e one e
and then in here we can just go on to
return children that we receive from the
props okay so this team provider let's
go on and Export this as a default so
export default team
provider and we're going to add another
state so we're going to have another
state here and we're going to call this
state um render component and this is
useful so that we know we have some
condition here for the class name so
that nextjs will be able to pick this up
on the client so we have render
component set render component is going
to be use state of
false okay and I'll just close this off
here and you're going to have our use
effect okay so in our use effect we are
sure that our component have been
mounted to the screen we are going to go
on to set um render component and set it
to tr
true okay so we're having this error
because we forgot to have our return
return statement so we're going to
return return this and back in our use
effect we're going to set render
component and set it to a value of true
like this so we can check over here if
our component is not yet rendered we are
going to go on end Reon and empty
fragment great so we have our team
provider now we are going to make use of
this team provider in our layout so come
over to the layout. TSX so in our app
and here where we have layout. TSX we
are going to wrap our entire application
with this uh Team provider so I'll cut
this and here we are going to have our
team
provider and we are going to return
return our main
tag okay so if we come over to the
browser we would expect everything to
work as know intended but actually it's
not going to work okay I'll just reload
the page and you know if we click on
this button you see nothing happens so
let's come back to our header because we
haven't weared up the event yet so in
our component header header.
TSX here we're going to be
importing um the D team and set that
team from our context and to make it of
our context we use the use context and
here we are going to make use of our
team context okay so I'll just bring
this down
here and we're going to D structure D
team and also set D team here great so
dark team we can use this um to
configure the icon we're going to show
so this icon here I'm going to cut this
icon and here how first of all check if
that te is
true so if dtim is true
here yep I have the question mark sign
so if that is true actually want to
return return a different icon so we are
going to go and and import this icon and
the icon is this
MD outline light like this so light mode
so I'll copy this and if do true I'm
going to paste this otherwise I'll use
this okay so we're actually going to use
this as a self closing tag like
this okay so next we're going to give
this
um class name of C pointer so I'll just
paste this class name over
here and next we need to wear up the
click events so on
click we're actually going to do two
things so have this callback function
you can Outsource it but I'll just write
it in line here so on click we're going
to first set um dark team to false and
we also want to go and remove the from
our local storage so we're going to
remove item from our local storage Hotel
team okay and I'll just copy this click
event here on the dark mode we are going
to do two things but this time around
we're going to set dark team to true and
rather than remove item
you are going to be setting item okay
and uh with this key of Hotel team and
the value will be true but not like this
as a string okay and to make our te
feature to work we just need to go on to
make this um header component uh use
client component because now we are
making use of context and not to have
errors and lastly in uh taing config we
just need to do one last thing so come
over to our um TN config dots and just
right above the content here we're going
to check Set Dark
mode yep so the dark mode we're going to
set it to value of class okay so now if
we come over to the
browser so I'll just come over to the
browser and if we click yep you see a
teaming feature works as
expected okay so up next if we click on
this icon here you see that we are
directed to SL off and for now this
leads us to a 404 page so let's work on
this page and in our app I'll create a
new folder which I'll call off and then
I'll create a file for page. TSX so in
here I'm quickly going to bootstrap this
component and I'll change from page to
off and remove the react in
and next I'm going to give this some
class names and I'm going to give it a
class name of container and then imagine
on the x axis of Auto and I'll change
this div to a section tag okay and in
here we are going to have a
div and this div is going to have uh a
class name of pattern
six and also a class name of space y4
and on medium devices this is going to
have uh space
Y6 and then on small devices is going to
have a padding of it like
this and we also going to give this a
width of 80 and on medium devices I'll
give this a width of
70% and make sure that I also go with MX
Auto so that the form is in the
center and then next we're going to have
a div and this div is going to have a
class name of flex a imin bottom of
eight give it Flex call and on medium
devices I'm going to give it a flex roll
items Center and justify
between and this div we are going to go
on to have a H1 now this H1 that just
going to say create an account and let's
start this H1 I'm going to give it a
class name of um text
XL and also font bold leading um tight
and also give it uh a tracking tight
like this and the medium devices I'll
give it a text of two
Excel now just after this H1 we are
going to have a paragraph which is going
to say
or and after this paragraph we're going
to have a
span and for the class names of the span
and we're going to give it a class name
of inline Flex item
Center and in this pan we're going to
have two icons first is this for GitHub
so AI feel GitHub and we're going to
give this a class name and the class
name of this is going to be uh margin to
the right of let's say three and then
I'll just give this a text of 4 XL and
the C of
pointer and then text um black like this
and then on dark mode we're going to
give it a white text so here we are
going to go on and have this pipe which
is going to differentiate it or separate
it from the Google icon so here we're
going to have this um FC Google with the
class names of um margin to the left so
margin to the left of three and also
give it a text of
4XL give it a c pointer
and next we can import these icons so
first I'm going to
import um this AI F GitHub which will
come from react icons for/ a and next
I'm going to import FC Google which will
come from react icons for
slfc all right so next we are going
to reload and if we check the browser
and you see that we have this um create
an account and we have everything
working as expected all right great so
after this div now we are going to be
having our form so our form but without
any action okay so I'm going to take the
action and provide it to the class name
and the class name is going to be let me
um see so the class name is going to be
space
y4 and on medium devices I'm going to
give this uh space Y6 like this and
inside this form we're going to have
different input so for the email
password and also for the name so this
input is going to be of type
email and then we are also going to give
this
um a name and the name is going to be
email and we're going to give it an ID
the ID is also going to be email and for
placeholder you can just go with name at
no company.com
and we are also going to make this
required like
this okay I think that will be all for
this um input okay so that would be all
and let's just style it for the class
name the class name is actually going to
reference a variable so we're going to
call this input styles and we can Define
this input styles here which is going to
be this constants so input styles is
going to be the string we are going to
go with border and also give it a border
gray of
300 and on small devices give it a text
SM and a text black like this and we're
going to give it rounded LG I'm just
going to fix this yep so rounded
LG and give it block and
also give it a width of
full um a padn 2.5 and on the focus
States I'm just going to take up the
outline by um saying outline none so
there will be no um outline on the focus
state so this input stes you can see the
complete um class names and that's the
input St we are passing to this input
over here all right so we're going to
have um more inputs so actually I'm just
going to you know copy this two more
times so we're going to use this for uh
password so that will be the type and
the name of this uh input field is going
to be
password the ID as well is going to be
password and for placeholder the
placeholder is also going to be password
so let's have um password here and for
validation apart from making it required
we're going to give it a minimum length
so this um password is going to have a
minimum length of
six like this and this is going to be
for the uh for the name so it's going to
be of type X so this other input over
here and the name is going to be name
for the username the ID is also going to
be um John do and for
placeholder so actually um the IDE is
going to be name okay and then
placeholder you can give it any
placeholder I'll just go with um John do
like
this and I will change the placement of
this input I'll cut this for the name
and just place it right above the email
like
this and if we reload the browser you
see we have uh different inputs and it
also works fine with our
teaming okay great so after this input
we are going to have a button to submit
the form so this button is going to be
of type submit like this and it's going
to um have the text of sign up okay and
let's style this button so I'm just
going to bring this um quot a single
quot back and for the class name of this
button this button is going to have um a
width of full like this and this button
is also going to have um a background
tary
deck and on the focus state so we're
going to give this button outline known
and also front media
rounded LG text SM and also pad to the
xais of five which I think is 20 and py
2.5 and also give it um the text of
Center like this so this is the class
name that we have on this button okay
and just after this button I think that
should be after this form we have
another button and this button is going
to have um a class name of text blue so
we're going to give it the class name of
text blue 700 and on the line and the
text should just say login like
this so we come back to the browser you
see that we have a form and everything
works fine with our team we can also
check the
responsiveness on how this form adjust
to the different um viewports okay so
everything seems to be working fine so
far and you see how the form adjust
great so next let's make sure that we
are able to retrieve the user inputs
from this form and at least log it to
the console for now so to en for us to
do this on the different input okay I'm
actually going to um let's
see uh I'm going to go and make this uh
a use client component because now we
are going to be managing State okay so
here we are just going to define a state
for the form data so we're going to have
const form data and then set form data
and this is going to be use State like
this and we're going to
Define um a default value so here I'm
going to have this con which I'll call
the default form data
which is going to be equal to this
object and the email is going to be an
empty string by default and also the
name is going to be an empty string and
then the password is also going to be an
empty string by default and I'll pass
this over to this um use State over here
great so next we can go to our different
inputs and wire up the value okay so we
can start with our email get rid of the
ID since we're using um name so I'll get
rid of the ID on all inputs and wire up
the value so the value for the email is
going to go to our form data. email and
I'll just copy this and use this for our
name so I'll change this from email to
form dat. name and also for the password
the password is going to be form data.
password you can also have an unchange
and on change we're going to call this
function which we have not defined yet
so handle input change
and I'll pass this function to other
inputs that we have sorry this unchange
and we can go up and Define this handle
input change function so somewhere
around here we're going to have this
const which we call handle input change
which is going to be this aror function
this function is going to automat
automatically get the event which is
going to be of type change event and
it's a generic type which is going to be
of type HTML inut M so here we're going
to destructure some properties from the
event Target so remember we have the
name so we're going to D structure name
and we're also going to D structure
value from event Target so with this we
can go on and update our form data so we
call set form data and this is an object
where we spread form data so just going
to spread form data and we're going to
use square bracket okay so that we can
dynamically update the name with the
value of the object great so this is our
handle input change and we can also um
Define our unsubmit function so our form
here we can Define our own submit and
this is going to be equal to a function
we don't have yet we call this function
handle submit so I'm going to copy this
and just after the handleing F change
say handle submit which is which is
going to be an asynchronous function we
get the event and this this time around
is going to be of type form event which
is a generic type and we said it's going
to be for HTML form element and then we
have our function declaration completed
the first thing we do we're going to
prevent default so event. prevent
default and then we can have our TR
catch block so this is going to be TR
catch and we can also have our finally
block just after the catch okay so for
the let's see so for the tribe block we
are going to go on and just log to the
console for now so we're going to
console.log um the different form data
that we have so cons. log form data
later on we are going to be obviously
submitting the form and in case of any
errors we are just going to log the
error to the console and finally we're
going to reset our form so we're going
to set form data to our default form
data okay so we have this and we're
going to save and let's try it out back
to the browser open the console let's
see if we're going to see the form
values for name I'll just go with the
name of uh for email sorry test test.com
for name I just go with name of test and
for password I'll just go with 1 2 3 4 5
6 click on submit and great we are
seeing our form details so we are
correctly retrieving our form details so
now we have this let's make sure that we
have um sanity studio in our project and
to integrate sanity studio in a project
first I'm going to quit the
terminal I'll clear and then I'm going
to open the Explorer here and the idea
is to move these different front end
files and folders into a separate folder
so I'm going to mark all actually first
I'm going to create the new folder which
I would call front end and then I'm
going to Mark and move move the folders
inside the front end folder and then
I'll get rid of the next folder this
folder is generated automatically for
caching purposes by nextjs then I'll
create a new folder called CMS and I'll
navigate into the CMS folder so CD CMS
and to integrate sanity studio in our
project it's important that we first log
out so MPX sanity at latest log
out and I'm going to chain on that
command and using mpm Create
sanity at latest like this all right so
this one word I'm just going to close
the Explorer and fix the typo I have
over here so it's meant to be one t so
MPX sanity at latest log out do go and
execute this command and let's keep an
eye on the CMS folder first the
C is going to install the packages and
then we are going to be signed out so
it's going to sign us out and we will'll
say okay to
proceed and we need to authenticate
ourselves let's give it a
second and to authenticate ourself you
can use the keyboard arrow keys to
navigate in this case I'll authenticate
with Google and this opened up on my
other screen so I'm just going to
authenticate myself over there and if
you had any previously existing projects
you would see them here I had one from
previously you can use the arrow keys to
navigate but in this case I'll be
creating a new project and give this a
name of hotel management like this and
go on to execute this
command all right so let's give it a
second and I would say yes to use the
name production so the names I ually
production or development for common
names and I would say okay for the
output path and for schema we're going
to start clean and then I say yes to use
typescript so this going to generate the
files and then we can use npm to install
the files that uh that get generated all
right so once this is installed we now
have sanity Studio here we can test it
by running npm run Dev so that we have a
local preview on Local Host
3333 so let's give it a second to build
yep so Local Host 3333 I'm just going to
visit this on the browser and this is
sanity studio so let's go on and
authenticate via Google and we are going
to give it a second for it to load and
this is our project now we don't have
any schemas we are going to be creating
schemas in the later up next we are
going to integrate this sanity studio in
our next project so that we use the same
common domain rather than use different
domains so CD out and then CD into the
front end and now I'm inside the front
end folder here so I am going to run the
command to install these packages so npm
install sanity and also next sanity like
this so to go on and install these
packages and we'll just wait for it to
install let's give it a second and once
it's um done installing next we are
going to come into our CMS and copy our
schema folder so I'm going to copy this
folder and paste it inside our front end
folder and come back to the CMS folder
we are going to copy the sanity config
dots file so I'll copy this and paste it
inside the front end here great so up
next we are going to go on now and if we
come
into
uh if we come into our sanity config in
here we going to see uh we need to add a
property and that property we need to
add is the base URL so just after this
um data set here I'm going to add this
base path and this base path I would go
to slash Studio okay so here/ studio so
this is going to be Local Host 3000 SL
Studio to load the sanity Studio we have
an error here because we need to install
this package so mpm install at sanity
for/ Vision so to go on and install this
package and the error should be
gone all right we are not done yet we
need to add the path in our Pages folder
so that this is going to be loaded up
when we go to localhost 3000 SL studio
so in the source folder and then inside
the app folder I'll create a new folder
and this folder I would call Studio like
this not with a square bracket so
studio and then inside the studio folder
I'm going to create a special folder
using double brackets like this and then
I'll spread out
index okay so once you create this
folder do go and create the page. TSX
file so I'll just expand this so you see
it fully is studio and then the square
brackets index and then page. TS so
we're going to use the use client
directive to make this a client
component and in here we are going to
also go on to import something which
will be coming from the next it package
that we installed and then for/ studio
and that is the package so the next
Studio package and with this package
imported we are also going to import
config and that is our sanity config so
this is going to be coming from we're
going to go one level
up and still go up again and go up and
lastly into our sanity config okay so
now we're going to Define our jsx we're
going to sport this as default and this
function we are going to call
Studio and here we are going to return
our next config like this which is going
to be a self closing tag and this is
going to take in the config and the
config is going to be our configuration
from our sanity
config now this is all we have to do
okay so let's start our application
running npm run
Dev and then we can see if we have set
it up correctly so I'll just wait for
this to
build and you can see our application is
done and we can visit Local Host 3000 so
we're no longer going to be going to
Local Host 3333 SL Studio we would go to
Local Host 3000 /
studio and it's compiling we can confirm
this if we go over to the IDE you can
see is compiling SL studio and then the
index and then the
page so we're going to wait for read to
compile we'll just um
wait so here in the IDE you can see is
compiling the page so it's done
compiling and this page should be loaded
up so now we can see our sanity studio
living in our next JS project on Local
Host 3 ,000 which is great okay and we
just wait for it to load up lastly we
can click on continue so that we can add
course so this is going to take us for
our project and all we have to do here
is to just add course origin and we are
redirected back to our application and
everything works fine great so we see
but you see we have our layout so we
have our header component and we have
our footer and that's because the studio
is sharing this same layout as our
entire application we can easily fix
this if we come into our app and we
create this folder so with parenthesis
CMS and another folder called studio now
this is Route grouping in nextjs it
doesn't affect the URL is used for
purposes like this where you want to
have different layouts so I move the
Earth folder inside the web move the
studio folder inside the CMS
folder and also I'm going to move
everything we have here so the five icon
and the homepage which is the page. TSX
I'll move it into the web like this and
we can go over to our
CMS and you see we automatically had a
layout. TSX so you can see it here in
green that your page will had um a root
layout so one root layout was created
for us by default which is this root
layout out um that was created by nextjs
so if we go back to application you see
that we don't have any root layout in
our studio and if we reload our next J
application to be sure everything is
still working fine over there we just
give it a second and we see that
everything still works as expected so
now we've done this we come over here
before we create our schemers so we can
actually delete this CMS folder we no
longer need it and I am also I also
going to now CD out of the front end and
actually move all these files so I'm
going to move them let's see actually
doesn't work like this so I am going to
again delete the cache so the next
folder and I'll just move this down so
I'll try to move it down here
and I'll move so we can go on to have
the setup we had initially and we can
even delete the front end
folder great so let's restart our
application using npm run
Dev all right so we just wait for
it okay seems it's um seems it's ready
so we can go back to and refresh our
application so we can reload the
studio and we see the studio loads up
fine no issues and we can also reload
our
nextjs application actually they are
both our nextjs application but we have
our studio leaving in our front end so
our nextjs application loads up as well
great so before we create our before we
create our schemas I would like to let's
see so before we create our schemas
which would leave inside this index if
we come over to our config so our sanity
config here I would like to move these
into environment variables and to move
this to environment variables I am going
to come over to root folder here and
I'll create a new file which which I'll
call
EnV and first let's get start with the
project ID I'm going to create this key
so nextore public uncore sanity uncore
projector ID equal to and I'll just
duplicate this and next I'll change
underscore project ID to be data set so
next public sanity data set for the
project ID we'll copy or cut this value
here here and I'll paste it in here and
for the data set which is production I
will also
cut and paste it in here so I'll copy
this value so in our sanity config we
can reference this value so project ID
is going to be equal to process. EnV do
this and then I'll say as string and
same for the data set so process. EnV
and then do I'll copy this from uh
EnV so data set and I am going to paste
it in here and say as
string great so now we have this you see
in the schema we have the schema types
which comes from our schema folder and
if we visit the index here you see here
we are going to be importing our schema
types but before we continue let's
verify our application works fine you
see it's crashed so I'll quit and
restart mpm runev that because we made
changes in our EnV and it's always a
nice practice to restart your server
whenever you make changes so once it
starts let's come here and reload both
the um our web and also our CMS and here
you see that it is you know actually
compiling our CMS Studio index page so
I'll just wait for this to compile
all right so it's building up the page
and once it's done we can go back to the
browser okay so it is done compiling and
here you see uh studio is loading
up and also our front end so our studio
is done and our front end is done and
everything works as fine great so now we
have this I actually close the terminal
here we can go on to PCD documentation
so here next up sanity which is the
library we are going to be making use of
so we're going to install this later and
here you see we're going to making use
of the um sanity
adapter and we have to create our sanity
schemas okay so this is one schema so
the user schema which is required or you
know if you go up you can see another
way but actually I going to Define my
own schema so that I can configure to
our needs and you see all these FS that
are required the password is only
required if you use credentials provider
which is our case in this project and we
also need to create an account
schema with all these fields and we also
need to create verification token
because we are using the email provider
and then we have ways to configure it so
let's come back to the IDE and let's get
started first we are going to create our
user schema so our user. TS file here
and this is going to be an object so
we're going to say con
user is going to be equal to this object
and let's not forget to export this
object as the default so export default
user so a user the way to go about it is
by giving it a name and this name is
going to be a string user this this name
is for queries and this title user is
for Stan studio and the type is going to
be a document type so the type of this
file is a document the schema and it's
going to take different fields so these
are the properties that we expect a user
to have and to define a field I'm going
to use this defined field which I'll
import from sanity so that we can get T
script autho completion and also correct
Direction so a user is going to have an
e admin property so that is the name of
this field so the name is going to be is
admin and the title for our Stan studio
is also going to be is admin and the
type is going to be bulying and we can
also give a description now this is
optional you can Define your schemas
Fields without adding description or you
can go on to define the description and
for initial value I would say false
because initially a user is not an admin
and this field is actually going to be
required so validation rule which is a
function where we going to return our
validation we're going to return row do
required like this which is a method so
you have to call required so this is one
field which our user is going to have we
can also make this read only so I'm
going to actually comment this out so if
you don't want this property to be able
to change in your sanity Studio you can
make it read only you can also make it
hidden so hidden true but I'll just
comment it out to let you know these
options exist so let's define another
field that the user would have the name
of this field is going to be name and
the title is going to be name okay so
user is going to have a name property
and the type of this is going to be
string which is needs to be string like
this and the user is also going to have
a description and this is going to you
know you can give this description the
name of the user it is not um required
so this description is just for your
sanity studio and I'll make this read
only so that we cannot change the name
of a user and we also going to define a
field for image
and the type here is going the title
sorry is going to be image and then we
are going to have the type so the type
is actually going to be uh URL for the
user image okay and then we are going to
Define another field for our user
property and the name of this field is
going to be uh password so user is going
to have a password and the type of this
is going to be of type
string and we are also going to go on to
make sure that this password is hidden
so that we cannot um see the password of
a user that's registered to in our
application and let's go on and Define
more Fields so we're going to Define
another field and the name of this field
is going to be about so a user is going
to have an
about and the title of this field is
going to be about like this and the type
because it's going to be a longer um
string we can say it's of type text okay
like
this okay so you see here we can also
add the description it is not um
mandatory and in other schema types I
may not even add this description field
you just see it in your sanity Studio
okay so this is just a brief uh
description about the user that's the
description I left here and I copy this
validation rule so that we can apply it
to other fields so I'll copy this and
apply it to a name so that a user will
always have a name and you can make all
Fields required if you wish
so let's import this schema in our
schema types like this and if we come
over to the browser to have a preview of
this you see that we have a user here
great which which is you know for now
there is no user and you can try to
create one but this should be created
whenever a new user
registered in our application so let's
go on and create another schema type and
the schema type we are going to be
creating this time around is for account
we saw this from the documentation is
actually mandatory we create this so we
have const
account and we can already export this
as the default so export default account
and the name is going to be account like
this and the title is also going to be
account and then the type of this is
going to be a document so we're going to
give this a type of
document and then we are going to go on
to give this the different fields that
the account is going to have so I'm
going to make use of the defined field
function from sanity and the name of one
field we are going to have is the
provider type okay so an account is
going to have the provider type because
we are going to be using different
providers GitHub provider and Google
provider even credentials
provider okay so we are going to have
another um field which is going to be
provider id and this is going to be
provide uh provider account ID and this
over here is going to be the refresh
token and I'm going to just go on to
duplicate this and the next field user
is going to have is the assess
token like this and lastly the next
field the user is going to have is the
assess token expired expires and this is
going to be of type
number okay and we can go on to Define
one more field and this field let's just
give this field a name and the name of
this field is going to be user so that
we can have a reference to the user
schema and the title is going to be user
the type is going to be of type
reference like this okay and then it
needs to point to the user so reference
to and then we're going to have the type
the type is going to be user like this
so this is the accounts and we are going
to import this inside of our schema
types so our accounts will come from our
do/ account okay and let's create on the
schema and this schema type is going to
be book booking because we are going to
be booking hotels and we want to have a
booking type okay so the concept booking
is going to be equal to object and we
can already export this as the
default so the name of this is going to
be
booking and also the title of this is
going to be equal to
booking and then we have the type which
is going to be of type
document and now let's go on to describe
the different fields that uh booking is
going to have in our application so we
use the defined field method and this U
the the name of one field the booking is
going to have is user and then the title
also is going to be user the type is
going to be
reference and then we need to add two so
that this reference points to the user
schema okay so two is an array of
objects where it takes the type and the
type is going to be user so a booking
will also the user would also have this
validation where we say the rule and
here we say it is actually required like
this so we're going to Define another
field so Define field like this and the
name of this field is going to be hotel
room so I'm actually going to cut this
and then add the name hotel room like
this and also the title so the title is
going to be equal to hotel
room and the type of this is going to be
a reference
type and which is going to be pointing
to the hotel room schema and we haven't
created this um schema type yet it's
okay we are going to be um creating this
type type soon so we have an error and
that's um let's see we'll come back to
it for validation we just going to say
this is required okay so Rule and here
we say ru. required like this so let's
inspect our error and let's see yeah so
that's because it's meant to be an
object so I'm going to cut this and put
it in an object like
this cool so let's duplicate this type
and the next type you're going to have
is for our checking
date and the title is going to be
checking date because the booking we
want to keep track of when the user
checks in and also when the user is
going to check out and the type of this
is going to be a type of date okay and
I'm going to duplicate this for our
checkout date so rather than checking
this time around a checkout date and the
title is also going to be checkout date
and every other property Remains the
Same so apart from checkout date uh
booking is also going to have the number
of um days so the number of days we
expect the user to book this room and
the title is also going to be number of
days and the type is going to be of type
number and the initial value is going to
be one so once you create a booking
you're going to have number of days
which is minimum one and we we can
change that mean here to be one like
this and I'll duplicate this and here we
can go on to add the discount so in case
um a user booked a room that had a
discount okay so this is going to be a
title discount type number initial value
zero and minimum zero like this and I'll
just bring this down again and we're
going to have another field to keep
track of the number of adults so the
title is going to be adults the name
adults initial value is one and the
minimum value is one for creating a
booking okay and apart from adults we
also need to keep track of the children
and the title is going to be children
type um number initial value zero the
minimum also zero like
this and let's um duplicate this and
another field we want to keep track of
is the total price so the name is total
price the value is total price and the
type remains of type number no initial
value great so I'll zoom out a bit so
that we can see the different fields
here so for a booking
hope and if you need more clarification
please do make reference to the GitHub
repo okay so in case you made a mistake
please do reference the GitHub and here
in index I'm going to import the
booking okay so let's go on and create
uh more schemers and the schema we're
going to create is a hotel room now this
is actually you know going to take a lot
of schema so I ADV again that you go to
the GitHub in case you know to just make
sure everything works fine and the title
of this hotel room is going to be hotel
room and the type is also going to be of
type document and then we can have the
different fields okay so to get that
script Auto completion I would make use
of this defined field from sanity
okay so let's uh a hotel room we
definitely have a name so the name is
name and the title is equal to title and
the type of this hotel U the name sorry
is going to be of type
string and also for validation you can
have more you know validation that than
we have seen so far so we have a
validation room and here we can go on to
say that this is required and we can
also go on to say that this should have
um a maximum of let's just say 50
characters like
this and while we having an
error um actually let's see why we have
okay yeah so we forgot to call the
required like this so we have to call
required and then we can go on to add
our own custom error so like this and
here we we can just go on to write any
error message that we want to see in our
sanity studio so maximum 50 characters
okay so we have more Fields um for the
hotel room so hotel room will will also
have a
slug and this doesn't actually no it
doesn't have a title so I'll take this
off and the type is going to be of type
Slug and I will take off this um other
validation Rule and we can have options
so for slog and options is an
object okay so options is an object
where we can specify this source so this
uh slug we want the source to be from
the name field which we defined um above
okay so let's define another
field for our hotel room and a we have a
description and the title is going to be
equal to
description and the type of this is
going to be text because it's going to
be u a much more longer
um string and here we have this
validation where we can make use of 100
characters 100 but rather than maximum
you can SC with mean and update text to
minimum 100
characters for the description so let's
copy this here and Define another field
for the price and the title is going to
be price the type is going to be of type
number and this is going to have a
minimum of 100 so maybe 100 USD for our
price everything Remains the Same and
next we have a discount so that we can
leave discounts on our various hotel
rooms so the type is going to be number
and the minimum this time around so
we're going to have row. mean the
minimum is zero so zero like
this okay and we can also add add an
initial value of zero so by default um a
hotel room doesn't have a discount so
the discount is zero
and let's continue let's define more
Fields so we're going to have this field
for images and the title is going to be
equal to images okay so the type this
time around is going to differ it's
going to be an array type and next we
are going to have an array of what so
it's an array again where we have an
object here we can customize the type
and say the type is going to be object
like this okay and we have Fields
actually this Fields needs to be defined
inside this subject so erase it and come
inside this object and Define the fields
great so it's going to have fields which
is an array we can pass the name and
here the name needs to be in an object
like this yep so we have the name which
is going to be URL and we can also pass
a type the type is going to be of type
URL as well and then we can pass the
title the title is also going to be
URL great so I'm actually going to copy
this object we have in here and I'll
duplicate it this time around for file
so the name is going to be file the type
also is going to be file the title is
going to be file like
this we can also add validation rule to
this um images which is an array so we
have our rule function and here we are
going to return return Ru do
required okay and we can also go to um
add a mean of three and also a costume
error so this is an array that means it
needs to be an array of minimum length
of three okay so minimum of three so
minimum of three images requ ired like
this and then we can go on to Define
more fields for our hotel room
okay so let's add more the name of this
field is going to be equal to the um
cover image like this and the title is
also going to be equal to cover
image and the type is going to be of
type
object and next we have the field
because it's an object so it's an array
where we have the name and the name is
going to be URL and the type is also
going to be URL like this and then we
have the title and the title is going to
be URL so I'm just going to duplicate
this where we are going to have the
name
so the name here and the name is going
to be file and the type is going to be
file as
well and for the title we will also give
it a title of
file okay so let's add more uh let's add
a validation before we continue and
let's just go on to say that this cover
image is required so we can have our
rule
and we are going to return our rule here
and just say it's
required and then let's not forget to
call and also add our error we have our
message and say cover image is required
here next we're going to Define another
field okay and this is an object so we
have to add an object we have a name and
the name of this field is going to be
type
and the title is also going to be room
type but now just fix this typo in
here like this and now we're going to
have the type the type is going to be of
type string okay but when it comes to
options we need to Define these options
because now we have list we're going to
define the list up here okay so let's
define the list by having this constant
what that we call room
types which is going to be equal to an
array okay for title we're going to have
our first room type which is going to be
basic and then the value is going to be
basic with a lower case b so
basic like this and this has to be in an
object so cut and wrap it around an
object and then I'll bring this down two
more times and the next type we're going
to have is
luxury for the
title and also for the value but with a
lower case
L and the next is suit and the value is
also going to be suit like this so we
can pass the um room types as a value to
this list over here so we're going to
have a list and for validation we can
have a validation ru
rule so we have our function and here we
are going to Reon our Ru that makes this
required we can also add an initial
value so the initial value is going to
be basic so when we create a room it's
going to be a basic room by default so
I'll duplicate
this and the next type um is going to be
special notes that is the next field
sorry and the title is going to be shall
note the type is going to be of type
text I'll get rid of the
options and for initial value I'll just
paste in this text over here not room
types just paste in this text and zoom
out so it just um a normal string you
know just giving the user some
information so this is the initial value
and it is also um required so that's not
all for the hotel room we still have
more fields and the next field is going
to have the name of Dimension this field
is not going to be required the title is
going to be
Dimension and the type of this is going
to be of type string so it's not going
to be required and this configuration is
actually okay for the dimension and
let's define more Fields the next field
is going to be number of um
beds and the title is going to be number
of
bread the type is going to be of type
number and here next we are going to let
me just fix this up our validation where
we have our validation Rule and we are
going to return return a rule that makes
this um required and have a minimum of
one okay we can also give it an initial
value in that case and give it an
initial value of one as
well and let's define more Fields the
hotel room is going to go to have uh an
offered
amenities like
this and the
title is going to be equal to offer
amenities and now let's have the type
the type is going to be equal to where
is it it's going to be of type
array and next we're going to have an
array off so we're going to have the off
value which is also an array and we can
configure it with this OB U object so
the type is going to be
object and then it's also going to have
the different
fields okay so the field is an array and
we can also give it a
name and the name is going to be icon so
we intend to use Font aome icon so that
we can integrate this seamlessly in our
front end we'll get to that when we
start fetching data and when we start
creating a room so this is going to have
another object and the name this time
around is going to be the
amenity okay no worries we will see how
this works and this is going to have a
title of
amenity and it's also going to have a
type and the type is going to be you
know of type string
here I'm not actually going to copy that
we are going to Define another field for
our hotel room and the next field for
our hotel room is to find out if the
auor room is booked and the title is
going to be is booked like this
the type is going to be of type
bowling and we're going to have an
initial value of false because initially
this room is not booked so I'll bring
this down I think two more times where
we have the next one is
featured so the name of this field is
going to be featured and the title is
also going to be is featured and every
other values can remain the same so next
we're going to have reviews because
a hotel room is going to have
reviews and the title is going to be
reviews the type is not going to be
bullying the type is going to be of type
array and we are going to configure so
we're going to have an array of words so
I'm going to fix this typo here and it's
going to be an array of type review so
of type our review schema which we have
not defined yet so let's put this hotel
room schema in our index here actually
we need to export it first so let's
export default uh hotel room like this
and now we can import it in our
index.ts so let's take one last look of
the hotel schema in case you missed
anything please do refer to the GitHub
where you would see um the code which we
just wrote out together
okay so this is the hotel schema let's
create more
schemas the next schema we're going to
have is going to be a review schema okay
so it's going to be pretty much
straightforward so we have con review
the name here is going to be a name of
review title is going to be review and
the type is going to be of type document
docment like this and then we have the
different fields for our review so this
review needs to be linked to a hotel
room and also to a user so one field we
are going to have is the name user and
also
the the title is going to be equal to
user and the type is going to be of type
reference we are not getting Auto
completion so I'm going to cut this
object and make sure that I have it in
the
defined um the defined field method that
comes from sanity then I'll past in this
field and we have this error already
because a reference type needs to point
to a document so we're going to have
this two and this two is going to be an
array and this array of object here I
will say the type is is going to be type
user can have a validation room and here
we are just going to receive our
validation Rule and return return not
here so we're going to return return the
rule that make sure that this field is
required like
this so let's copy and paste it because
next looks similar because next is also
going to be a reference type that will
be pointing to the hotel room and the
title is going to be hotel room the type
is um reference the type here is going
to be hotel room like this and then our
review just has um some more couple of
fields so let's bring this down two more
times and this is going to have a name
of text which is the actual review text
and the title is going to be review text
the type is going to be text
and the type here is sorry going to be
reference and the type here sorry I'm
just going to R this to text and get rid
of this to here great so that fixes it
and next is the user rating so this is
the user rating which should be between
1 to five the title is going to be user
rating the type is going to be of type
number and I'll get rid of this two and
apart from required I'm going to chain
mean it's going to have a minimum of one
and also a maximum of
five and we can just have our costume
eror so we just telling the user rating
must be between not a so rating must be
between one and
five so this is our review schema let's
not forget to export this as a default
so export default
review and we can already import this
inside of our schema types so I'm just
going to remove every other tabes that
we have open and save this we are not
done creating our schema actually we
have one last schema to create and this
is our
verification um token so this is the
last schema we will be creating and this
is because we are making of the email
provider so we have this con which is
going to be we call verification token
and let's not forget to export this
already so the verification token schema
is going to be um pretty much
straightforward okay and this
verification is going verification token
is going to have a name of verification
token like
this and next is also going to have a
title and the title is going to be equal
to verification
token okay and the type is going to be
of type document okay like this and now
let's have the different fields so field
is an array we're going to use our
defined Fields method and one field we
are going to have is going to have the
name of identifier so it token is going
to have the name of identifier and the
title is is going to be equal to
identifier like
this and the type is going to be of type
string and I'll just bring this down two
more times and next we are going to have
a token so a sply token and the title is
going to be equal to token and the type
remains string and the next is expires
and the title is going to be expires and
the type is going to be date time like
this and this is for our verification
token so pretty straightforward and I'll
fix this typo over here should be
verification token like this and this is
our verification token schema so we can
import it inside of our index. TS so
verification token and that's it for
creating our schema pretty intense you
can verify in the GitHub and we miss our
verification token here so let's see the
type if it's actually of type
document yeah it's of type document so
let's come back to the
browser and we see our verification
token so everything is fine pretty
intense if you missed any please do
check the GitHub now we can proceed with
our
authentication using next off so get
started with next off here we are in the
documentation and we see the command to
install next or
sanity but let's scroll further down to
the example usage so here you see to use
the GitHub provider you need the GitHub
client ID and the client secret so what
you do next you come over to your GitHub
profile and click on your profile Avatar
over here and you click on
settings so once here you can click on
developer settings and then click on or
apps you create a new app I had an app
from previous and you could give this um
application name hotel management and
the homepage URL we can take this from
our application and paste it in
here and same for the authorization
callback URL so Local Host 3,000 and
register
application so here we have our client
ID I'm going to copy our client ID and
come over to the IDE and in our EnV I'll
create a new key which I'll call GitHub
uncore client _
ID and also create um GitHub client
secret so GitHub uncore client andore
Secret
secret and we can get this from our repo
so here we are going to generate a new
client secret and you provide your
password and then you click on
confirm so now you have the client
secret you can copy and before you go
back to the uh IDE click on update
application and next you can now P this
in the IDE over here okay so we also
need our Google client ID and our Google
client secret so here we going to say
Google client ID and equal to then we
can also type our Google
clients
secret so let's go over for our Google
client ID so come over to
cloud.google.com
and go over to the
console
okay so let's wait for this to load
up and you would have to agree to the
times of service and click on agree and
continue okay so come over to this tab
here where we have this drop down to
select the
project and we're going to click on new
project
so you can give this project a name I'm
going to give this um project a name of
hotel management like this and click on
create okay to create this new
application so take note of this Bell
icon here so once the application is
created we are going to be notified yep
it's done and you can select the project
now we in the project dashboard let's
create our a AP keys so to do that you
can come over to apis and services and
here click on all off consent
screen yeah so we click on off consent
screen and it brings us to this um
dashboard we'll just wait for it to load
up and here for the user type please
select external so that is available for
anyone with a Google account and click
on create
and we need to give this application a
name I would also give it the name of
hotel management and this name is a name
that is going to be visible on the um UI
when Google is asking the user to
authenticate so this could be your brand
name and give the supports email and
come down
here and for developer address I will
also go on to provide um the same email
address over here so bright 2 which is
the email address for this project sorry
the Google account I created for this
project so P Library 2 and click on Save
and continue so the next step is copes
we can actually skip this so just say
save and continue for test users we
would also say save and continue and
here you can see the summary of the
information you
provided okay so this is the the summary
and for us to proceed you can now come
over to
credentials and here in credentials tab
you just click on create credentials and
you choose all of client
ID and for application type we'll choose
web application you can leave every
other thing
here and then we come down here we are
going to click cck on ADD URI for
authorized redirect
URI and this URI is going to be HTTP
colum for/ localhost colum and then here
we have 3,000 for/ API for/ off for/
callback for/ Google like
this and you can okay I'll just delete
this water one here so that's the
URI and then once you have this URI you
can come down and click on
create so this has been created we have
our client ID I'll copy this client ID
and P this in the IDE and go over to
copy our client secret so this client
secret and I'll paste it in here as
well and I'll just say okay over here so
this is all we need at least to get
started with uh authentication Google
and
GitHub okay so now we have all of this
we can come over to next sanity and copy
this installation command open our
terminal and I'm going to create our
terminal and paste this in here so mpm
install next off sanity and we also need
to install another package which is the
next off package like this please do go
on and install these packages
and I'll just wait for it to install and
once installation is completed we are
going to start our development server
with npm run
Dev okay so in our source
folder here in our source folder we are
going to create an API folder which is a
special folder in
nextjs and here we're going to create an
off and inside the off we are going to
create this special folder with next off
like this and here we are going to
create a route.
TSX sorry a route. TS so here it is API
off next off and route. TS you can also
see it over here okay and to create this
we need to import the next off not from
next off off so next off is just going
to come from next off like
this and here we are going to create our
Handler so we say con Handler is going
to be equal to next off so I will remove
this inputs we have here and make this
to be an uppercase
n and we call this and you see it takes
in some options we don't have yet and
let's go on and Export this already so
we export this as an object like this so
we export Handler as get it all has to
be open case and we'll also export
Handler as post like this and we need to
provide the options for this we are
going to create a new folder in our
source folder which will call lebs for
library and here we are going to create
our off. TS
file okay and this off. TS file we can
go on and export ort this constant which
will call off options off options is
going to be of type next off
options which needs to be imported from
next off and equal to this object so we
can already import this other options
inside of this uh route Handler
here and I'll just rearrange the
order so now we have this let's have our
options defined in here so the first
options we are going to provide is the
providers which is an array and for
GitHub we are going to have our
GitHub provider like this which we need
to import okay so this GitHub
provider we are going to import this um
GitHub provider coming from next
off so next off for slash providers and
for Slash GitHub okay and we can already
import the Google provider coming from
providers for/ Google and we're going to
change the name here to Google
provider so this GitHub provider as we
saw documentation it takes in the client
ID and this is going to come from our
process.
EnV and then do um let's go back to our
NV file and copy this key so GitHub
client
ID and you say as string to avoid any
errors and then for the client secret it
will also be coming from our process EnV
and then do we copy this GitHub client
secret
key and we use it in here and we say as
string like this
okay so now we have this we have this
error so I'm just going to fix this typo
here it should be string like this and
next we can have our Google provider so
I'll duplicate this and I'm going to use
actually copy this Google provider and
use here so I'll copy the client ID from
EnV and replace this as well as the
client
secret so place this value over here
okay so after this we also need to go on
and provide
the
not this so we're going to provide the
sanity credentials which needs to be
imported from next of Sanity like
this and this sanity credentials is
going to take the client so we don't
have the client yet we are going to
create the client in a second and here
the session is an object and we say the
strategy is
JWT like
this okay so the next configuration is
the adapter and the adapter we're going
to be using is going to be our sanity
adapter which also needs to be imported
from next of sanity and we call this and
it also needs a client we are going to
provide the client in a second and next
we want to get useful the buug consoles
so here we're going to set this only if
not EnV is equal to development so that
means the bug is going to be true in
that case and for the secret we can
Define this in our process. EnV so here
in our EMV file we're going to call this
next oore
secret and I'll just go in um word
secrets you provide um much more hard
word to guessing in your case and this
secret would be coming from our
process.env and then with this next of
secret
key and we also need to provide more
configuration for now the Callback I
will just leave this empty object we are
going to revisit this callback so let's
create our um let's create our
credentials our sanity client to pass to
our sanity
credentials and to do this still in our
lips folder I'm going to create a new
file and this new file I would call
sanity Dots
here and let's go on and import the
create client method which comes from
next sanity here and we can have our
sanity client variable which is going to
be equal to this create
client and this needs the project ID
which we are going to get from our
process
and it also needs the data set we will
come back to these and it also needs
this use CDN all right so this ucn we
are going to set it to be true only if
we are in production so if process. env.
notore EMV is equal to production like
this okay and next we need to pass the
token and for the token let's do that
later and next we need to pass the API
version and the API version is going to
be
2021 iPhone 10 iPhone 21 like this so
for the project ID we can copy this from
uh EnV so next off sanity project ID so
project. EnV and I'll P this key same
for our data set which also be coming
from our process.
EnV next public sanity data set and for
the token we can come to our application
and here I'll just click on this Avatar
and go over to manage
project okay so now we are here we just
wait for this to load up you can come
over to the API section so click on the
API section and click on token and we're
going to click on ADD API token and we
can give this API token and name we see
some example names that we have up here
and I'm just going to give this a name
of read and write assess like
this and I think we can space this okay
read and WR access and most importantly
you should make this editor like this so
click on this checkbox and you see you
need to have read and right access to
our
database our data set so I'm going to
copy this
token and come back to the ID here come
to the EnV and I'll create a new EnV key
for this
token and this I'm going to call
sanity like this underscore Studio
underscore
token and then I'm going to paste in
this our token and copy
this and come over to our sanity TS and
the token is going to be coming from our
process EnV and then sanity Studio token
like this
let's export our sanity client so we're
going to export this as a default
export so we can pass our San client to
the San credentials and San adapter and
I will let the IDE import this from our
sanity
file okay so this is what we have going
in our off. TS file over
here so these are the
settings and now we are done with this I
will just close all these tabs that we
have here and we can come over to our
components and in here I'm going to
create an O provider so that we can
provide this to our component so we have
our off
provider.
TSX and I can already make this uh
client component making of This use
client
directive and next I'm going to import
session Provider from next o
react and this is the jsx so I'll call
this next o
provider and this is going to be equal
to this aror function and we're going to
receive props so Props is an object
where we dist structure children and we
say this is going to be of type um props
and we can Define the props up here so
type props is going to be equal to this
object where we take children and
children is going to be of type react.
react node like this and come down here
we can have our return return where we
return return the session
provider and in here we are just going
to wrap it with this children that we
get from our props like this so we have
this provider we need to make use of it
in our layout
okay so come over to the app and in here
to the web and in here to the layout.
TSX
and I'm just going to
cut and wrap everything with our next o
provider which needs to be imported from
our components Earth provider and Earth
provider so this import over here so
everything is
fine um for now and now we have this we
can go on and come over to uh o and then
uh sign up our page so I come back to
our app and here our Earth page. TSS and
this is the handle submit
function first I'm going to quit our
terminal I'm going to restart our server
okay so before we actually continue this
page we are going to be sending some
toast
notification so for that I'll come over
to our components and create a new
folder which I'll call Toast TSX
toast and create a new file which I'll
call toast. TSX so in here we are going
to import the react hot toast package so
mpm install react hyphone hot hyphone
toast like this and I'm going to make
this a client component making use of
the use client directive and then I'm
going to import toaster which comes from
react hot toast
so this is pretty straightforward we are
just going to have this toast GSX and
here we are going to Reon toaster like
this and we're going to export default
toast now to make use of this Library we
are going to first restart our
development server and then come back to
our layout where we import this um toast
so
here come over to the web and in the
layout. TSX so just right above the main
I'm going to import to that will come
from our components toast SL toast and
this file this component
here okay so now in the page. TSX I'm
just going to make sure that you know we
are still getting our console.log so
here I'm just going to open up the
terminal and here I'll visit the off
page so I'll click on this Avatar and
this is going to take us to the
authentication page and I don't see the
bother around the input and to fix that
I'm just going to Y have this hphone
here and I'm just going to reload the
page okay so that's we see our
changes
and once it reloads we get an error
actually so if we see this error is
because we have uh you see we have this
uh where is it so you see Local Host
3000 API off is not found and if we come
back to the IDE that means our API
folder is outside of our app folder okay
so you see our API folder actually this
folder needs to be inside of our app
folder and that's why we get this error
message that this F for that that page
canot be found okay and to fix this
error we are just going to drag the API
folder inside the app folder like this
we're going to move it and this is the
API folder actually inside the app
folder okay so inside the app folder
like this and if we come back to the
browser and just reload this
page now we don't get any errors so
let's be sure that we are getting the
values to the console so I'll just give
it a name of test and give the password
of one to six click on sign up and yep
we are still retrieving so now let's
work on this form
submission and the first thing I'm going
to do actually really rather than have
this log to the console let's come here
and have this
user user we are going to await sign up
and sign up needs to be
imported so import sign up from next of
Sanity for slash like this
client so let's also import uh um sign
in like this and also the use session
hook and this will be coming from next
off react so we're going to import this
from next off for slash react like
this and then we can come down here and
call this sign up method and pass our
form data which we just saw on the
console not quite long and here we're
going to check if we have a
user like this then we are going to send
a toast notification to the user using
toast do success where we just go with
the text of
sign success and then tell the user to
please sign in this is actually going to
fail so by want us to say this error
because we have not yet implemented one
route Handler so we're not going to see
the success over here in the conso log
error we are going to set the error and
let's to. error and say something went
wrong so it's actually going to fail but
I would like us to see it because we
need to implement one last
route and if we come over to the
browser I'm just going to provide an
email so test at test.com and uh
username is going to be test and the
password is going to be one to6 so we
click on sign up yep so we see our
error and let's inspect this here you
see that we get this 404 not found so/
API SL sanity SL signup we don't have
this API route implemented and that's
why we get this error so next Earth
sanity
actually makes needs this API route so
so inside of the API folder here we are
going to create a new folder and this
folder would call sanity so this sanity
needs to be directly inside the API
folder like
this okay so inside here we are going to
create a sign up
folder and in here a sign up route so
for request coming to/ API SL sanity SL
signup okay so here we're going to
import the sign up
Handler and this sign up Handler needs
to be coming from next Earth sanity and
next we're going to export our post
Handler so we're going to say export con
post and this is going to be equal to
sign up Handler like this and we're
going to pass our sanity client okay so
go on and save this file and actually
this is all we need to do now for this
to work so I will reload our
browser and here for the email let's go
again let's give there an email of test
at
test.com and for the name I'll just go
to the name of test and provide the
password of one to six so click on sign
up and if sign up is successful yep we
see success please sign in and if we
come over to our sanity Studio we see
the user here so this test user we just
created and with those with these
details so wait for this to
load so we'll just give it a
second and it actually crashes okay so
nothing wrong here we are just going to
inspect the terminal we see the terminal
is fine we're just going to reload this
um our studio okay we made changes to it
and we haven't refreshed the studio in a
while
now so once the studio reloads you'll
see that everything actually works fine
okay and this is the user we just
created so with this name with this
image and we don't actually get the
field email defined in our
schema so let's visit our schema perhaps
we missed out the user
email so here inside of our schemas and
go over to user.
TS Let's see we actually missed the user
email and know if it's also verified so
the verified field so just after uh I'm
going to create the email field and I'll
Define this field just after our
password so here Define
field and the name of this field is
going to be
email so the name is going to be email
and the type is also going to be
email
and then
the
title the title is going to be email and
the type actually is going to be string
so not email so the type is going to be
string and I'll just duplicate this so
that we know if the email is verified so
here we're going to have email
verified the type is going to be date
time
and it's actually not going to have a
title because we are going to set this
property as hidden so hidden through
like this so let's come back to the
browser and I'll just reload our sanity
Studio to pick up the latest schema
changes and now everything works as fine
so you see we cannot type inside the to
change the email the name and I'll just
make this admin to be true and publish
it was actually
published um when we created a user so
let's try um let's go back to the IDE
and in the ID we are going to have all
our login provider so somewhere here we
have this signning imported already and
this use session okay so let's get the
data from our use session so we're going
to D structure data and rame it to
session coming from the use session hook
and in here I would like us to
console.log the
session okay so I want to do this so
that we can see how the session object
changes as we log the user in so here
we're going to have this login Handler
which is going to be an async function
like this and we're going to have our
try catch block so in case of Errors we
are going to log the error to the
console so we're going to console. log
error and next we're going to have this
to. error and then we say something went
wrong like this and in the tri block we
are just going to await the sign in like
this without passing any provider here
okay and once we sign in upon successful
signning we want to go on and push the
user to the homepage so here I'll just
leave a comment and say push the user to
the homepage I want do this now so that
we can see this uh console.log and the
sign in the login Handler I'm going to
pass it to the GitHub
icon and I'll just copy this click on
click here and pass this also to the
Google and also pass this to our login
button which is this button over
here so let's save this and let's go on
to try this out and we we expect to see
our session and how our session updates
so here I'll just close
this and you see we see a bunch of null
I'll just reload the
application and now we have application
reloaded let's try to to sign in the
user so click on
login and I'm going to log in with um
credentials we already have the GitHub
and Google wired up but first let's try
to sign in with this user that we just
created and once we click on signing
with credentials let's keep an eye on
this console and you see how we get the
user object so this is our session
object so we have our user email and our
us user name so let's try to
authenticate via
Google I'll just clear this and now
click on the Google
icon and we're going to click on sign
with Google
here and I'm going to choose my email
address okay so let's keep an eye on the
console
and over here you see we still get our
user from our session object and if we
come over to
the um our studio I'll just reload
because we still see the test
user and actually we still see the test
user because we we don't have any
functionality to sign out yet so we have
to just do this manually and but you
come over to the account so if you just
come over to the account you see we have
a new property o and you see the
provider id is Google and we see all
these properties but the user is still
the test user because we we didn't sign
out that user okay so we still use um
the same credentials as
before but we see everything here so
what I'm going to do actually I'm going
to manually sign out by deleting the
this um property we have
here and come back to the user I'm
actually going to delete uh this user as
well so just come here and delete this
user okay so come back to application I
would come over to the application tab
so that I just clear all
the um storage that we cut from next off
so clear the local storage
and also clear the session storage in
case we have any um things St there and
come back to cookies and I'll also clear
the
cookies okay so now let's try this out
I'll reload the our application and then
I'll click
on GitHub let's try sending in with
GitHub and here I'll just click on
authorize myself
and if this is successful we should be
redirected back to our application so
let's wait for
this and we are redirected back to our
application and we see that we get our
user and this time around you see the
name ofd to my user name and I'll just
make this user me to be null we see the
image we see the email and I'll publish
so if you come over to the accounts
again you see we have o off and we still
have our users so everything is working
fine so we can click on the back to our
application and I'm just going to sign
out again
manually I'll clear all the storage that
we have
and reload our application come back
here and I'll delete this user so that
we can try our Google
authentication so delete anyway and is
not successful because first this o we
need to delete it so you see here this
GitHub o we are just going to delete and
now delete the user as well
all right so next we can now try to sign
in with Google I'll click on the
signning with Google and you know we
have already given this application
permission and we should be sign in
automatically so here we see our user
object and now you see my
name and we see the user property so
everything is working fine and you see
it was actually published and I'll just
set this admin property to
false okay and everything works fine
even if we come over to the account tab
over here so now we are making sure that
the we are getting the session we can
now make use of this to navigate the
user to the homepage so in our use
effect let's not forget to add our
dependency array we need to push the
user to the
homepage and to do this first I'm going
to just quickly have
router which is going to be equal to the
use router hook that the next GS team
gives us so import use router from next
navigation okay and here we can push the
user to the homepage so router. push to
slash and I'll copy this and come over
to our use effect and first I'll going
to check if we have session if that is
true then push the user to the homepage
and add our dependent array where we
need to pass router and session like
this so now we should be redirected to
the homepage because we have a session
great and we are redirected to the
homepage so we have this page um done we
see I'm just going to remove any
console. logs that we have so all these
I'll leave in case of any errors and now
let's take a look at this callback
object that we have here okay so this SC
back object out come over to the
header so here in the header
component I'm just going to get access
to the session as we did in the sign up
page so somewhere here I'm going to have
this Con right structure
data which are rename to session and
this is going to be equal to the use
session hook which comes from next off
react
and I'll just re rearrange this and here
I'm going to console.log
session and if we come back to the
browser you see the property that we
have in our session so we have this user
with email image and name we want to add
an extra property to this session so if
we come over to Earth TS we have this
callback object have the session which
can be an asynchronous function and here
I'm just going to D structure session
and token like
this so inside this function I'll going
to get the user email from our token so
this is going to be equal to token.
email like
this and I'm going to have this user
coming from our sanity client so I'm
going to await sanity client. fetch
let's try to f a user via this email so
here I'm going to provide a query we're
going to go more into this when we go
over to data fetching but the query
actually works like this with the star
and then the cracket and we say theore
type is equal to user and we want to get
the user by email so where the email is
equal to like this and there we have the
dollar
sign email so this dollar
sign is to inject uh a parameter so we
get to this and we want to structure the
ID so we added this Z here because this
returns an array and we want to just get
the first matching elements and we can
say this fetch is going to return an
object so an object with the underscore
ID property which is going to be of type
string so remember here we are just
getting the underscore ID now we have
this user what we are going to do next
we are going to return this object where
we spread all the session and come down
here where we update our user so in our
user property we're going to have this
object where we spread the session do
user and most importantly now we want to
add this ID property and the value is
going to come from our user doore ID we
are now making use of this email so this
fetch takes in a second argument and the
second argument is the query parameter
so comea here and you say we have param
of type Cod parameter and we'll pass
email to be user email so this email
needs to be this email with this dollar
sign here so this
email okay so now if we we get the user
and we update I'm just going to log this
this user to the console and check our
terminal everything still works fine and
we get our user so if we open this up
now you see wa we have the user email
the ID and other properties so from
previously we didn't have the ID but now
we have the ID of the user and here we
have it on the console the user so I
think we should update that because that
is not actually the user that is the
user ID so I'm going to change this to
user
ID and I would use it here so rather
than user ID I actually call it user ID
object and use this
here okay so that's great now we're sure
we have the ID we can make use of this
in our header to correctly navigate the
user to the user profile page okay so
this link where we that goes to SL off
I'm going to cut
this and I'll have a check to check if
we have session. user if that is true
then I'll paste this link otherwise I
would paste this link again I'll still
repace the
link but the navigation is going to be
different so this link would go to the
user profile and this link will go to
the authentication page if we don't have
uh an an authenticated user so the H is
going to be dynamic I'm going to delete
this and so that we can use this object
here and back tick so we're going to go
to/ users and then I'm going to use the
last sign bracket session. user.
ID now we get this error that we don't
see the user property so user ID doesn't
exist we know it actually exist because
you know we just saw this in the console
so to fix this error we are going to
have another types so in our root folder
I'm going to create another file and
this file out call next hyphone off.
types.
TS like this so in here I'm going to
import a type A type that will come from
the next or Library which is the default
session
type so here we're going to declare a
module in this module we're going to
call
the next alt module and here we have our
bracket so we're going to have an
interface for the session object and in
here
user and user is going to be coming from
the default session we're going to D
structure user like
this so like this we are going to D
structure user and we want to add an
extra property so we say end here and we
have this object where we add the ID and
the ID is going to be of typ string so
now you see this gets rid of the error
that we had in our header and now um the
property ID property has been added to
our session and here I'm going to have
another change so to show the user
profile image so we're going to check if
session. user.
image if that is true we're going to
return return a
div not um fragment we're actually going
to return return a div
and here we say otherwise we'll just
return this Avatar so in the case where
the user doesn't have uh an image so
we're going to give this a width of 10 a
height of
10 rounded full and overflow
hidden and inside this div we are going
to have an image come from next
image and inside this image we are going
to have the source property which is
going to come from our session
do user. image and then we're going to
have our art
property which is going to come from our
session. user.name
okay and now just add this exclamation
sign
here all right so we're going to give
this a width of 40 and a height of 40
like
this okay so this is the settings we
need if we save this and we come back to
our
application you see our application
reloads and we have an error so we have
an error for the host name so for the
image host name so actually I'm going to
copy this error and come over to our
next config dots file so here I'm just
going to come over to our next config.js
and inside this object here I'm going to
have images and images is an object
where I have domains and domains is an
array of string where I provide the
string so if we open the terminal you
see next off is trying to restart our
server I'm actually going to quit it and
restart it
ourselves using npm
runev and we come back to the
browser I will just reload this okay
I'll reload this and wait for our
application to build so it loads up and
we should see the aatar update great so
now we s we see the user Avatar update
to the user image which in this case is
just this um a we have here so for
GitHub if we have the errors do go on
and have add the GitHub image in the
domain so now we have this
avat I want to add the um an animation
and I'm going to do this inside of
uh
global. CSS file so first I'm going to
give this a class name and in the app AP
not API web and global. CSS I want to
add a
costume um class name for our image and
also a scale animation so IMG I'm going
to use the at apply
directive and give this class name of
object cover
with full H full like this and I'll have
this um styling for scale animation
making use of the apply directive by
taing
CSS and on H like this I'm going to
scale and I'm going to scale this by one
to five and then I'm going to transition
all and I'm going to give this a
duration of 700 like this so I'm going
to copy this scale animation class name
we can now use it in our header and also
the IMG class name okay so now those
classes we wrote out here in the global.
CSS is going to be applied and we come
back to application you see we get this
um hover animation on the image so this
is the authentication in our application
next let's continue with our hero
section so back to uh app and in our
page so web page. TSX here we are going
to have a hero section okay so I'll just
have this placeold here where I would
have hero
section and then we can go over to
create the components so in the
components folder I'll create a new
folder called hero
section and in here I'll create a new
file heror section.
TSX so let's Bo P STP this hero section
and get rid of the
reactjs input so import react from react
we get rid of it and we can already
import this hero section over here in
our homepage so here I'm going to um
import the hero section and we are going
to be working in this
file all right so I'll change this div
to section and give it class names
already so give it a display of flex I
would also give this uh padding on the
xaxis of four item Center and give it a
capap of 12 and a container and then
I'll position the items in the center
using MX
atho and inside this um section we are
going to have this div with a py of 10
and the height of
full and in here we are going to have
what I would call The Heading so we're
going to have more like like the heading
inside this div and also inside this div
we are going to have another section and
this section I'm going to have this
placeholder that I would just call the
room
description okay so here we just have
the heading and inside this div we have
the room description and outside we'll
have the images okay so in let's get
started with the heading so here we're
going to have this H1
and I'll will give this a class name of
font heading we don't have this costume
font yet we are going to create it in a
second and I'll give it a margin bottom
of six and this text of
explore just explore our Exquisite
hotel and after this hron I would have
this paragraph and this paragraph is
going to have this um text color of # 4
a not 41 actually so 4 a 4 a 4 a and on
that team I'll would give this uh text
of this # FFF up to six places and then
add this EA like this and I'm also going
to give this a margin bottom of
12 and here I'll give this a Max width
of
LG and inside this paragraph We are
going to have this text of x experience
and exquisite like this so experience
and exquisite Hotel immersed in Rich
history immer in Rich
history and also Timeless Elegance like
this so I'll just have this text inside
here and then I'll have this button that
says get started this button is going to
have the class name of button primary
another
custume um class that we haven't defined
yet we're going to Define this font
heading and button
primary okay
so if we have a look on the browser this
is what we have going on okay so what we
can do next we can come over to this uh
to
uh
um Global do CSS and in here where we
have the this class name I'm actually
going to paste these other class names
so we have new class names for the
button primary the button tertiary the
font heading and font noral so we're
using this at apply directive and we
apply these classes you can obviously
find this class in the GitHub repo which
I attached to the description okay so
that's where you get these classes I
don't just want to see you to see see me
type all these classes from scratch and
take our time so that's why I just
provided these um classes here which
you'll find again in the GitHub attached
to this video so go on and save this
file and if we have a preview of what we
have now this is what we have updated
with our heading and also our primary
button so now we can write for our room
description I'm going to get rid of this
heading tag here and I'll also get rid
of this room description okay and I'll
give this have a div here which I'll
display Flex justify
between and I would also give this a
margin top of 12 so inside this div we
are going to have another div like
this and this div I'll give it a class
name of flex
and I would also give this a gap of
three give this a flex coal like this
position the items in the center and
justify
Center all right so inside this div we
are going to have a paragraph and the
paragraph that would say basic room here
and this class name for this paragraph
is going to be Tex SM Xs
and on large devices and above this is
going to have a text
LG and our position the text in the
center So Below this paragraph we're
going to have what I would call a
counter so more like showing how many
basic rooms that we have in our
application and this is going to have a
class name from medium devices I'm going
to position this I'm going going to
position give this a font bold and a
font medium by default give it a text
LG and on larger extra large devices
I'll give a text of five XEL so in here
we can have a count as I said we just go
with plus
20 I'm just going to bring this down
twice like this so after basic room next
so we're going to have luxury
room and after the luxury room we are
going to have suits which are the three
main kinds of room that we are
supporting the application and this is
what we have going for preview so next
for the images we are going to have this
um div and let's style this div by
giving it these class names and on
medium devices we are going to display
this as a grid and this is going to be
hidden on smaller devices by default and
this is going to have a cap of
eight and we're going to give this a
grid Coe of one so inside here we are
going to have this first div where which
would give rounded 2
XL and give overflow of hidden we're
going to give this a height of 48 and
inside here we are going to render an
image so we import image from next image
and we get this image a source so this
image source is going to be a
string and we also give it an ALT which
will be a string and we're going to give
this a width of 300 and a height of 300
like this so for class name I'm just
going to use our IMG class name and give
it our scale animation remember all
these are coming from our global. CSS
and after this we are going to have an
another div that will hold two images
and this would have a class name of grid
and now we're going to give this grid
code to remember the first one was grid
call
one and we are going to give this u a
height of
48 so we're going to give this um inner
div arounded to excel overlow hidden
like this and here I'm going to have an
image I think we can actually copy this
um image that we have from up here so
I'm just going to copy this and paste
this over here we have two images
because we have grid code too so I'm
going to copy this div and duplicate so
if we go to the browser let's have a
quick preview this is what we have for
now okay so this is what we have and for
the images I have actually provided us
with images to use in our project so if
you come over to the public which is
where we save static asset I'll create
an images folder and in here I'll paste
these images which I got from on Splash
so these are the three images which
we'll be using in this
project so let's um point to those
images so here to point to it we don't
go with SLU we actually go to slash
images automatically nextjs is going to
look in the public folder and the name
of the file is hero one.
JPEG and for the alt I would also go
with the with an ALT of hero one so I'll
copy this and use this here so the next
image has a name of Hero
2 and the alt is hero2 and same for the
third image so I'm going to paste it
here and go with Hero 3 for the name and
same for the O So once we have this
let's save this and have a preview so
this is what we have now for our
application great so we have this and it
works as fine with our teaming feature
great so let's animate this counter that
we have here so I'll zoom out a bit
actually and this other section for the
images is the section on the right where
we display these images
okay so and we have these images here
okay and we have this first image and we
have this D for the two images and in
this other place the same thing applies
so I would like us to animate the text
and for that I'll create another
component which I would call count so
I'll zoom in a bit and call this count
up number okay so I'll copy this and
create a file count up number.
TSX so let's have the jsx for this
component I would first remove the
reactjs input and this is going to be FC
for functional component and we are
going to be receiving props so but first
I would like us to go on and manage
state that is the count State and set
count which is going to be equal to you
states that we import from react and
we're going to start at zero and this FC
is going to be receiving props so here
we are going to define a type for our
props and this is going to be equal to
this object and we have the N value
which is of type number and we also have
the duration this duration is going to
be in
MCS okay so this is going to be of type
number okay so here we are going to be
receiving the props or we can D
structure directly that is the duration
as well as the end value all right so
here just below this our set State let's
have our use effect that we UT from
react and our use effect we have this um
callback function and we should not
forget our array of
dependency okay so let's go and have
this um function this update count
function which is going to help us to
achieve this animation so this update
count is going to be called with a Tim
stamp which is going to be of type
number okay so to achieve this animation
we are going to have this start time
which is of type number like this so we
are going to update this start time
based on the time stamp that we have
here so first we're going to check if
there is no start time then the start
time isal going to be equal to the time
stamp that we pass across to this
function and we're going to get um keep
track of the progress and we're going to
say this is equal to the Tim stamp do
the start time so this is going to give
um track of the progress we have and we
say if progress is now less than the
duration the duration that comes in Via
props we are going to update our account
and we're going to update our account by
getting the minimum value so making use
of math. mean we takes in the values and
the value we are going to pass in here
is going to be the N value and we're
going to have this mathematical
mathematical operation here here we say
the progress divided by the duration and
we multiply this by the end value okay
okay so this is we going on to update
our set count our count property and
let's keep track of the animation and
the reason we are keeping track of this
animation frame ID here is so that we
can unsubscribe and do some clean up
okay so we have this animation frame ID
and we are going to say this is going to
be equal to request animation frame
provided by JavaScript and we pass this
function so this update count function
here and that's the Callback we pass
else we are just going to go on and say
set our account to the end value okay
that we get from
props so let's pass our dependency
arrays so in this array of dependency we
are making use of the N value and also
the
duration okay so let's update our
animation frame ID just after this
update count so our animation frame ID
is going to be equal to request
animation frame ID and the Callback is
going to be our update
count okay like this and let's not
forget our cleanup so we are going to
Reon here and this return is going to
take this callback function and this
callback function we can cancel the
animation frame and pass the animation
frame ID okay they hand that to it
so I'll just zoom out so you see the
complete implementation and here we are
not actually going to have a div we're
going to have a paragraph and this
paragraph needs to be the count so
actually I'm going to copy this from the
hero section so this paragraph we have
here just copy one of these
paragraphs and I'll use it in here I'll
replace what we have here and we need to
round it up so the counts I'm just going
to have this brackets and we are going
to use the
math. round like this and we are going
to pass the count to
it okay so this is the implementation
for this count of number
functionality and we can already use
this in our hero section remember we are
managing States here so making use of
this is going to give us errors but no
worries I would just like us to see the
error and we're going to fix the error
so I'm going to import this component
and in here we're going to pass the
duration remember it's in milliseconds
Out Pass 3,000 which means 3 seconds and
the end value I'll just pass two U 200
you can play around with these figures
okay so I'll pass it here like this and
if we save and we go back we should see
our error yeah so we see our error
because we're using you state in this
count up number component but to surpass
or to suppress the error we can make
this client component making of that use
client directive we would come back to
this okay so if we reload our
application now you see the counter
animation you can you know play with the
different values so you can play with
the duration maybe give it 5,000 for 5
seconds and also play with the you know
with a different end values to just fit
your application needs
so we have this but I want to see
something actually let's copy this text
and if we right click and we view the
page source so I'm just going to wrap
this and we find this text we don't see
it because this is a client component we
made this of the use client directive if
we copy this other text and we come back
to the page Source we don't see this
text in here okay and that is an issue
that's an issue for SEO and we sometimes
need this because this is our hero
section you might need to you know
render some part of your application on
the on the server and some part on the
client now to fix this first we can
comment this out because this is what
broke the code and get rid of this use
client directive here and you see our
application works as expected okay but
now we don't have our animation and if
we copy this and we view the P Source
I'll wrap this again and find here you
see we see our explor text because now
this is a server component and it is
rendered on the server but once we
attach our use client directive it
becomes a client um component and it's
no longer rendered on the server so I
actually want to render part of my
application on the
server and I'll get rid of the use
client directive and this brings us back
to our error and I'll come back and zoom
out here okay so now now how do we
achieve this so what's going to happen
is I'm going to create two new
components here I'm going to create a
client component. TSX and I'm also going
to create a server component. TSX so the
client component can take in server
components as props and this is what I
want to do here so I want to pass props
to this client component and these props
are going to be the server component so
the part of the application I want to
render on the server so here in the
server component we are going to
bootstrap this component and I'll get
rid of the react input and in the hero
section I'm going to copy everything we
have here so in here I'm just going to
copy this entire
section and we are going to paste it in
into of our client component in here
like this I'll get rid of the react
input
and make this a use client component
like this we have the errors would fix
it so I want to render this section
where we have the H1 paragraph and
button I actually want to render it on
this server side if you want to handle
click events on this button you have to
handle it on the client because there's
no clicking on the server so here I want
to render this section on the
server side and I'll cut it and here in
the server component I'm actually going
to change the structure here so I'll
remove everything and I will export this
constant and this constant I'm going to
call heading one and it is going to be
equal to this jsx here so it has to be
this uh self closing tag like this so
header one is going to be equal to this
jsx and this header one is going to be
passed down to this um component as prop
so you can say this of type FC for
functional components which is a generic
type let's create a prop so we're going
to say type prop is going to be equal to
this object so we have heading one and
heading one is going to be of type
react. react
node all right so we're going to pass
props in here and here we can go on to
receive props and here the structure The
Heading one from the
props so let's bring in the heading one
and this heading one we are going to
have it in the place where we had that
text so in here we are going to have the
heading one like this so this is a
server component that we are expecting
via props and I'll just import this
count up number for the counter
animation and I also want to render this
section where we have these images so
you know one of the advantage of having
um a server component is is fast load
time so I just want this images to be
coming from the server so I'll call it
section two and I will paste this and we
have errors so I will try to import the
image component okay so maybe I'll just
import it manually I would import image
from next image like this okay and the
error should go away so this section two
which contains our images we going to
also receive it at props in this client
component okay so in here let's go on
and
um customize our propes so that it
expects this section two which is also
going to be your type react. react
node all right so here we are going to
pass the section two over here where we
had the section two previously like this
so this section two doesn't have to come
from our server component let's bring in
bring it in Via props so here we are
going to bring it in from the props so
this is the setup we have now this is
our client component and in our hero
section we are going to import the
client
component like this so go on and import
the client component and I'll remove
these other inputs we have here now this
client component needs the props so it
needs the section two which is going to
be equal to section two which will be
coming from the server component and it
also needs the heading one which is
going to be called to this heading one
from the server component so if we
reload our application you see that our
application works as fine and we get the
best of both words so we have our client
component which renders this counter
over here so this section and we have
this heading section coming from the
server component and we can prove it if
I copy this and I right click and view
the page Source this time around and I
find it you see that it is there so we
have this text it wasn't there before
when we made use of the use client
directive but it is there now and then
if we copy this other text and we
check we are going to see it there so we
have the section of our application
rendered on the server side and we just
have this
counter section rendered on the
client okay so you can play around with
these figures this um counter animation
we have here you can just play around
with it give them different values just
give this a value of 50 120 you know 60
you can change the duration anyhow as
you wish all right so next we can go to
have our other components so we can
have our search component next so for
our search feature our search feature is
just going to be below this our hero
section and let's come back to the
application I'm going to close all these
other sections and let's come over to
our page so which is our homepage I'm
just going to collapse all of these and
in our page. CSX here we are going to
have a page search section okay
and we obviously have other sections
next we're going to have our featured
room section and next we are going to
have our gallery and lastly we are going
to have our newsletter section so let's
get started with our page search um
section so this section over here and
I'm going to come over to the components
and create a new component which I call
Page search and inside um this folder I
create another file which I'll call Page
search. TSX like this so let's boostrap
this page search component I'll get rid
of the react input and this page search
component is going to take a search
component so in the components folder
I'll create another um component for
search and create a search. TSX and the
reason why is because this search is
going to be reusable across pages so
that's why I'm putting in its own
component rather than the Page search so
we're going to import this search
component inside the Page search
component so that it can be customizable
so we import the P search components
inside the homepage like this and we can
come to the browser to have a preview so
this our search component let's come
back to the browser and let's test the
responsiveness of our application we
didn't actually test this after working
on the hero section so we see how
responsive our our application is and
everything works fine with our dark and
white team
feature okay so you see we can um scale
and see how our application adjust to
the different view Parts all right so we
can go back and work on our search
um component and this search components
I'm going to change this to user section
and the class name is going to have a
background of tary Light which is our
own tary light color this is going to
have a px of four and the py of six and
it's going to have a rounded LG and
inside here we are going to have a div
this div is going to have a class name
of container and MX Auto we're going to
display it as a flex give it a gap of
four and give it Flex wrap and also
justify between items Center like this
and inside this div we are going to have
another div this div is going to hold
our um drop down so we're going to give
it a width full and on medium devices
we're going to give it 1/3 of the width
and on large devices we are going to
give the width Auto like this and give
it a margin bottom of four and also on
medium devices give it a margin bottom
of zero so here we're going to have a B
okay but there's not going to be any
HTML 4 this is going to have a class
name of block I'm going to display this
as block and give this a text SM a font
medium uh maging bottom of two and not
to Black we are going to give this a
text of black and in here we are going
to go with the room type for the
labo all right so after this label we
are going to have this div we give the
class name of
relative and then we're going to have a
select without any name or without any
ID okay but we're going to style it
obviously give this a class name of with
full give this a padding X of four a
padding y of two give this
capitalize and give this rounded and
give it leading tight and also not data
Al the on on the dark mode like this I'm
going to give this uh background of
black and give this uh a font on the
focus State give this an outline of
none so that is class names for our
select so a select always have options
but first we are going to handle the
give this the unchange Handler so in
this select I'm going to pass this
unchange
and this unchange is going to be called
to a function we haven't defined yet so
we're going to reference this handle
room name room type change function
which we don't have yet okay and here
for the value we are going to give this
value of room type
filter all this will be coming from
props and this select is going to have
these options okay and this option is
going to have the text all and I will
just bring this down and the next option
is going to be for our different room so
this is going to be basic for our basic
room and this is going to be luxury I'll
just copy this luxury and use this over
here and the last one is going to have
the tag of Suits which is the last type
of our room like
this okay so this is what we have going
on and after this first section if we
save yeah we get these errors So to
avoid these errors I'm just going to
comment these out until we have them
from propes and this is what we have
going
on so after this we are going to have
another section for our search
input so we can style this we're going
to give it all with our full hand on
medium devices we're going to give it
1/3 of the width and on large devices
I'm just going to give this a Max like
this give this a with
Auto and margin bottom of four and the
medium devices a margin bottom of
zero so here we're going to have the
label without any HTML 4 and the class
name for this is going to be display of
block okay we're going to display this
label as a block
text font medium imagine bottom of two a
text black and here we give this label
search so outside this label we're going
to have our input and the input type is
not going to be text it is going to be
search like this and here we are going
to give this an ID of search and we are
also going to come here and give this a
placeholder of search dot dot dot just
like this and here we can go on to
handle the class
name and before we continue with the
class name let's give this a value which
also come from prop so we're going to
comment this out and the value is going
to be search query and on change event
which is going to point to a function we
don't also have yet we're going to just
call this handle search query
like this change so handle set query
change and I'll just comment them out
since we don't have them to avoid errors
now we can starty our input give it a
with full a px of four a py of three
give it rounded leading tight like this
and on the dark mode I'm going to give
this a background color of
black and I'm going on the focus stage
I'm going to remove the Outline by
saying outline none like this and give
this uh a place holder a text of black
and also on the dark team we can style
the placeholder and give this a text of
white okay so this is the second section
and next is going to be our button so
we're going to have this button and this
class name is going to be our button
primary like this and the type is going
to be equal to button okay and on click
we are going to have a function which we
don't have yet so handle filter click
and I'll comment it out and give this
button um the text of search like this
so we can save this and this primary
button remember is coming from uh um
global. CSS that's why we have this
button primier
all right so I'm just going
to close this off global. CSS and if we
come back to the browser this is what we
have going so we have this drop down we
have our search and we over here we have
our button and there's a typo there in
our button which we can just quickly fix
like
this okay so I'm going to bring this
back in because because now we are going
to customize this search component by
receiving props so here we are going to
import FC from react like this and let's
make this a client component so making
use of the use client directive and this
FC is a generic type which will Define
up here so this type called props is
going to be equal to this
object and we going to rece the room
type filter and this is going to be a
string and then we are going to go and
receive our search query like this and
the sech query is also going to be of
type string like this okay we also going
to receive the function that would
update these properties so the Set uh
set room filter type
filter and this is going to be a
function that gets the value which is of
type string and returns void like this
and up next we are going to have the
other function which we called set
search
query like this and now we can pass our
prop to FC and we can just destructure
these values from the prop so set room
type filter and set search query like
this
so we have these types and we are going
to Define some other functions here so
this handle room type change which will
make use of these properties coming in
from props so handle room type change
going to take the event remember this is
a select drop down so if we see here it
is a select and select is going to have
the event the type of this event is
going to be of type change event but
this change event is a generic type and
here we're going to say this is a type
of
HTML select
element like this and what happens on
change we are going to call set room
typee filter and we're going to pass the
event Target value like
this okay so next prop that's this next
function is this handle search query
change which is being called on this
input element okay so here I going to
have this function that we call handle
search query um change which is going to
take the event which is also a change
event but this time around is a change
event on the HTML input element and in
here we are going to update our query so
we're going to set search query to the
event Target value like this
and lastly for this button so handle
filter click we're going to have this
Con here where we call handle filter
click and this is just going to be this
Arrow
function and in here we are going to go
and and call and navigate the user to
the rooms page like this so with the
query so in order for us to do this we
need to import the
router so here just up here I'm going to
say con router is going to be equal to
use
router and use router needs to be
imported from next navigation and you
call this use router like this so here
when the user clicks on the search we're
going to call this router and we're
going to push the user to the rooms page
so the path is going to be dynamic and
we use back th to go to/ rooms and we
are going to construct a query where the
room type is is going to be equal to the
room type filter and we're going to add
another property to this query where the
search query is going to be equal to
this Dynamic search query here like
this and in Page search we are going to
handle these props so we're going to say
the search and also the set query we're
also going to pass the set room type
filter and all these props here so we're
going to go on and set our state so
we're going to set the
room type filter and function so set
room type filter is going to be equal to
use state which calls from react and by
default it's going to be an empty string
so let's not forget to make this uh
client component making use of the use
client directive like this and we can
set another state value here we're going
to set another state value for the sech
query and here we have set sech query is
going to be equal to UST State and an
empty string by default so the room type
filter is going to be equal to this room
type filter from States also the sech
query and also the set room filter we're
going to pass it here and then the set
search query function is going to be
passed here so if we save this and let's
try this out already I'll just reload
the application to see how it works on
the light and dark team we can also test
the responsiveness of this application
and everything you know is working fine
in that regards so let's try out the
query and I'll just add any Dom search
here and click on set so let's take a
look at the URL so you see we are
redirected to SL rooms and we have the
query over here great we're going to
make use of that information when we
work on the rooms page so this is what
we have going I just get rid of these
components and next for the featured
room we would come back to this because
it involves some data fetching we can
already work on the gallery components
so here in the component folder I will
create a new folder for the
gallery like this and in here how to
create a new file gallery. TSX so in
here I'm going to paste this component
that I already provided for us so I'm
just going to paste this get rid of the
react
input and just you know I'm just going
to remove everything we have here so the
reason why again is because this is just
a static component no data fetching or
anything special going here and I don't
just want you you to watch me type out
all these class names and waste your
time so see we're using the IMG and we
are just using our hero images that we
imported in our public folder so that's
all that is going on in this Gallery
page so come back to public images you
will see there images where they are
being referenced so that's all is going
on here we can go on to make use of this
Gallery component
already and I'm going to import it in
our page. TSX so here I will import the
gallery component and if we go back to
the browser we see our Gallery component
and we can test the responsiveness of
this component as well and we see that
this component is equally
responsive okay so it's
responsive like this so we see the
component is responsive and it works
fine with our dark and white
team okay so this is our application
next let's go over to the newsletter
component okay so over here we are going
to paste in this components so come over
to the components folder and I'll create
a new folder for news
letter and I'll create a new file for
newsletter
TSX and I'll paste it in again please
you can find this code in the GitHub
this is just static data and I don't
want to waste your time for you to see
me typ in all these H um jsx with all
these class names but you can just copy
and paste this code from the GitHub
there's nothing special going on inside
of this component it's just styling
purposes okay so this is what is going
on on in here so you can go on and save
this component and please once again get
a code from GitHub and I'm going to um
import this newsletter component from
the components we just created so this
is the newsletter component with this
input and we can go on to test that it
is responsive as
well so we see that the newsletter
component is equally um
responsive all right so we have this
going on in our application now we can
go into Data fretting and work on our
featured room section okay so let's come
over to our components and in here I'll
create a new folder called featured room
and I'll create a new file that I call
featured room. TSX and have this react
component here I also get rid of the
react input and import this component
inside of our page. TSX like this we can
come over to the browser and here in the
browser I'll just scroll down and you
see our featured room so for us to
continue we need some room rooms that we
are going to play around with and let's
come over to our sanity studio and I'll
just reload this San
studio all right so now we are here we
can see this user which we created
earlier and we are going to go over to
the hotel room section so in here we are
going to create a hotel
room and we need to fill in all these
details so I'm going to fill in the name
and the name I'm going to call Deluxe
suit which is a name I just made up and
for the slog we can generate a slog
based on of the name and the description
I will paste in this description here
and description needs to be minimum 100
S so in case you're having an error you
can fix it and same for the price
minimum 100 characters you see here if
we choose 19 we have an error and the
error says minimum 100 so the minimum
cost follow room is 100 we set this
together and discount I'll just go with
a discount of eight and for images I'll
come to unsplash.com and in unsplash.com
I'm going to search for rooms
here so sech for room and here I'm going
to um copy the image address so any of
these rooms I'll copy and use in our
project so for every other room I'm just
going to fast forward through so here
I'll copy the image address and add item
I will paste in the URL index it so next
I'm going to fast
forward and now for the cover image I'll
would come back to Splash and choose an
image here so maybe this image I'll copy
the image address and I'll paste it in
here the room type so by default we
chose basic which is okay I'll change it
to
suit and in the dimension I'll give this
a dimension of let's say 600 square ft
you can give this any dimension of your
choice for number of beds I would just
go with
two and for offer the many face let's
add an icon so this has to be font
awesome icon like this so fa and then
bed and for the amenity you can give it
any name so I'll just give this name of
king sideb bird to match and I would add
two more amenities okay so this is going
to have an icon of fa Wi-Fi so fonts
awesome and The Amity we can just use a
text like free Wi-Fi or anything like
that
and I'm going to add one more so I'll
add an icon and this icon is going to be
f a coffee and the amenity is going to
be coffee maker like this so by default
it is not booked I will make this
featured like this and go on to publish
this hotel room so if we click on this
um right hand corner here where we have
these three dots
just here we can inspect this and we're
going to see all the properties the
hotel room has so it has discover image
this discover image has the URL it has
the
description it has these images so I
added five images and I can just
collapse them and each each image has it
key and DRL okay and you can see here is
featured and the offered amenities that
comes with this room you can see the
priz the slug has the underscore type
and the current and then the special
notes I am going to fast forward and Out
Create four more hotel rooms at the
background I have created these hotel
rooms and now that we have this hotel
rooms it's time for us to go into the
world of data fetching so I created four
more and we can see the H rooms here so
let's come back to code and now we in
the IDE I am going to create two new
file
okay so I'm going to create these files
in our leaps folder and the first file
I'm going to create is a sanity queries
file so I'm going to call this file
sanity queries. TS and our queries would
leave inside of this file we would come
back to this file we are going to create
another file and this file we would call
apis. TS and this is the file that will
be discussing to our sanity client so
let's export a function that we are
going to use to fetch our featured um
room so we'll call this function get
featured room like
this and here we are going to have a con
which will call result and this result
is going to await our sanity client and
in sanity client we have this fetch
method you see Tak in the query for now
I will just pass in this empty string
and I'm going to also pass an empty
object for params because we don't have
any params so we can create this query
so let's come over to our sanity
queries. TS file and in this file I'm
going to export a constant which I would
call get featured room
query now this is going to be equal to
Gro so Gro from santic L it has no spe
special use case rather than maybe for
AO completion or SS like that so we have
the star and we have our Gro query here
and we want to fetch a room where the
type is equal to hotel room now if we
come back to our sanity studio and we
inspect one of these rooms here you see
that theore type is hotel room that's
why we can query by this type of hotel
room and we see his featured is false so
if I check the first room we both
created we created together and I ECT
you see here that is featured is true
okay so this query is going to return an
array and that's why we're going to take
the first element so we're going to
change it featured property and say
Where It's featured is equal to true and
I have this um array this structure here
something like that where I taken the
first element and here corly brackets
I'm going to just take the properties
that we need and we need the underscore
ID we also need need the description we
also need the discounts of the room we
need the images and we need the is
featured property we also need the name
we need the price as
well and we need a slug so this query we
are going to import it in our API uh
file so here just after this sanity um
import I'm going to import everything so
so using star like this as queries and
this is going to be coming from the
sanity queries file so this file
Here and Now rather than an empty string
we are going to pass our queries and
then we can access the get featured room
query like this now this fetch can take
in an extra object for configuration and
one configuration we can pass is cach
and we see the options one option is no
cash and and this just says we want to
go on end disable any caching mechanism
and always fetch data on every request
now apart from this um from this cache
we can also pass another configuration
which is next and next is an object
where we pass revalidate and we pass a
number now this number is in seconds so
for
1,800 we mean 30 minutes okay so 1,800
seconds and this validate is going to go
on and fetch data on this interval so in
this case every 30 minutes this function
is going to get called automatically and
refresh so this might be the use case in
your application where you know your
data doesn't change as often but in this
case because I'm in development and I
would like to see my changes happen I
would just go back to cash no cash
that's um this function gets called on
every request and let's forget to also
Reon the result that we get from our
sanity client like
this okay so now we have this query you
you see fetch fetch is of type any so
fetch is a generic type and we can pass
in the type so in our app here I'm going
to create a new folder which I would
call models so here I'm going to create
this folder which out call models like
this and I'm going to create a room
model so that we can um map how a room
looks like in our application all right
so let's export this type I would call
it room equal to this object and the
room is going to have an underscore ID
which is of type string and it's also
going to have a cover image a cover
image is going to be its own type so
here I'm going to have this type of
cover
image which is going to be equal to this
object
okay and here I'll just have the URL
which is going to be of type string and
pass this over to cover image and next
uh room is going to have a description
which is a string and the room is also
going to have Dimension and dimension is
going to be of type string we also have
this discount which is of type number
not string and we also have this images
images is its own unique type so here I
would have this type for images like
this which is going to be equal to this
object where each image will have the
underscore key property which is a
string and also have the URL which is a
string like
this and we can pass this image to this
images so an array of this image
property like this and next apart from
images we can also have this is booked
property which is of type Bing and we
also have his feature
which is also of type buing and we also
have the name of the room the name of
the room is a string and we have the
number of
beds that we have in the room which is
of type
number and we also have the offered
amenities so offered amenities it is its
own unique type so we're going to define
a type for our amenity here so our
amenity is going to be equal to this
object and here we have the underscore
key property and the underscore key is
going to be of type string and here we
also have the amenity the amenity is
going to be of type string and we also
have the icon which is also of type
string so this amenity we are going to
pass it here as an array of amenity like
this and we also have the price of the
room the price is of type number and we
have the slog the slog is is its own
unique type and here we can Define the
type so all these types we saw it in our
sanity Studio when we inspected a room
so this log is of type uh the type is of
type string and we also have the current
property which is the actual slug of
type string so I'm going to pass the
slug to the slug over here like this and
then we also have the special note the
special note is of also a string and we
have the type so the type of this
property which is a string like this we
have this room type we can now import it
inside here and pass it over to fetch so
if we go over to get featured room query
if we come over here you see these
properties are part of the properties
that we are um expecting a room to have
and fetch is going to be of type room
and also this function resolves to a
room okay so now we have this function
we need to make use of this function in
our page. TSX so in our homepage we are
going to go on to make use of this and
fetch a room so just here I'm going to
have this called featured room this
variable and this featured room variable
like this is going to be equal to the
result of awaiting our get featured room
call from our lips we have an error
because we can go on to mark this
component as an async component so home
here is going to be equal to this async
component and already we can console.
log this featured room so that we are
sure of um if our query actually works
as expected so let's open the terminal
right here in the IDE because this is a
server
component and I am just going to save
and here we see our featured room so we
see our featured room with these
properties here so with the price and
all these properties that we set in our
sanity studio so this is our featured
room I will collapse the terminal and
actually exit from this terminal so this
featured room we are going to pass it as
prop to our featured room
component and this is going to lead to
an error because in the featured room
component we are not yet accepting the
prope now is the time to change it
we're going to mark this component as a
functional component and here we're
going to receive props so this prop type
where let's define it here so we say
type props is going to be equal to this
object where we're going to get that
featured room and we have seing this
featured room is going to be of type
room so let's import this room here and
I'll just separate it from the react FC
input so we have this end next this div
I'm going to rename it to a section so
just here I'm going to rename this to a
section and I'll copy and paste it over
to the closing div so let's style this
component I'm going to give it a class
name of flex so I'll display it as a
flex and on medium devices I would say
Flex roll and by default I would go with
flex column give this a padding on the x
axis of four and I also give us a
padding on the Y AIS of 10
and give this item Center and give this
a gap of 12 I would also give this
container styling and then give it a
margin on the x-axis of Auto Now inside
this featured room we are going to have
another div so another div with the
class name on medium devices we display
it as a gried and uh give this a gap of
eight give this grid code one and in
here we are going to have another div so
this is div that holds one image okay it
has a column of one and I'll give this
um rounded 2XL overflow hidden give this
a height of
48 like this and I'll also give this a
margin bottom of
four and on medium devices I will take
off the margin button so in here we're
going to have an image so we would
import this image from from next image
like this and in here this image
property we're going to give it a source
and the source we can already now get
our props so that we are going to
destructure the feature Dr from our
props so here I'm going to destructure
the featured
room all right and now this image source
is going to be pointing to the cover
image of the featured room so here we're
going to go with featured room and here
do cover image
URL okay and then we have the alt and
the alt is going to go to the name so
alt is going to be called to featured Dr
do name like
this okay so we can also pass the width
and the width is going to be 300 same as
the height so the height also is going
to be equal to 300 pixel and we can give
this our image class name and also our
scale animation which we Define in our
global.
CSS so let's save this and let's see a
first preview of what we have going on
so come over to the browser and we have
an error okay now this error is because
we are not getting the cover image from
the API so if we go back to our query
get feature Dr query here we are not
actually receiving the cover image so
add this property and that should fix
our error if we come back to the
browser so I just come back to the
browser here and let's see we have a
different error and that's because
images. unsplash is not configured so
let's copy this host name and here we're
going to come over to our sity config
sorry we will come to our where is it so
our next config and in here we are going
to add this URL like this we would save
this and we are going to quit our termin
down and restart so I didn't actually
save so I'll save I'll quit the terminal
again and restart npm run Dev so this
should fix our
error let's just wait for it to load and
let let's preview I'll just refresh our
application and wait for it to load okay
so this should fix our error so if we
scroll down to take a look at our
featured room so yeah so we now see um
the cover image great so I'm going to
close this and let's have um another div
where we display two images Okay so this
other div is going to be having a grid
code to property so here in this div I'm
going to give this div a class name of
grid and give this grid grid C to
and give this a gap of eight and I'll
also give this a height of 48 so inside
this div we are going to map through our
featured image images so featured images
we're going to First Slice spli sorry so
spli we want to just get two so we're
going to start from one two as our count
and now we can map through the images
and we'll get each image not room so
I'll change this to image
and I'm going to return return a div
like this we have an error because in a
map we need to provide a key so I'm
going to provide a
key and this key is going to be equal to
the image
URL so this image we have
here dot key sorry not the URL and here
I'm going to give this a class name and
I'm going to give this rounded
um
2XL I would also give it a class name of
overflow hidden so here we're going to
have a image component and the source
property is going to be our
image do um URL so our image. URL and
the alt is going to be our image. key so
I'll just use the key as the alt and
let's also give this a we of
300 and the height of 300
pixel okay so copy this class name and
attach it to this image
here so let's have a preview and let's
wait for it to load we have our two
images okay so now let's have this other
section where we display the text okay
so the name and some other um
information about our feat room so here
I'm going to have this
div and this div is going to have this
class names so first I'm going to
display on medium devices give this div
uh padding y of 10 and on medium devices
also give it a width of
50% and give this text of
left so we're going to have this heading
and here we'll just go with that
featured room like this and the class
name is going to be our font like this
so our font heading okay and give it a
margin bottom of 12 so after this
heading we are going to have a paragraph
So this paragraph is going to contain
the description and we can style it
already and here I'm going to give this
a font normal so our font
normal and give this a Max WI wi of
MD and here I will just have a featured
room
description okay so after this we're
going to have another div and this div
is going to have the class name of flex
Flex call um medium device 6 position it
as a flex row and also medium devices
give item and justify between and
imagine top of five
and in here we're going to have another
div and this div is going to have the
class name of flex a imin bom of three
and medium devices no margin
button and in here we are going to have
this div and this div is going to have
the class name of flex give it a gap of
three and give this a flex
coal and also give this items Center and
justify the content
Center and give this a margin right of
four okay so in here we are going to
have two paragraphs and the first
paragraph is going to have these class
names so text
SS can I find it here so text not SM I'm
looking for XS so extra small y so I'm
looking for this and here on large um
devices and above I'll give this uh text
uh
Excel position the text Center and I'll
will say start
Fir and in here I'm going to next I'm
going to display the price so the price
of the room in this paragraph so I'm
going to give this a class name of um MD
font
B give this Flex give this font
medium and give this a text of LG and on
extra large devices I give this a text
of 5
XL and in here I will have this dollar
sign where will display the price so
here we're going to display our featured
room do price so I'm going to copy this
so not this div I'm just going to copy
this div here I'll duplicate it because
next I want to show the discount of the
hotel room so so here I'm going to have
the text of
discount and in here featured room do
discount so let's save this and next
we're going to have the link so just
outside this div we're going to have a
link that will take us to the featured
room page so to the rooms page and here
we just have the text more details and
this link is going to be dynamic so the
hre sorry I'll get rid of the class name
and we start to the H so the HRA is
going to go to backtick for slash rooms
and here for slash we can inject the
room slug so the featured room do slug
like this and here we have the current
property so now we can style this and
this is going to have a class name of
B and this is going to have a height of
feet and it's also going to have the
class name of text
Center and we're going to give this
border test of dck and also give it uh
text tary of dck
okay again give this a padding on the x
axis of three and the padding on the y
axis of two and on large devices give us
a padding y of five and also on large
devices give theel padding X of
seven like this okay so we are also
going to give this uh rounded to
XL and I'll give it a font B so for the
font weight and on large devices I'll
give this a text of extra
large so I'm going to save this and
let's have a preview
so yeah so first we see at uh link is
out of place and actually the link needs
to be inside of this so I zoom out
and the the link needs to be inside of
this div so this div just below the
description so let's move it in I'm
going to copy everything we have here
and cut it actually so highlight and cut
and I'll collapse this div so that I can
have our link just in inside this
div okay so let's save this and our
styling is still um somewhat off let's
see what we have going let's make this
uh client component I think it has to do
with the way we fetch data because we're
fetching data from the server component
and passing it here let's save this and
let's
reload and if we come here you see our
component now renders uh as it should so
here we have our featured room we have
these
images and we are displaying the
description so we are done with our
featured
room and this is uh our first test of
data fetching and I'll just zoom back in
and this is the component and if we just
uh have a few for everything we've done
the code is in the GitHub if we go to
the more details link We Go go to the to
a 404 page you see so everything is
working fine we don't have that page yet
we will be working on it so up next I
would like to add a loading State
because if we are fetching data is
likely to have some time where that data
is been fetched so nextjs gives us a
loading component we can use so in the
web folder here I'm going to create a
new file which I'll call loading.
TSX so in here I'm going to show a
spinner so let's Bo strap this react
component I would say con loading
spinner like this and loading spinner is
going to be equal to this Arrow
function and here I would WR a div and
the class name is going to be Flex item
Center justify Center and give this a
height of
screen okay so in here we're going to
have the actual loading animation so
we're going to have this div and I'll
give this div a class name of Animation
spin give this a rounded of full give
this a height of
16 give it a width of 16 and also give
it a b top width of Two and a border
bottom width of two like
this and I'll also give this a b gray
900 and this is our styling we can also
go on to just make this a self closing
tag like this and we should not forget
to export this loaded spinner so I'm
going to export it as the default export
so we can already try it out if we
reload our
application we don't see it yet but I'm
sure we're going to see cases where
we're going to show the um loading
animation and when fetching data you can
also have have errors so I'm going to
create another file here which I'll call
error. TSX and these are actually
special files that nextjs will call so
this is an error boundary so this error.
TSX and it has to be a client
component okay so I'm going to export
this as the default so export default
function I'll call it
error like this and this error component
is going to receive some props so we're
going to D structure error and we also
going to the structure reset now for
typescript to be happy let's set the
types so this error property here is
going to be of type error
and it can also have uh an optional
digest property which is of type
string so string like this and then for
reset reset is going to be of type
function so let's spell reset correctly
it's going to be of type function that
return returns
void okay so here let's have our jsx so
we're going to return and here I'm going
to have a div this div I'll give the
class name of
container like this and then margin to
the x-axis of
Auto so inside the div I'll have another
div which I'll give the class name of
font heading and I'll give this a text
let's say red 800 now you can start this
anyhow and I also give this a margin
bottom of 10 so in here I would just say
something went
wrong like this okay so if we have an
error this is going to show and actually
I'll change this div to a H2 to so to a
secondary heading and after this we're
going to have a button and this button
is going to have the class name of
button primary like this
and for the text I'll just tell the user
to try again like this and on click of
this button we're going to call a
function the reset function and this
reset function is just going to help the
user to recover from the error and just
going to go on to uh we render a
particular segment of our application so
where we have the error and if this
reloads we don't see the error but we
can actually create an error so we come
over to our featured room I think I
actually create this error in our
homepage so here in our page. TSX I'm
going to just throw an
error so I'll throw a new error and this
error I'm just going to say unable to
fetch okay so that we see this um error
boundary file come into action so now if
we reload the application we see
something went wrong okay and then we
see the button try again okay so here
this is the text something went wrong
and the button here and if we click on
this error here you see unable to fetch
so this unable to fetch is coming from
our page so here this unable to fetch we
defined it like this so I'll take it off
and I save and reload our
application and now we are sure that
whenever we have errors we are going to
be catching the errors gracefully so up
next let's go on and um try our query so
I'm going to try this
query and click on search which is
obviously going to fail but you see we
are redirected to the rooms page so the
rooms page is the page we are going to
be working on next so let's stop going
to a 44 and let's go on and work on this
rooms
page okay so I'll come over to the IDE
and here I will just close all of the
tabs that I've got
open and next I'm going to create this
page so here in the web folder I'll
create a new folder for rooms and then
I'll create the page. TSX
file now I'll boost STP the react
component get rid of the page and rather
name this rooms and then get rid of the
react input and I can already make this
uh client component making use of the
use client
directive now we've got this let's
manage some states and I'm going to
manage two states so the first is the
room type
filter and here set room type filter is
going to be equal to you state with an
empty
string and next I'm going to set another
state and this state is going to be the
search query because I want to keep
track of this search query to to apply
my filter so con search query and here I
have set search
query is going to be equal to UST state
with a default value of an empty string
and also I'm going to initialize this
constant and this constant I'm going to
call search params so this is going to
give me access to the sech params that
the user is going to use and I'm making
use of your States like this so next I
would have the use effect and this use
effect I would pass in the Callback
function and the empty dependency array
like this and first I want to go on and
have this constant where I can have the
different values of the search parameter
so call this search query is going to be
called to search par like this and we
have do get all right so sorry this
isn't your state this is use search
param okay so use search param should be
imported from next
navigation and now if we come back here
you see the dot get and we have atho
completion so we want to get a value and
the value name is search query okay so
this name over here the search quy if we
come over to the
browser and let's try to fetch data so
basic and I'll just give this test and
search so up here the you aware but you
see we have this rooms which is the
rooms page and we have this query where
we have the sech query and the value is
test and we also have the room type and
the value is basic so I want to get
access to the test and basic and this
gives me access to those values and
apart from the search query I want to
also have access to the room type and
this is going to come from search pars
doget and I'm going to get the with the
key of room type like this
okay so let's log these values to the
console so I console. log the set query
and also console.log the room type like
this okay um let's see so search query
not search params so I I would save this
and come over to the
browser and I will just reload the page
and this is our rooms page so open the
console and in here you see we are
currently getting the values so basic
and also test so we are correctly
getting these values okay so let's come
back to the browser to the IDE sorry and
I'll get rid of these console. logs and
have this if check so I'm going to check
if we have room type then let's update
the value here so I'm going to set room
type filter to room type like this
okay and we can also do the same for our
search query so here I'm going to check
if we have um search query then let's go
and set search query to the set um
search query value
okay all right so let's um update the
dependency
array okay so now in our use effect if
we have a value for
our um typon filter and search query it
will be updated accordingly okay so we
can go into the world of data fetching
and inside here actually I'm going to
move our models fold out of the app and
inside the source folder it's just a
practice that I prefer and to fetch data
for uh rooms I will come into the API
folder not here actually so our lebs
api. TS now we're going to have a
function that will help us to get a room
so let's export an async
function and this function I'm going to
call get
room like this and we can have our
result so const result is going to be
equal to await our sanity CLI
do
Fetch and we'll call this method it
needs a query now we can Define the
query if we go into the sanity queries.
TS file so I'm going to define a
constant here which I would call get
rooms query like this and this is going
to be equal to groc and we're going to
have a query so let's go get the hotel
room so we're going to get room where
the type soore type is equal to hotel
room like this so no extra um check and
let's get the parameters so we're going
to get underscore ID we're also going to
get the cover image we're also going to
get the
description let's also get the dimension
of the room we're also going to get if
the room is booked and also if it's a
featured room so it's featured so all
these properties also going to get the
room name the room price the
slug let's also get the type so these
are the um parameters we'll be getting
now we can call
queries. get room query like this and
the API
folder and this should be all okay so
let's return return our
results now we have this get room
function we can make use of this in a
page so in our rooms page so I'm just
going to come into the rooms page so
here I'm going to create the server and
run npm install s SWR and this is a hook
that helps us handle things like errors
loading State
optimizations and stuff like that so
let's restart our development s all
right so let's have a look on how this s
SW Arrow hook works so here I'm going to
have the cons and we're going to
destructure out some properties and we
call the used s SW AR hook and this used
s SW you see it's imported from s SWR
and we call this
hook like this and it needs a key so
this is a unique key that it can use for
caching data okay so it's a unique key
and it's actually up to you what name
you would give it here so I'm going to
give this a name of get and then have
this for/ hotel rooms like this and and
next it needs a fetcher so see it needs
a fetcher and the fetcher is a function
okay so it's a function that is going to
WR on the data so here we're going to
have such function so it's an async
function so let's have this asnc
function and we can call it um fetch
data you know any name of your choice
like this and this is going to wron the
call for our sanity studio so the
function that we just wrote out our get
rooms function like this which will be
coming from our lebs and API
folder okay so this get rooms function
and see over here it Returns the result
so in here let's not forget to call the
get rooms function so it's going to
return return our data and now we can
take this fetch data function and pass
it as the fetcher to this s SW hook so
this is going to handle the loading
State and we can get access to it here
so we can get access to the data error
and every other property so I'm going to
D structure data error and it's loading
and you know we still have more but
these are the most commonly used um
parameters so here let's first of all
check if we have an error we are going
to throw a new error like this which is
going to be CAU by our error boundary
and this new error we just going to make
use of the text so say cannot fetch data
and we are going to have another check
so in case it is done loading and we
don't have uh data so we're going to
check if type of data is equal to
undefined and like this we are not
fetching so have this is is loading like
this is false so if it's loading is
false and we don't have any data we want
to also go on and throw this error
cannot fetch
data so now we should have data and
let's log data to the console so
console. log data I'm going to save this
and let's see what we have going so if
we reload our browser and open the
terminal we actually get an error so use
effects change size so I think I think
we can actually do without the
dependency array and here the search
params I'm actually going to take this
off okay CU we're not going to be
needing it and we can refresh our
browser to see if everything works fine
now so this was actually a warning not
an error but I think we can just um do
without the dependency
array okay so we get on the find and
yeah so we get our data okay so we get
our data which is our rooms and if we
expand this you see we have the
different rooms with the property that
we are quering from our sanity studio so
so we have all these types over here for
our rooms and it's great so now we have
our room we can now make use of this
data okay so here I'm first I'm going to
get rid of the console. log and I have
this function which is going to help us
to apply our filters so this function
I'm going to call filters room and it's
going to take the rooms and this room is
going to be a room array so an array of
room and we're going to have our
function body
all right so if we come back to our apis
and if we h on rooms you see it returns
um any let's define the type for fetch
so this fetch let's say is going to
return return our room type so an array
of room like this and re Over You See It
returns our room array now we know that
data is going to be of type room array
like this rather than just of type any
and we see it can also be
undefined okay so we're going to have
handle the undefined case later but now
we want to filter through the rooms that
we are going to receive so let's have
all rooms and then we say filter and
filter is a
JavaScript method where we can apply to
arrays an array method which we need to
be done through a false Upon A Certain
condition and then the rooms that
reaches those condition is going to be
written just going to leave these
comments over here and then the second
comment for our search
query and these filter rooms we going to
get in the end are the rooms we going to
map through right than map through the
room that we get because you know the
room that we get from c. is the
unfiltered room so we're going to have
couple of checks first we're going to
check if the room type filter so if we
actually have a room type filter and
then we're going to convert that room
type filter to lower case like this and
we're going to check if is not equal to
the text of all so if this room type
filter is not equal to all if that is
true then we're going to go on and check
again if the rooms do type so now the
type that we have to lower case because
now we know the F the user want to
filter but the user doesn't want to
actually filter all so if it's not equal
to the room type filter to lower case
again to avoid any casing confusion we
are just going to go on and return
false
okay so room type filter is true then we
are checking if the room type filter to
lowercase if it's not equal to all now
if that is true we want to also go and
check if the room type lowercase is not
equal to the room type filter to
lowercase okay so if this doesn't match
we are going to go on and Ron false like
this so this is the filter for the room
type we need to also apply the filter
for the
search query so again we're going to
check if search query is true they want
to check if the room name so if the room
name doesn't include so if the room.
name do to lowercase like this do
includes so we're going to have this
include and if it doesn't include the
search query so this search query that
the user provides from the URL and we
shouldn't forget to also convert this to
lower case so if this is the case we are
also going to to return
false and after all of these we
shouldn't forget to return true okay so
now we have this we have our function
our filter room function we are going to
use it and pass our rooms so up here we
are going to have this Con filtered
rooms because that's what we're going to
get in the end we're going to get our
filtered rooms so we'll call our filter
rooms and we pass data so you know data
data can be undefined so we'll pass or
empty area like this so we are going to
be mapping to our filter room let's log
it to the console to sure that to be
sure that our Filter Works as
expected and here I need to get a valid
room name so I'm going to come over to
our sanity Studio rather than test I
want to get a valid room room name so
this room Delux suit I'm just going to
copy Deluxe to use it as search query
and let's also verify the type because
here we have basic so you see let scroll
down you see the type is suit okay so
let's also filter by this room type like
this and if we run this query take a
look at the console for the data we get
back so you see over here we get back
this data so our filter is working with
the name of the loog suit and all other
properties now we are sure our Filter
Works as
expected we need to render this filter
on the UI okay so I'll get rid of this
console.log and map through our filtered
rooms so first I'm going to give this
some styling and here I'm going to give
this the container styling and give it
an MX Auto give it a pattern to the top
of 10 and first I'm all just going to
return our setch
um components which will be coming from
our components folder so this search
over here and we already have the
parameters that it needs so it needs
this Prop Room type filter and room type
filter is going to be equal to the room
type filter and we're also going to pass
the search query so the search query is
going to be equal to the search query
here and it also needs the room type
filter so set room type filter is going
to be equal to set room type filter and
lastly it needs the set search query so
we're going to set it to search search
query so here we can now go on to map
through our filtered rooms so this is
what we have for our search
component okay so I'm going to have this
div and this div let's style it I'm
going to give this a class name of flex
imagin top of 20 and I'll also give it
justify between I'm going to give this
Flex wrap like this so in here we have
the corly brackets and then our filter
rooms map and map is going to map
through each room so here we're going to
have our room and that will just return
return an empty fragment here at least
for now we're going to return a card
component but we'll come to that we are
having this errors map okay all right so
that's because this is I think because
it's filter room it needs to be filtered
rooms sorry about that so we need to
match our filtered rooms that we just
saw moments ago
and now everything is working fine so
rather than with on empty fragments I'm
going to create a new component for our
room card so in the component folder
let's create a new folder I'll call this
folder rooms card and create the jsx so
room card. TSX file so I would make this
a react component get rid of the react
input and also go on to say this is an
type FC and FC that will take in some
props we don't have these prop types yet
so let's quickly Define it here so type
RS is going to be equal to object and
this is going to take the room which is
going to be our type room that comes
from our model
folder like this and here we are going
to receive the
props and we can go on to the structure
the room from the props so the structure
from the props like this this so here we
get the
room okay so in room we have different
properties we're going to come back to
those properties to the structure later
and let's style this uh room card so I'm
going to give it the class name of red
XL also give it a width of let's say 72
which is 18 R give this a margin bottom
of 10 give this an MX Auto I'm going to
give this on medium devices a margin X
of
zero and an overflow of hidden give this
a text of black like
this and in here we are going to go to
have another div and this is for more
like our image container so I'm going to
give this a height of 60 uh overflow of
hidden like this and in here we are
going to render our image component from
next image so I'll just move this to the
top like
this just close that to the f input and
this image is going to take in some
properties we know so it's going to take
in the image source and this source is
going to come from our room so which is
our cover image so remember our cover
image has the URL property so it's going
to be our cover image. URL and the out
we can now go on to the structure the
name also from our room so just after
the cover image I'll bring in the name
so let's also give this more properties
for the width I'll just give this a
width of 250 and the same for the height
so also give this a height of 250 pixels
let's not forget to style this image
I'll just go with the IMG which is our
own
costume
um class name and the scale animation so
that we just have the scale when we
overover on it all right so after this
image we are going to have another div
now this div is going to hold the the
name of the room and also the price so
this div over here and inside this div
we are going to have another div so I'll
give this div a class name of flex
justify between and for the text I'll
give it a text of 2XL and give this a
font of semi bold like this and in here
we're going to have paragraphs so this
paragraph is more like for the name and
the next paragraph is going to be for
the price we don't have this price yet
we are going to bring it in we're going
to destructure it from the room so let's
do that quickly let's just come over
here and let's bring in the
price so after this div which will show
the name and the price we can go on to
show the room type so let's have this
paragraph I'm going to give you some
padding to the top just to shift it
slightly away from the name and the
price and I'm just going to give this a
very small text so text EXT extra small
and in here we're going to have the type
and then the room so inside this
brackets let's have the type and we need
to bring in this type from the room like
this so I'm going to bring in the type
all right and after the type we have the
description okay so here I'm just going
to have another paragraph which I'll
give a pattern top of three and give
this a pattern bottom of six and here I
just want to show the description of the
room and I would also destructure the
description from the room like
this and if we come down after the
description we are going to have a
button so this button is actually going
to be a link so a link that will take us
to the um page where we can see more
about the room so the room Details page
and for that we need to bring in this
log so don't forget this log has the
current property and one also bring in
the is booked so here we're going to
have this href and this HF is going to
be dynamic so it's going to go to slash
rooms and then the SL log. current so
the um slug of the room which is the
room Details page and inside this link
we are going to have a check so if it's
booked you want to display another text
so we're going to display the text of
booked in all
uppercase and if it's not booked we are
just going to display the text of book
now like this
okay so let's startle this text I'm
going to give this text um this link
sorry a class name of BG primary and
then I'll give it an inline block like
this position the text in the center and
give this a withd full so we still have
more class names I'll give it a pattern
to the Y of four give it some border red
so rounded XL give this a text of white
so we have a white text in the in our
green background and then I'm going to
give this a text XL also give it a font
bold and on over I just want to
translate this to the Y AIS so Y2 I
think is going to be perfect in this
case all right so we also need to give
this um Shadow so I'll give it a shadow
LG on Hover and I'm going to trans all
and give it some animation duration so
give this a duration of 500 like this
and this is what we have going so now we
are going to use this component in here
so rather than we turn empty fragments
I'm going to return return that room
card that we just um defined and we're
going to pass in the key because we're
in the map and the key is going to be
the room ID so room doore ID and the
room is going to be equal to this room
room like this let's see what we have
going I'm going to save and if we come
back to the IDE we see this room which
is looking good so we get this H
animation and we have this book now we
have the type we have the description I
think the description is quite large we
can you know try to reduce it if we come
here to the room card component I will
just try to slice it and get the first
characters so here I'm going to say the
description slice so slice and or slice
from 1 to 50 and just add dot dot dots
yeah and let's preview what it looks
like um I think that's quite small so
I'll just Ram it up to 100 characters
and I think this this makes more sense
so we have our do Dot and then we have
the first 100 so let's go back to the um
homepage so that we don't have any
queries we see our spner which is
looking good and let's come over to the
room space page so I'll come here and we
see all other rooms here so the images
are loading up like this um I think the
name is quite distorted for some but
it's looking good and let's fix this so
let's fix the name and the price which
is looking distorted so for fixing this
I'll just
come I'll just come back to the IDE and
here this D where we have the name and
the price so here in our room card
not here where is it so here so I just
missed it here so here I'm going to
change it right than go with two XL I'll
just go with XL okay so text XL like
this let's save this and let's see what
it looks like I think this looks way
better than what we had
previously okay so I think this looking
good we see the different links you know
and here we see this so if we try to
filter you see we get suit already so we
can also filter luxury we don't have any
luxury room okay so let's go back to
basic and I will just take this um
executive room so I'll take this
executive room I'll come over to our
studio and I'll make this a LX room so
that we just have one room of that type
so let's look for where we have the room
type I'm just going to scroll and check
for where we have the room
type
where is it so this I'm going to choose
Lux and
publish and we can already come back to
our application and give it a Reload so
you see it's already left without even
reloading so if we come over to luxur
you see the luxur room here which is the
executive room that we just added if we
go to basic you see we now have three
basic rooms so everything is working
fine let's try to search so let's try to
search by executive you see we don't get
any search result but if we go to all
you see we have our executive room and
even if we go to suit we don't have any
if we come to luxury you see the
executive room here so everything seems
to be working fine and if we cancel our
search we see all other room results we
can go to the
homepage and now up next let's try to
search here so we try to search basic
and we just click search you see the
basic is populated here but we don't
have any search so you see set quer is
empty and we have the different rooms
okay so this is what we have going if we
click on one of these rooms here we are
redirected to a 4 for page so let's fix
this room Details page and here where we
have rooms I'm going to create this slug
like this and in here I'm going to
create this page. TSX so request coming
to/ rooms SL log is going to come into
this page so here we can have our jsx
and I'll get rid of the react inputs and
rather than page I'll call this room
details and this room details is going
to be receiving some props here and the
props is going to be of type
params now param is another object where
we receive the slog property and this
slog is going to be of type string and
so that we see our console um this log
in the console I'm going to make this uh
client
component making use of the use client
directive and here let's D structure the
slug from the
props and to do that here we are going
to first of all get params and from
params we are going to get Slug and we
can
console.log slug
here I'm going to save this and we have
this errors are we spotting yep we are
so now we see our hotel rooms component
and if we open the terminal we should
see the family suit so I just reload
which is this slog SL SL rooms and this
slog and here we see the slog great now
we sure we getting this slog let's fetch
data so to fetch data would come to our
leavs a pi. TS and in here we are going
to fetch our data so I'm going to export
this async
function like
this and this function I'm going to call
get
room and it's going to be called with
this slog because now we need to fetch a
room that belongs to a specific
Slug and we get our
results and our results we're going to
await our sanity client and here we call
Fetch and fetch is going to return us a
room like this and we can get it from
our queries and we don't have such query
yet so let's come to sanity
queries and let's export this Con get
rooms like this which is going to be
equal to this Gro
query so we want to get a
room where the underscore type is equal
to hotel
room sorry hotel
room and where the slog do current
remember the slog has the current
property is equal to the slug so use
dollar sign slug here this will return
an array so so we take the first element
and here we can request the parameters
that we need now this log is going to be
passed as params so this log here it
will come to api. TS and here we call
the gets room and here you see when we
pass params so this params we are going
to pass this slug
here and now this log is going to be
used in here like this okay so let's
continue here and in here we're going to
receive the underscore ID the
cover
image we're also going to receive the
description we're going to receive the
dimension the discounts also the images
is booked is
featured we're also going to receive the
name of the room the number of
beds
we're also going to receive the
offer
amenities the price the
slug the special
notes and we're going to reive the type
so I'm going to save this and come back
to
uh apis I'm going to copy this cash no
cash and actually use it
here like this and also use it here like
this we have our result we should not
forget to return our results so I'm
going to save this and let's be sure
everything has been done properly so
here in our page.
TSX first I'm going to go on and have
this um that we call our s SW AR
hook so I use S SWR hook like this and
it needs the key for the key I'll just
pass SL API slash room and then it need
the fetcher which I'll just Define up
here as
fetch
room so I'll copy this fetro and Define
it in here so fetro is going to be equal
to this function I can make it a sync
and here we're going to call get uh room
that we just def find in our
Libs and to this get room I'll pass in
our Slug and now we can get data I'll
just rename data to room we can also
get error and we can also get is loading
and then out come over to our page so
our room page.
TSX and I'm going to copy this check
that we have over here and I will paste
it in here like this sorry about that
and rather than data I call this room
and here we are just going to check if
there is no room we are going to return
return our loading spinner
component okay and here we can just
console. log room like this so if we
save this and here we should see our
room if we did everything fine and here
we see our room so we see this family
suit room we are currently looking at
now we are sure we are having our room
I'm going to get rid of this
console.log and in here we are going to
have our hotel Gallery component so
let's define this component first in the
component
we're going to call this hotel
photo gallery like
this and I'm going to copy this and have
the typescript file
here and quickly have this here so get
rid of the react input and import our
hotel photo gallery from here and we can
already pass the photos prop which is
going to be to our room do images here
I'm going to save this and now we are
going to be working in here so we can
already say this is going to be of type
FC and here it's going to receive
props and the props is going to be this
object we would have
photos and photos is going to be of type
an array of
images now we don't have this image Imes
yet here we come all we do in so models
room. TSX is over here we have this
image type so let's export this type so
we can make use of it so I'm going to
save and here out export so this will be
coming from our models like this so in
here we are going to have this class
name a class name of container and
you're also going to give this MX
Auto and in here we're going to have
another
div and the class name of this div is
going to be greed and MD we're going to
give it
grid uh where is it grid call
two give it position relative give it a
cap of five and give it a px of three
like this and inside this div we are
going to have another div a div that
will give the height of
540 pixels get this relative rounded to
XL overflow hidden like
this and in here we are going to have
this div another
div and I just give this D A Class name
of
hidden MD
Flex give this justify Center item
Center withth full and the height four
like
this so in here we are going to have
this image now the idea of this div um
is to have this section okay so we're
going to have two sections here this is
where we display other photo images and
this is where we display more like the
first image okay so inside this div we
are going to have this image so import
image from next image this will give an
error so I'll change this to as image
type over here and use this
here now this image we are going to give
it the source and the source is going to
be equal to
photos we haven't getting it here yet so
I'm going to D structure photos like
this and now we can make use of photos
and take the first photo
URL and for the alt the alt is going to
be dynamic so here we're going to have
the
room
photo and we're going to save some value
in state so here we're going to have
this um current photo
index and here Set current
photo index which is going to be equal
to use
State and have the default value of
zero so it's important we do it like
this and and I will not forget to make
this a client component
already isn't that use client
directive so we're doing like this
because we are going to be having a
model and we want to keep track of the
current photo we have so I'm just pass
the current photo index plus
one and we need the class name I'll give
it a IMG class name with our scale
animation class name and that also give
this a c pointer
yeah and for the width this will have a
width of 150 pixels and the height of
pixels all right it will also have an
unclick Handler and then click we uh
once we click on this image so this
image we have here we want to show a
model so we're going to have this open
model um function that is going to take
in the index so here open model which is
going to take in the index and here we
can call do
bind like this and we'll pass this and
then we'll pass zero so as the index so
the first image that's why we're passing
zero here all right so we don't have
this function let's define this function
so here comes open model is going to
take in the index which is going to be
of type
number like this and now we have this
index we are going to use it in here to
set the current photo index to this
index and here we going to have this
const that will say show model and here
set show model like
this which is going to be equal to use
State and by
default it's going to be false and here
when we open the model we're going to
set show
model to
true all right so after this image just
here we are going to have another div
now you see this div is going to be
hidden by default and this is a div that
shows on uh large devices and this are
that div is for mobile devices so I'm
actually going to duplicate this because
they are very much alike and this other
div is going to show the photo with the
current photo index and URL like this
this Remains the Same since we on mobile
we're not going to have the C pointer
and the um scale animation and this is
going to call open model so if we save
this and we have a first preview we see
this image and we go on mo mobile we are
going to see the other image so we don't
see because we still have this hidden so
we want it to be hidden from mum devices
and on mobile is going to show now so
this div over here all right so now we
are done with this if we click on this
you know we don't see our model we are
going to be fixing that
next but we can now come on to collapse
this div so this div that we just worked
on and to show the user count we're
going to have this other
div and this is only going to be visible
on um mobile devices so here we're going
to say empty
hidden and display this as Flex justify
between like this items
Center and in here we are going to have
this other
div going give it a class name of flex
space X2 like this and in here we're
going to have fa Arrow
left that we import from react icons
for/ fa and we can already import fa
Arrow
right
sorry like this and here we are going to
make use of the fa
AR right like this so for the click
event here I'm going to give this a
class name of C
pointer and now for the click event
we're going to have two
functions so handle
previous for the backward image so for
the one that goes left and this is going
to be handle next
I'll come back to this um shortly
because these are just going to help us
to slide through the different images
but here I'm going to have this span
tag and here we want to display the
current image count so here we're going
to display our current photo index plus
one and we're just going to have this
where we display the
photos that
length like
this okay
just like this and here we can go on to
define the handle previous and the
handle next so that we can swipe through
the different um images so here I'm
going to have this Con handle
previous which is going to be equal to
this aror function here and in here
we're going to set current photo index
then we get the previous
index
and we're going to check our previous
index that is equal to zero so we're
going to say our
photos. length minus
one otherwise we minus one from the
previous index so this is going to
update our previous index okay and then
we can have a handle next function to go
to the next image so this is going to be
equal to this AR function and here we're
going to set our current photo index
where we have the previous index we're
going to return our previous index if
this is equal to our photos.
length minus
one we use zero okay so we're going to
set it to zero otherwise we have our
previous
index plus one
so this is going to help us to navigate
to the next photo and you see here this
is going to be visible only on mobile
devices so if we come here we don't see
it yet and if we open and go to mobile
you see here we now see this and if we
click you see we are going to the
different photo images so this is
working great and that's expected so we
need to we need to show show this other
section on desktop I think we should
work on it next so displaying this other
section and we are going to map through
the different images that we have so the
rest of the photo images to display here
and we want to also keep track of the
counts so before we start um
mapping we're going to have this Con
here and this Con we're going to call it
display
photos
and this is going to be equal to
photos do slice not slice do slice and
from one we need to know the maximum
visible photos that we want to show so
con we can have this
Maxum visible
photos and this is going to be let's say
two like this and here we're going to
start splicing from one to the maximum
visible photos minus one just like this
okay so actually I'm just going to make
this
three and here we're going to have our
remaining photos
count here which is going to be equal to
our total photos and our total
photos is just going to be our photos
length
here so here is going to be equal to our
total
photos and we're going to minus our
maximum visible photos here so now we
are going to show sorry now we're going
to show
our display photos so we're going to map
through our display photos and this will
show the remaining photos
count so if we come down here we're
going to have another
div and let's Di itate we're going to
give it a class name of hidden because
we don't want it to show on mobile
devices and on medium devices we will
display it as a grid we also have grid C
to here give it a height full and give
this a gap of
five so inside this div now we're going
to go and map to our display photos do
map where we get each
photo and let's just have this call back
because we also need the index and we
are going
to return this
div like this because we are mapping we
need to give this div a key and the key
is going to be the index and let's style
it I'll give the class name of C pointer
give it a height of
64 give this red 2
XL and give this a overflow of
hidden so now inside this div we can
have our image component from next
image to show the remaining images so
this is going to have a width of
150 a height of
150 a source of uh
photo. URL like this it's going to also
have an alt and the alt is going to be
dynamic so we're going to have a room
for
photos uh room photo and then we have
our the last sign back tick where we
display the index plus two like this and
let's give it a class name so we're
going to give it class name which is
going to be IMG and
scale
animation all right so this is for the
image and for the remaining photo counts
just here so just after this here but
still inside this div we have so here
we're going to have our remaining photos
count we want to check if this remaining
photo count is greater than zero so if
that is true we are going to show this
div and this div is going to have the
class name of C pointer relative a
height of
64 rounded to XL and overflow of hidden
like
this and it's also going to have an
onclick to open the model so here on
click we're going to call open model and
we use do
bind and we'll just pass this and then
we're going to pass the maximum visible
photos
here okay so now inside this div we can
go on to show our
image from next
image and let's give this a width of
150 let's also give it a height of
150 let's give it the source and the
source is going to be equal to our
photos and here we have our maximum
visible photos minus one and we can
assess the URL property and for the alt
we're going to give it this alt where we
say uh room
photo and here we have a maximum visible
photos like
this and let's give us a class name of
IMG now this is the image but we don't
just want to show the image so let's see
if we have something like that let's go
for a room where we have more images so
let's see if we have more images
here and let's check on
room let's check
executive we don't let's check the
family
suit we maybe don't let's check our
featured room so it looks distorted here
I just
reload okay so let's check
this and we wait for it to load um Let
me let me just reload
this okay so these are the images and
let's see so let me change this to
two and we see this okay so now we want
to see this image but we don't want to
actually see um just the image like this
we want to show the count so to show the
count just after this image we're going
to have this div where will say plus uh
remaining photos count so we just have
the plus here and inside this div we're
going to have this class name of
absolute give it a c
pointer give it a text of white give it
insert Zer give it Flex justify
Center give it a this background where
we give it this R
GBA and
then
0 z0
0.5 give it a item Center and give it a
text of two Excel so now if we save this
and we come back here you see we see
plus three okay so we see we have plus
three images and we can say here so
maximum visible images it we say four
let's see what we have now we see plus
one so one 1 two 3 and four okay so this
is working as
expected all right so after this we want
to show the model because clicking on
this now doesn't show any model and also
clicking on you know this doesn't show
any model all right so to fix this let's
come just after this div I'm going to
collapse and here we are going to have
this div so it's more model
open uh or what we call it show model so
show model if show model is true then we
want to have this div so this is going
to have a class name of
fixed a top of
zero uh a width
full uh height full uh
Flex justify center items Center a BG
black like this a BG opacity of
90 and a z index of
55 okay and inside this div we would
have this other
div and now this is the div that would
have the image so let's give it a height
of 75 viewport height and a width of
let's say
pixels
and on medium
devices like this I'm going to give this
a width of
pixels and give it position
relative so now inside this div we are
going to have our
image and the source is going to
be from our
photos and here our current photo
index. URL like
this and the alt is going to be equal to
uh room
photo and here we have the current photo
index plus one like
this and it's going to have a width of
150 and the height of of 150 like this
and we just give it a IMG class name
because this is the model we not just
add the scale
animation so this is what we have next
and after this we want to show two
arrows and uh count so I think we had
that before so where did we have it
let's
see so I want to show this so I want to
show these two arrows and they count so
I'm actually going to copy
this div so I'll copy this div over
here and I will use it
here so it's not going to be hidden like
this so I'll just give it Flex because
we want to show the model on both um
desktop and mobile and we're going to
give item Center and just give it to
pattering y of three and here we're
going to give it Flex space X2 we can
also position the items in the center
and get this a text white like this and
we have this Arrow now we have this
other arrow and we have the span okay so
this span we can style
it and give it a text
white okay and give it a text SM like
this so we need to have a way to close
the model and just outside this div so
outside this div here here we're going
to have another div sorry not on that
div we are going to have a button and
the div should be
here and this button is just going to
show the MD cancel from Material
design okay react icons MD and for class
name I'm going to give this a class name
of font medium give it a text 2 XL and
give it a text tertiary
dark like
this and on click of this button we are
just going to call close
model what did we call it so let's see
model do we call this show
model we don't have the close model
functionality so let's define it so cons
close model it's just going to be this
function
like this so we set show model to
for and now we can call close model here
like this and let's start this button I
give it a class name of absolute give it
a top of two a right of
two not
ring give this sorry give this a right
of two give it a text white and give
this set Tex LG like this and if we come
back here now I'm just going to reload
our
application and if we click any of these
images we should see our model
displaying so I'll click on this we see
a model it's a little bit distorted but
let's see the functionality works yeah
so it's a little bit distorted and let's
fix that so here where do we have it so
this our show model fix top zero and we
should give it left zero like
this so let's see if that fixes it we
try again and yeah so this fixes it and
we see our model but now the image isn't
correctly positioned because this is
should be 75
VH okay and now we see our model works
fine so we can close our model and if we
go to mobile device device and we click
on this we see our model great and it's
working fine and we can come over to
other rooms so you see our rooms over
here and if we click on another room so
if we just click on this room we come to
the room Details page and we see this
the room images now we are done with
this let's continue and next we are
going to add more life to this section
where we can Now show some deson or some
details about this hotel
room all right so and for this section
let's come back to code and I'll get rid
of everything we've got
here and we can come over to our app web
rooms the slug and then the slug page so
this page over here and after this we
are going to have this div and this is
going to have the class name name of
container and MX
Auto and also Imagine to the top of 20
like
this so inside here we're going to have
this div and this div on medium devices
we are going to display it as grid and
the medium devices we are going to give
this grid Cod 12 give this a gap of
10 and give it a p on the x-axis of
three so now inside this div remember we
gave this div um grid Cod 12 so now
inside here we are going to have this
div okay and this is going to have a
class name of on medium devices we're
going to go co span
8 and then on medium devices I would
also give it the full width okay now
this is going to have the hotel
information
and after this we are going to have
another div and this other div here
let's style it so this div is
the is going to be our book room C here
so our book room call to action
component and we can already styled it
so medium devices I'm going to give
this uh Co span 4 so this is going to
span eight and then this is going to
span four giving a total of
12 okay and we're going to give it red
XL
Shadow
LG and on du we'll just give it a lower
Shadow so Shadow like
this and on dark let's color the give
the shadow a color of white so Shadow
white like this we position it STI and
then 10 pixels not 10 pixels I think
that's 40 pixels so top 10 like this yep
so that's 4 40 pixels from the top give
it a height of feet to fit the content
and an overflow of
Auto all right so now we are going to be
working in this hotel information
section we don't see anything yet but
this is where we are going to be working
in so in here let's have this div so
without any class name and now we're
going to display the room name and the
dimension so this
H2 is going to have this class name of
font bold text left and text LG and on
medium devices text to XL like this and
inside here we are going to have a room.
name and just in parenthesis we are
going to have our room do description
and we save and we come back to
application not description sorry uh
Dimension so room. Dimension so we save
and we come back to application now we
see the room name and we see the
dimension okay so here we're going to
display the amenities next so after this
H2 we are going to have this div and
we're going to give the class name of
flex and imagine y of 11 like this and
in here we're going to have a room.
offer amenities and we're going to map
through each and then we get each
amenity and we're going to return
return this
div
here okay because we're in the map we
need to provide a key and the key is
going to be equal to The Amity doore key
and for styling on medium devices I
would give this uh width of
44 uh width sorry so a width of 44 like
this I'm just trying to create more like
a box where we can display a font aesome
icon and also the Amity name then I'll
give this width of
fet give it a text
Center give it a padding on the xaxis of
two give it on medium devices a padding
on the x-axis of zero give this a height
of 20 and medium devices a height of 40
give this some margin on the right Axis
of three and give it this BG so this
slight gray color like this with this
head code # e ff0
F2 and on that mode we are going to get
this a BG gray of
800 we're going to give this red LG like
this display this as a greed and place
content Center like this so first we are
going to have this
icon it's not going to show up because
we don't have the font aome CDN but the
class name is going to be dynamic like
this and here we're going to display fa
a solid so font awesome solid and here
we have our amenity do
icon okay and we're also going to give
this on medium devices a text to
Excel and that's all for the icon and
here we're going to have this
paragraph where we are going to display
the amenity name so I think we call it
amenity so it's also going to be this an
amenity we receive here and then we're
going to assess the amenity property and
we should also style this paragraph So
this is going to have a class name of
text extra small and the medium devices
text base and give it a pattern to the
top of three so if we check go back to
application we're not going to see this
font awesome icon so let's see if we
come back here you see we don't see the
font or some icon and in order for us to
see it we will just come here and we
need to add this CDN link so it we come
to web and we come to our layout. TSX so
in here we're just going to have the
head tag and in the head tag we're going
to add a link to point to
CSS okay so the H I'm just going to
replace this H here with this link that
goes
to um this link that goes to font
awesome like this and we can also
already have the cross origin and send
this to Anonymous like this so if we
save this and we come back here now we
see we display the icons we don't see
this icon for the private Garden so
perhaps we must have you know missed
this icon somewhere but at least we see
our icon shop so why do we have because
you see this actually look looks
distorted so let's see what we are
missing so we give the
width um withd fet Tex Center PX of two
and M medium devices PX of Z give a
height of
20 and height M3 we give it this
background yeah so this should be great
like
this now if we save this and we come
back yeah so this looks better we don't
see the icon here so maybe we chose the
wrong icon so that's why I said it's
always important to choose the correct
icon so that you have the icons display
okay so let's continue and after this
section here we are going to have
another section for the description okay
so after this div just here we are going
to have another that div and I'm going
to give this a class name of margin
botom 11 and in here we can have the
H2 and this H2 we're going to give a
class name of font bold we're also going
to give a text 3 Excel and then imine
bottom of two like this and here we can
display the the text
description like this so after this um
H2 we are going to have this B tag where
we then go to display the room do
description so let's save and let's see
if we see our description shop so this
is our description like this and this is
the text okay so after this so I'm just
going to collapse this or maybe we just
continue all right so after this div
we're going to have this other div and
we just give it a class of maging bottom
11 so just like this div here actually
I'm going to collapse this div and also
collapse this for the description and
now we have this where we show the
different amenities so here inside this
div we are going to have this H2 and
inside this H2 we say they
offered amenities like
this and in here I'm going to give this
a class name of font bold and give this
a text 3 XL like this and give us a imin
bottom of
two all right so inside this H2 we are
going to have this div and I'm going to
give this a class name of grid and give
this grid code to like this and here I'm
going to say our room do amenities off
amenities and map just as we did
previously and here we have each
amenity and we are going to Reon this
div here like
this and we should give this a key and
the key is going to be equal to the
amenity doore
key so inside this div we can display
the icon and the amenity as we had
before so I'm going to give this a class
name of on medium devices I'll give this
a class of text
base sorry I just give it the class of
flex as we had previously items Center
and on medium devices I'll give this
some margin y of Z
and give it a margin y of one so in here
we are going to display the icon as well
as the text so I'm just going to copy
this and paste it in here like
this so this should be 1 M so that means
we had the typo over this I'm going to
save this and fix the typo that we just
saw
here okay so it should be one M like
this
and if we save let's see if we see this
section okay we see this section and our
styling looks to be off again so where
did I miss the styling so here we
display GD grid code to and then inside
this div we give class Flex item
Center so everything seems to be fine
I'll get rid of
this text size here
and give this uh medium devices text
base
text uh right pattern top I'm going to
give it a margin left of two so if I
save this and we have another preview I
think this looks better now we having
this error with the cing because we
don't have any icon so let's try to see
another room just see the executive room
and here we don't have this other icon
so I chose icons that were not you know
F awesome that's why we don't see the
icons display so it's important to
choose font a some icons so that it
display okay so this room has you know
all the icons great so we can continue
working and after the offered amenities
we can just go into display another
section for safety and hygiene okay so
I'm going to collapse this div and here
I'll have another div and I'll give this
a class name name of Marin bottom
11 and here I would have a H2 I say
safety and
hyene like this and quickly sty this
font
Bard and giv us a text 3
Excel and give this a imin bottom of two
so after this we are going to have this
div and I'll give you the class name of
of grid and grid call two like this and
in here I'm going to have this other
div and the class name is going to be
Flex item
Center my of one and then on medium
devices my Z like this and here we're
going to have this MD
outline um
cleaning services like this and just
after this we are going to have this
paragraph so
here we're going to have this
paragraph okay just like this and inside
this paragraph We just say daily
cleaning okay so let's starty this
paragraph I'm going to give this a class
name
of
ml2 on medium devices get text base
and give this
uh text extra
small like
this text extra
small okay so if we save this and we
have a quick preview we should see this
section here so our safety and hygiene
and I'm just going to duplicate this so
just this I'm going to bring it down
couple of
times
and next we're going to have
after um daily cleaning we can change
this to fire extinguisher so I'm going
to use this l i a and f i r e going to
take this off so that I can get Auto
comption so l i a f i r e we don't get
so let's import it manually and this the
opportunity to rearrange our order of
inputs
here so I'm going to import this coming
from react
icons for/ L A like this and this is
going to be L
fire extinguisher solid and we can also
import from react icons for/
aai and this is going to be the AI
outline medicine box and we can already
import
the from GI so here we're going to have
this GI
smoke um bomb great so let's come back
here and now we're going to have our
Auto completion so this is going to be L
fire still don't get the auto comption
so I have to copy it manually okay and
paste it in here all right so this is
for this and here I'm going to to have
the text
of
fire
gous okay so that's for that and this is
going to be the AI outline medicine box
and here we're going to have the
text this infections and
sterilizations steril
iations like this l i a
yeah r i
sterilizations okay so after this we're
going to have this where we just display
the GI smoke bomb and this is going to
go with the text of
smoke
detectors okay so let's save and let's
see if everything came out
clean did we save it yes we did and here
we don't see so let's um reload our
application to be sure that everything
works fine it's taking some time to
build okay yeah so this is it for this
section and after this section next we
are going to have a review section
okay so I'm going to collapse this and
now after this we are going to have a
review section so we're not going to you
know have this review but we can already
map out the components we're going to
have this div which I'll give the class
name of
Shadow give it uh on dark
mode
here give this a shadow white and give
this red LG and give it a padding of six
and in here we're going to have this
this div and I'll give this class name
of item
Center and give it a margin bottom of
four and in here we're going to have
this
text which we're going to just style and
say on medium devices give it a large
text and font semi bold like this and
here we have customer
reviews okay so after this div so after
this we are going to have another div
and this is a that is going to display
the review component so I'll give this a
class name of grid a grid calls let's
say one and a medum devices get this
grid C
two and get this a capap of four so in
here we are going to have our reviews so
I'm going to cut this and paste this in
here like this so if we save and we come
back we should see the text yeah so we
see this customiz reviews and we see
this Shadow over here so I'm just going
to go to our dark team and we see our
customer review section here which is
going now going to contain the different
reviews but we don't have this yet so
now we can focus on the booking section
of our
application we are going to first start
with
the we're going to first start with the
component and then we're going to
proceed to integrate strip
payment so we can already create this
component if we come to our component
folder so here let's have this book room
CTA
component and have the jsx
file and have
this so I'm going to remove the react
input and already make this a client
component
and then import this inside here so here
uh book room C
here should be
imported so here all right so let's come
back to this we check the browser now we
see our book room sit here like this and
we see the little Shadow we have and you
see it's already sticky okay so you see
because of the position sticky that we
set on this book room all right so now
we have
this rest style it more so we're going
to give this a class name of
px7 and uh py of
six and then we're going to have this
heading so this heading isn't going to
have any class name and then we're going
to have this span now this span is going
to have some class names and we need to
have access to the discount to be able
to style this properly so we need to
calculate the discount and to calculate
discount we need to also you know have
the price so you're going to say this is
an FC for functional component and we
can have the
props which is going to be equal to an
object and we are just going to ask for
the price at least for now which is of
type number and we also going to add for
ask for the discount which is of type
number so I'm going to pass this props
over to
this
here and here I'm going to get the
props okay so we're going to D structure
these
values from our props like
this and we are going to get our price
and and also get our discount from here
so to calculate our discount price so
let's have our discount price is going
to be equal to our price and here we're
going to subtract our price divided by
100 and we're going to multiply this by
the
discount so this is going to give us our
discount price and now inside the span
we can show the discount price somewhere
here but for styling purposes we are
going to say if we have discount so
here if discount is
true if it's a true the value then we're
going to have this text grade
400 otherwise we are just going to have
an empty
string like this
and we
always we always want to have this fonts
B and then text extra
LGE all right so now inside this pan we
can go on to display the price so I'm
going to have the the sign here and we
would have the price
here and after this we want to also show
the discount so here we're going to
check if discount is true then we're
going to show this
span and
otherwise we would show nothing we'll
just show an empty string so now this
pan is going to show our discount price
that we have
calculated so here we are going to show
our discount price and we're going to
style this so this is going to have this
font
bold and it's going to have this text XL
not left text X um LG sorry not LG extra
large like
this and we're going to have this text
so after this P here we're going to have
this pipe and then have
discounts and display our
discounts like
this and show the
percentage okay and then we can have
some full stop and then we have
now
and in this now I'm just going to have
another
span okay and now inside the span that's
where we are going to have this discount
price okay I think it's going to make
more sense when we interpret it so text
test shary deck so this is more like
showing the user the price in this pan
and then if discount is true we want to
then tell the user you know the discount
price so the discount
and then the price now we have errors
because we need to provide the necessary
props and for now it needs the discount
and discount is going to be equal to uh
room.
discount and it also needs the price
which is going to be called room. price
like this so let's save come back to the
browser and we see this so $100 and then
we see the discount which was 8% and now
is
$92 so I want to give a gap between
these dollars and this uh percentage
this pipe here so where do we have the
pipe um in our book room CTA just here
so I'm going to give this space like
this and save this and if we come back
now we have the space so this $100 and
now discount
8% is now 92 perc so if we check some
other
rooms I'll just check this family suit
300 it doesn't have a discount and we
can confirm if Rec did we call it um I
think we have an error here so let's
reload this this is family suit so let's
wait for our studio to
reload Okay
so
let's
see so family suit if we check we don't
have any discount and that's why we
don't see the discount TCH so it's
already working and if we check this we
have a discount yeah we have a 20%
discount and that's why the price is now
$400 so great it's working as expected
so after this H3 we are going to have we
going to have this div which is actually
going to be self
closing and now we can style this I'll
give it to with P give this a border
bottom so border
bottom two give this a border bottom
secondary and give a margin y of
two and let's see what it looks like so
so this over here and after this we are
going to have our special notes so I
have this div and here we'll just
display our
special
notes which we need to bring in so
rather than I think I'll use a
H4 and I'll get this NY
of8 so let's bring in this special notes
so bring it in
here and bring it in here which is going
to be of type string and we can now
request it from here so the special
notes which is going to be equal to the
room does special notes like
this and let's have a
preview so we see the special notes here
and let's be sure this application is
responsive and yes our application is
fully
responsive okay
so after this special notes we are going
to have a div where we display some date
Piers so here we're going to give this
uh class name of flex like this and in
here we're going to have another div and
this div is for the checkin date so to
have a label and the HTML 4 is going to
be check in
dates and this D is going to have the
styling so the class name of this div is
going to be with
50% and it's going to have a pattern to
the right of two and this label is going
to display the text check in date like
this and let's style this we are going
to give this a class name of block give
this a text
xsm give this a font medium give a text
Gray 9
100 yeah and on dark mode I'm going to
give this a text Gray of 400 like this
and here we display the check in date so
now we need our date pier and I would
open the terminal and I'll quit
determiner now and
npm install react date Pier like this so
we will just wait for it to install or
we could use it already so I would come
here and in here I would import date
Pier that would come from react date
Pier Library we just installed since we
need to install the types so mpm install
save Dev this type out copy and paste
this in here like
this okay so while that's installing we
can already import okay it's done so
let's restart the application
using npm rund Dev so we can already
import the CSS file in here I'm just
going to import the react date pier and
there we have the this folder and there
we have the react date
picker. CSS file
here so now this date picker we are
going to use it here so after this label
we are going to have this um so in in
here we are going to display the date
Pier component and it needs a prop and
now it needs so many props so first
selected we are going to come back to
this it also needs the unchange we are
going to come back to this and we can
pass the date format so the date format
Al go is day and here month and then the
year and you we can also pass
the disabled prop cuz I actually wanted
to be disabled you know
and so I'll get rid of disabled prop
okay and we can also pass the minimum
date okay we want the minimum date to be
the current date so I'll set this to new
date like
this and here we can already give it an
ID and the ID is going to be this
checking date from the label so that
that's going to be our
ID and let's style it I'll give it a
with
full and give this a border and give
this a text black give this a border
gray
300 like this get this red LG give this
speed
2.5 and focus like this give this ring
primary
ring
primary like
this and on
forus I'll give this border
primary border primary like this I don't
know we can have a variant no we can't
so put that primary like this and we're
going to have an error because we need
to pass the unchange and we need to pass
the select selected prop so selected is
going to be the check in
date okay and on change we need a
function to update the setting um
checking date so we can call uh we're
going to get the date from this function
and then we can call a function so set
check in date like this and we're going
to pass the
date
gosh okay so now we need to receive all
of these uh from props as
well so the checking date I am going to
receive it here and this is going to be
of type date or null like
this okay and then we have the set check
in dates which is going to be of type
dispatch because it's going to be coming
from State and here we're going to have
the set State
action and we're going
to know have a type of date or null in
our state that's the type of action
we're going to dispatch and here we can
now bring in check-in date and then
set checkin date like this and let's
save this and now we need to pass the
props to this book now C here so so we
need to handle them instead so I would
just come just after this props and here
I would have
the checkin date and then I would have
the set checkin date like this this is
going to be equal to UST
State and UST state is imported from
react I'll just rearrange this and UST
state is going to have a default value
of
null and for typescript this is going to
be of type date or null like this okay
so we can already have the state for the
checkout date so check out
dates like
this and here we have set check out
dates and every other value Remains the
Same okay so let's pass the props here
going to pass the checkin date to be
called to checkin date and here the set
checkin date to be called to set checkin
dates like this so we can save and let's
have a
preview we don't see anything is the
application up and running yes it is so
I'm just going to reload the browser and
we wait for it to reload let's be sure
yep so application is up and running and
now it loads
up and nothing shows okay yeah so this
is our application and we have our
checkin dates okay and in user clicks
here we have this okay so now we have
this component
here like this okay so next we can have
a checkout date so just after this
check-in date we are going to have our
checkout date so I think I can just
duplicate
this here and bring this down so these
are checkout dates and rather than give
it a pattern um right of two this is
going to have a pattern left of two and
the HTML 4 is going to be checkout date
and The Styling here Remains the Same
and we're going to update this text to
check out date and here we have the date
picker so selected is going to to be
check out
date which we're going to bring in from
props and on change is going to be set
check out um date and this is the date
format it's going to be
disabled and it's going to be disabled
if uh if there is no checking date so if
the user hasn't provided any checking
date the checkout date is going to be
disabled and now we for the minimum date
we are going to have a function that is
going to calculate the
minimum um checkout date so we're going
to come back to
this and for the ID I'm just going to
copy this ID
here and use it in here like
this and for this other section I think
everything you know Remains the Same
okay so let's have this checkout date
and set checkout date so here
I think I'm going to duplicate this CU
it's very much iik so just change the
name to check out date and here set
checkout date and then we can break it
in from the props so checkout date and
also set checkout date so we have an
error to calculate the minimum date
we'll come back to read let's just pass
the prop so check out date is going to
be called to check out date and then set
checkout date is going to be equal to
set checkout date so let's save this and
here in the book room CTA let's have
this function to calculate the minimum
date so we can call this
C minimum um checkout date like this and
let's define this function and
here this receive the
function and here
let's define it so this calculate
minimum checkout date is going to be
this
function that is going to return the
date or it's going to return no like
this okay so here we are going to have
the function so
calculate minimum check out date is
going to be equal to calculate minimum
checkout
date so let's define it somewhere where
here um where so I think I'm just going
to Define it here so going to have this
Con calculate minimum check out date
which is going going to be equal to this
function and here we're going to check
if we have a checkin date then we are
going to calculate um the checkout date
otherwise we would return M like
this
okay so so here we are going to first of
all get access to the next day so the
next day is going to be equal to new
dates and then we we passing the checkin
dates okay and then we want to set the
day so we want to set the date of the
next day so call the next
day like this and then we want to set
date and this date is going to be the
next day and then do get date like this
and we want to add
one so we go and return return the next
day like
this so if there's no checking date we
will just going to return null okay so
they will calculate the minimum checkout
date and we are going to use it here so
let's see what we have now we have our
checkout dates and you see is disabled
okay so it disabled until we select uh
checkin date so I'll select let's say
tomorrow and you see I chose 11 and if
we see the checkout date it starts at 12
okay so it starts at 12 and this you
know starts at 11 now we enabled it the
user can still now go on and select you
know let's say 20 which is not um
doesn't make sense so you can't check in
on the 20 and then check out some days
behind we are going to handle
the logic to restrict such operation but
for now everything is looking good let's
continue so after this so after this um
div we are going to have another div so
after this here so here we're going to
have this div and we're going to give a
class name of flex and then Marin top of
four and here let's have this other div
I'll give the class name of we with um
1/2 and give this sub pattern to the
right of two like
this and in here we have this
label and HTML for
adults and let's give it this class name
of
block text
SM font
medium text Gray
900 like this and adducting text G
400 okay so inside this label we are
just going to have the text of
adults okay because the user would also
have the chance to choose the number you
know of adults and after this we're
going to have this
input and this input is going to be of
type
number and is going to have the ID of
adults to match with the
label and for
Value this going to have the value of
adults which we don't have yet we would
come back to that and on
change now we're going to have this
function which takes the event and set
adult which we don't have
yet and we're going to set adult to
the event do
Target do
value
okay and we are going to give this a
minimum of one so let's say we want to
you know have minimum of one by default
and let's want to have a maximum of five
so give this a width
full give this a border you just say B
grade
300 like this get this run
LG give this spe
2.5 and on Focus State get this
ring I think we don't even need this on
the focus State and all of that so I'll
just get rid of it okay so we need the
adult and set adults so here I'm just
going to have
const adults and also set adults is
going to be equal to use State and have
a default value of one we're also going
to have for children so has a default
value of
zero children and here we can have
set children like
this and we can ask for this from the
props so
adults and also children like
this okay and we
can have this so I'll bring this down
twice so this is going to be for set set
adults and here we're going to dispatch
type number and for this we're going to
have set
children and here we're going to
dispatch of type number like this and to
get rid of the errors we just bring it
bring in these for our props so set
adults set
children and adults and also children
because we're going to be needing
children soon so here
here we have set adults to event Target
value we're having this error because
this is going to be a string and we need
number can just add a plus here and it
gets rid of the error so I'll save this
and here we can pass the
prop so here we can pass um adults equal
to adults we can pass children which is
going to be equal to Children you can
also pass set adults which is going to
be called to to set set adults we can
also pass set children which is going to
be equal to
set children like this so we have an
error
here um do not pass children as props
instead n children okay so it doesn't
know
um okay so let's see we're just going to
rename it to rather than children I just
say number of
children like this and here I would say
set
number of
children okay so children is going to be
number of children and here set number
of children I'll use this here and I
would use this here like this and update
our book room CS so rather than children
I'll call it number of
children and use it here and then rather
than set children I would say set number
of children like
this and bring this in here okay so this
fixes it and we should see our input so
if we check now we see
adults and we don't see for children yet
so let's add
it so I will actually duplicate this so
I will just duplicate
this and this is going to have P to the
left of two a label for
children and the class name is actually
going to remain the same and here I have
the text of children the type is going
to the number the ID is going to be
children like this it's going to have
the value
of
children so number of children and on
change we're going to set um number of
children like this to PR taret value the
minimum is going to be zero and let's
say the maximum is going to be three for
our
application and everything should be
fine now so if we reload we see children
here okay so that's working fine next
let's have um this section that helps us
to display the price to the user
so we're going to have a function to
calculate the number of days so
somewhere here let's have this function
I'm going to call c number of
days like this and this is going to be
equal to this function so we want to
want to return return if there is no
checkin date or there is no checkout
dates okay so if there's none we are
going to return return zero like
this so first to calculate the number of
days we're going to have the time
difference and the time difference is
going to be check out
date going to Beal to check out date.
get time and we're going to subtract
this from our check in date like this do
get time here and now we have the time
difference we can now convert the time
difference to days and here you can call
this number of days and this is going to
be called to
mat.
se and we're going to pass our time
difference divided by 24 multip by 60
and multiply by 60 and multiply by
1,000 so this is going to give us the
number of days and now we
can return return the number of this so
return return number
of days like
this so here I'm going to copy this and
we can come below here and after this
div so after this that displays the
adults and children I'm going to
collapse this so after this we are going
to have this section where we call this
calculate number of days it returns a
number and we check if the number is
zero then we want to go on and display
this um P tag okay so we're going to
display this paragraph
tag and otherwise we are just going to
display an empty fragment like this so
let's start this I'm going to give this
paragraph class name of margin top of
three and in here I'll just have total
price and the total price in dollars is
going to be this
calculate number of days like this and
multiply it by a discount
price so if we save this and we come
over to the
browser we don't see anything because we
haven't chose the number of days so here
I'll choose 10 and say I want to check
out um on 13th and now we see our total
price like this okay so we have 400 and
we stay 3 days so that gives
1,200 all right so now let's have our
book Now button so just after this we
can have our
button and this button is going to be
having this class names so but Buton
primary and it's going to have a width
full a margin top of six and it's going
to be disabled you know have this um
color on the disabled States so BG gray
uh
500 and if it's disabled we're going to
have this
cursor not
allowed like this so this button if this
hotel room is booked so we also need to
receive this Pro so if it's booked we
are going to display the text
of
booked like this otherwise we are going
to show the text of book now like
this so we have this error because we
don't have this is booked property and
it's going to be disabled if this room
is booked like this and on click we're
going to call a function
the handle
book now
click like
this all right so now we need to pass
this is booked and also the handle book
now click
function so here we are going to receive
is booked which is going to be of type
bowling and we can bring it here to our
props and we also need to bring in the
handle book now
click and this is going to be equal to a
function that returns void so we can
take this function and pass it in here
so I'm going to save this and we come
here we need to pass the two props so
it's
booked is going to be equal to Rooms or
room do is booked like this
and the handle book now click is going
to be equal to handle book now click we
don't have this yet and this is for our
booking so just somewhere here I'm just
going to have this function and it's not
going to be doing anything at least for
now okay so let's come back to the
application and we see the textbook now
because this room isn't booked so you
see we have this um sticky and we can
come to other rooms to test out the
functionality let's see if our Filter
Works so a basic room maybe this
one and it doesn't have a discount so if
we want to stay for you know two days
the room should be 600 so because the
unit price is 300 so everything is okay
now we can work
on before work on the booking Fe fature
let's just test that when we call these
functions we to to create a booking that
we are getting the correct values so
once we click on this function we are
displaying the values that we need to
create a booking so we don't have the
API yet so for our sanity Studio we are
going to be creating all of that so what
we can do first is to just do some
validation so if there is no checking
date or if there is no check out date
then we're going to wron a
toast. error and then we can just say
please
provide um
checkin slash
checkouts
dates like
this okay and let's also check so now
we're going to check if the checkin date
is greater than the checkout date so so
if that the case we're going to return
toast.
error and we're going to tell the
user please
choose a valid check in
Period like
this okay so after this check so this
other check
here we are going to calculate number of
days again so
con um number
of
days and number of days is going to be
equal to a function that would calculate
the number of days so we can have this c
number I could just say C nor days like
this and we already have the function so
I'm just going to copy this function you
know we can pass it via
props but let's just Define
here and I'll just get calculate nor
days and here right than return zero
I'll just return and here we have we get
a time difference like this we get the
number of days and we with so here we
just calculate number of days and next
we can get the hotel
room
slug and the hotel room slug is going to
be the room do slug do
current okay and next we can now
integrate
stripe okay so before we integrate
stripe I won't talk about middle ways
but before we get to Middle ways I also
want to make sure that we have the API
uh from sanity Studio ready to help us
to create a booking so in our lebs and
in our API folder now we're going to
export this so export this constants and
then we can call it create
booking like this which is going to be
equal to this asnc
function like this okay so here we are
going to um
receive properties that we're going to
use to create the booking and this
properties is going to be of type so we
don't have this type yet but we can call
this create
booking dto which stands for data
transfer
object and where do we have a models
rooms so do we put it in
here I'm just going to put it in here
because it's related to a room even
though it's now related to
creating um a room okay and I'm going to
export this type create booking D which
is going to be equal to this function to
create a booking we need the user which
is of type string so the user ID we need
the hotel room which is also of type
string we need a check in
dates and the checkin dates
is going to be of type
string we also need to check out
dates and this is going to be of type
string we need the number of
days and the number of days is going to
be of type number we need the adults
which is going to be of type
number we need the
children which is going to be of type
number like this
we need the total
price total price is going to be of type
number and then we need the
discount which is going to be of type
number so we need to
spell
discount so to confirm if you come over
to the schemas booking TS you would see
the fields we need so we need the user
ID we need the h hotel room ID so where
is it that we show we pass the hotel
room ID here so you see we need the
hotel room we need the check-in date we
need the checkout date we need the
number of days we need the discount we
need the adults children and the total
price and that's all the field that are
defined in here okay so now we are going
to import this create booking dto coming
from our models
and in here we can now assess these
properties so we can assess adult um the
check-in date we can assess checkout
date you can assess children um
discounts hotel room number of days
total price and user so these are the um
values we need to create a booking and
then we can have our mutation
and our mutation is going to be an
object we have mutations like this
mutations is going to be an
array okay so an array and here we have
an
object so we're going to have a create
mutation and to be sure not to be sure I
just want to show you where I'm getting
it from so let's visit the
documentation so I just Googled sanity
mutation and we click on M
mutations just wait for it to load and
here if you click on create you see here
you have mutations you have create and
then you pass the values okay so this is
what we're doing here so we create using
a create mutation and then you see the
URL so https the product ID API
sanity.io you give the version data
mutate and your data set name okay so
this is the
create mutation that we are know
currently doing here in our
application so we have this create and
create is an object so it's an object so
pass underscore type so the type of
mutation or the type of where is it
again if we come over to our schema
booking the type of schema is booking so
this booking schema and that's what we
have here so apart from a type we're
going to have the user so remember it
needs the user and here theore type is
going to be of type
reference so please make sure there's no
typo here else is not going to you know
work as
expected and we just have the underscore
ref and the underscore ref is going to
be this user so it's going to be this
user
ID here okay so after this um user so
after this we are going to have another
property which is a hotel
room so hotel room like this and it's
going to be an
object so an object where we have the
same underscore type and the type is
going to
be
reference like
this and we have the underscore R which
is going to now point to hotel room okay
so after this hotel room now we can have
the other values so the check-in date
the checkout
date and the number of
days also adults and then
children and then we also have the total
price and then we also have the
discounts like this and after our
mutation so after this our mutation
constant we can now have or send the API
request so we're going to be using ex I
don't know if we have Exel installed so
let's mpm install Exel like this and
we're going to get our data which is
going to be equal to our weight XS so
I'm just going to restart our server so
here we're going to await
XS which we need to import so just
here I'm going to import
XS from XS like
this and here we're going to await x.
poost and the URL is going to be so we
have backtick
https and then we need to go to our
project ID which is going to come from
process. EnV and then
do we just come to our
EnV and we're going to copy our next
public um next public sanity project
ID I'll paste it here and then we also
go to
API
sanity.io and we then specify the API
version so V and then
2021 then 21 like this and then we go to
slash dat
slate and then we go to the data set so
process
EnV and then we come and copy this so
net public sanity data set like
this okay so after this we are going to
pass another argument and the data is
going to be our
mutation and then we need to pass
headers okay so here we're going to have
headers and headers is an object like
this then we have
authorization and the authorization is
going to be our BR token
so BR and then the token is going to
come from our
process.
EnV and then we have our sanity Studio
token and that's why it was important to
give read and write assess because now
we want to write to our sanity studio
and here we get our data we can
now return our data
here so we have our
endpoint we have our p page setup now
we're going to
discuss um we are going to discuss
middle ways okay because we only want
authenticated users to be able to book a
room okay by the way let's you know
authenticate
ourselves so I'll click
here and it doesn't load up so I'll just
reload our application you know we
restarted our server so let's be sure
it's up and running so is actually
compiling and it was compiling our art
page before we refreshed our page so
let's just for it to compile and as
we're saying we're going to integrate
stripe so we're going to be integrating
stripe next but I just want us to
discuss about middleway a bit because we
only want
users that are authenticated to be able
to call the rout okay so here let's
authenticate so I'm just going to
authenticate
myself using the Google
provider and that should be
authenticated okay so we
authenticated and we can come back to a
room so any room we
do and if we are not authenticated we
don't want the user to go on and book um
a hotel room so we don't want this book
now to actually make a call okay so
let's discuss middle ways now and the
way middle Ways
work if we come here so we come to the
root of our source
folder here and we create a file called
middleware
dots like this and we just just need to
export
theault like this and then we're going
to export this from next off at least
next off middleway for/ middleway now
with just this line of code we are going
to be blocking all our pages from
request so we don't have a way to
manually log out so we can't see this um
working in action because we are
currently
authenticated but if we are not
authenticated we would not have been
able to visit this page we don't have
the ability to log out yet so we can't
you know test our functionality but we
get this page cannot be
found
okay so we want to block two pages I
want to block two routes actually so I
want to block the user profile route and
I also want to block the API route so
I'm going to support conf fig which is
going to be equal to this object and
this object takes in the
matcher and this match can be a string
it can be a reject expression or it can
be an array of path so I want to block
request going to slash users and then
slash the user route like this so any
request going to SL users and then any
other route is going to be protected if
the user is not
authenticated and same I want to do for
our API folder so request going to SL
API slash and then the path like this is
not going to
be um allowed to pass unless the user is
authenticated so now we have this in
place we can now work on
our to make sure that we integrate our
stripe payment to integrate stripe in
our project first we need to install the
stripe package I'm going to quit the
development server and we we are going
to start from the back end route so mpm
install stripe like this and this is
going to go on to install the stripe
library and if we come up to our folder
and in our app uh leaves and here not
here sorry so our app and where we have
our where is it our API folder and here
we're going to create a new route for
stripe so let's have our stripe route so
we have stripe and here we have the
stripe. TS so this is our stripe route
and let me just restart our server here
okay so what the first thing we need to
do let's have this stripe constants so
stripe is going to be equal to a new
instance of
stripe yep so we're going to import this
Stripe from this stripe here and this
stripe this new is going to need
um an API key all right so we don't have
that yet we are going to get it in a
second but we can already reference it
so process. EnV and we can call it
stripe uncore
secret and underscore key like this okay
we still having error but we can say a
string here and the other is an object
so a config and here we're going to pass
the API version and it already has an
API version so this API version so let's
get our secret key so our stripe secret
key if you come to your
browser and here this is the stripe
dashboard you already um should create
an account for stripe and then you come
back to your dashboard you see that you
have to be in test mode and even to
activate um to go live you need to
activate your account so in test mode
you come here so you see we have our
publishable key and we have our secret
key but for now we need our secret key
so I'm going to copy this secret key and
if we come to application here in our
EnV um first I'm just going to paste in
the secret key here and for the value
for the key I'm going to copy this and
use here so our stripe secret key is
going to be equal to this key we just
copied okay so let's save this and next
we are going to have our function so
let's export a const
function Asing
function like this we're going to call
it
post this is going to be called the
request which is going to be of type
request and here we have our response
which is going to be of type response
like this so this is our function body
and we're going to have some data that
we're expecting from the front end okay
so here let's have Co so we're going to
get access to those data which is going
to be equal to await request. Json like
this and we can already Define the types
for data so we're going to have our
request data here and our request data
is going to be this object so we have
the checkin
date and checkin date is going to be of
type string and we're also going to have
the checkout
date which is going to be of type string
and then we're going to have the adults
which is going to be of type
number
children which is also going to be of
type number we're going to have the
number of
days which is also going to be of type
number and lastly we need a hotel rooms
slog this is going to be of type
string
string like this so we have our request
data we are going to use it here and say
this is going to be of type request data
like this and here we can get the
check-in date we can also get the adults
checkout date children hotel room log
and also the number of days so we're
going to get all of these from the
request so the request like this and we
need to call this like this all right so
up next we can have some validation so
we can check if these properties are not
there then we're going to return a new
next
response and we're going to say please
all
fields are
required like this and then we can set a
status of 400
so what are we going to check here we're
going to check if there's no checkin
date or there's no checkout
date if there is no checkout date if
there is no
other or hotel rooms
slog or there is no number of days then
we're going to return return this error
so we meant to use all like
this I not this so if there's no this or
know this
or we don't have
adults or there are no hotel rooms like
this and or you know number of days so
if this properties are not set then we
are going to Reon this error now we're
not checking for children because
children you know can be zero if the
user don't pass know that's default that
we are using in our page so here
children is zero
there is it so number of children is
zero so if we check for children and you
know we get zero value which we actually
allow in our database then we're going
to have an error so that's why I'm not
checking for children here okay so after
this we can go on and get to the request
origin so C origin is going to be equal
to our request. headers and here we can
get and we're going to get with the key
of origin like this so this is going to
give us the request origin and after
that let's have access to the session so
session is going to be equal to await
and then we await our get server session
and this needs the O options so we're
going to pass our
o options here coming from our leaps
folder so where is it so our Au
options and here we're going to have our
session we can have a check if there is
no session
then we are going to return return a new
next response like
this and we're going to
say authentication
required okay so now you know because of
our middleway so this middle way we have
here you know that only authenticated
users would be able to visit this route
so this check is not needed but I
actually want to go and get access to
the user ID
okay so const user ID and we're going to
get it from our
session do user. ID like this so this
gives us the user ID and we can also
format the checkout date the date so
formatted checkout date and this is
going to be equal to our checkout date
so not checking here our check out date
and then we can split
by T this capital T and get the first
index now if you're not show these
values please just log these to the
console and you'll see the format of the
checkout date and I'm just going to
change this to formatted checkin date
and then this is going to be our
checking date do split all right so here
after all of these let's have our TR
catch
block and in our catch Block in case of
any errors let's first look to the
console so we're just going going to
have this um payment
fied and have the error okay so let's WR
on a new next
response and the body is going to be
empty and we can set the status of 500
like this or we can just send the error
like this we have this error say this is
going to be of type any and the error is
gone now our Tri block let's try to
first of all get a room because we want
to get all the details about the room
from our sanity Studio the only thing we
want to get is the number of days okay
so we need the hotel room slog to get
the room and then the number of days
we're going to use this number of days
to then calculate the price ourselves
okay and not um allow the user send any
data to the front end so how do we go
about it we are first going to get our
room in our Tri block so here we're
going to get our room and this is going
to be equal to we await get room
remember the get room from our leavs if
we visit this get room you see here that
this gets a room so it gets this query
this get room query and it Returns the
results okay so we are making use of
this get room it needs this log and
we're going to pass the hotel room
slog so this hot room slog Okay so after
getting the room let's get the discount
price because you know we are leaving
discount on some of the hotel rooms and
this is going to be equal to the
room
price
minus the room. price divided by 100 and
we're going to multiply this value by
the room
discount so this is going to give us the
discount price now okay so after this
let's get the total price the total
price is going to be the discount price
which is the discount price per unit
we're going to multiply it by the number
of days so once we multiply the unit
price by the number of days we are going
to get the total price and now we are
going to come over here and create a
stripe
payment okay so we're sure we have all
that we need now to create a stripe
payment so we're going to have this
stripe session
and this is going to be equal to a
weight
stripe that is the stripe instance that
we formed here so this so we're going to
await stripe and then we can call
checkout and here we have sessions and
then we have the create method and this
is going to take a mode and the mode is
payment it also takes the line items and
the line items is this
array okay so an array of
object and first we're going to pass the
quantity the quantity is one so the
quantity is a mandatory field and here
let's have the price data the price data
is going to be this object so we can
specify the currency and the currency
will support is USD we going to have the
product data the product data is this
object where the name of the product is
the hotel room name so I think it's the
room. name
okay and we need to provide images and
images
sorry images like this images is an
array so you know that um our room
images has the URL property so we're
going to have our room and then have
images we're going to map through each
image like this and then this is going
to give us each image and then we're
going to return the image URL so map
returns an array and automatically
images is going to be an array all right
so after the line items next we are
going to send the payment method
types so underscore payment underscore
meore types and we support card payment
and after this we have this we need the
sucess URL and the success URL is going
to be dynamic remember we have the
origin which is where is it this origin
over
here so we're going to go to our origin
and and here slash users and we want to
go to the user ID so user ID like this
remember this user ID is coming from our
session here okay so now we have all of
these we still have all these fields to
create a booking we are not going to be
creating a booking here all right
because we want to only create a booking
when this payment is successful so
that's why we are not calling this route
stripe gives us access to web hooks
which is more like subscription events
that we can subscribe to and these
events are going to be called for us
automatically by stripe when they occur
so we're going to be looking at web
hooks functionality next and how we can
create an order only when a payment is
successful but for now let's just test
that our payment is working okay so
after this we need to return a response
so we're going to return a next
response do Json and here we have the
stripe
session and we are going to have this
side the status to 200 and then we can
have a status
text status text like this and the
status text is just going to be
payment say
payment um session
created okay so we can for us to test
this out we need to wire up stripe on
our front end so we just did the back
end now we need to to have stripe in our
front end and let's come over to uh
Libs so we're going to have a for a file
here for stripe.
TS and to continue let's quit our
development server and we need to import
the stripe for the front end SL stripe
for/ stripe
hjs so we need to install this Library
all right so we're going to import some
properties from it so import all of
these from at
stripe stripe JS like this and let me
restart sorry let me restart uh
development server all right so what are
we going to take we're going to take the
stripe class and then we're also going
to take the load stripe like this and
we're going to have this variable which
will call stripe promise which is going
to be of type
promise and This Promise can resolve to
two values so sorry it's had to be here
this per can resolve to stripe or it can
resolve to null like
this so here we are going to have this
function that is going to help us to get
stripe so we're going to export this con
which we call get stripe and get stripe
is going to be equal to this
function and we are going to return this
G get stripe
function all right so what we want to do
here first want to check if there is no
stripe
promise then we going to say our stripe
promise is going to be equal to load
stripe so this package that we import
like this we're not going to return
return here I'm sorry we already
exporting and we need to return return
inside so we're going to return return
inside and that's here so call L stripe
and L stripe is going to need a
publishable key so we don't have this
yet but we can say this is going to come
from our process.
env.
nextcore public
underscore stripe publishable key stripe
publish
shable key like this and we can say a
string all right so so I'm going to copy
this and load it in our
EnV and get it from our stripe so this
is the publishable key just copy this
and I'll past this in here and save so
whenever we make changes to our EnV it's
always nice to restart our server so I'm
going to create this and restart our
development server okay so now we are
done with this we would come back to our
page so this room Details page
and in here we have this function so to
handle book now click this handle book
now click function okay so what we can
do here we have the number of days here
where we are going to be integrating
stripe I'm going to take this off and we
have our TR catch block so first we're
going to use exus to send our data so
this is going to be equal to we're going
to await exos do getet and we need to
import exos from exos like
this and here we are going to call
A.G and the API is going the endpoint is
going to be/ API slash strip so this
Endo if you open this up sorry not this
if we come to our API stripe this so
this route over here and it has to be a
get request sorry post request not get
so this has to be
post like this all right so after this
because the post request we need to pass
data and what data we need to pass the
checkin date we also need to pass the
checkout
date we also need to pass
adults we need to pass
children and children is going to be a
number of children like this
we need to pass the number of days and
we need to pass the hotel room slog like
this having this error because we need
to make this
async all right so from this we are
going to get our
data and we can name this rame this to
be stripe
session okay so after this we're going
to check if we have
stripe that means we need to import our
load stripe function like
this and somewhere here we can just say
con stripe is going to be equal to
AWA get
stripe and this is this get stripe here
so we're going to import this to help us
load stripe here and let's see so this
is it okay so once we await this gu
stripe we now have stripe like this and
why we why are we having an error why do
we have this
error
okay can have con
results we have an error here which is
saying an expression of type void cannot
be tested for Trace it's a typescript
issue and if we come back here to this
um get stripe
function that's because here we forgot
to return
we forgot to return our stripe promise
and that's why I love typescript because
it helps us to catch errors like this so
we forgot to return a stripe promise and
that's why we're having error here see
the error is gone because it knows it's
going to return stripe or no so comes
result is going to be equal to we
await
stripe we always stripe like this and
then we call redirect to to check
out redirect to checkout here and this
is going to take the session
ID and the session ID is going to be
what we get back as data so stripe
session do
ID okay and this strip session we are
getting back here if we come to our
route see here we are sending this back
as a response so this strip session and
there it has the ID property all right
so here we have our
results we can have to check so if
inside here so if
results.
error we're just going to have a toast
so we going to toast. error and
say payment
field and here if we have an error let
let's log it to the
console so we can cons that log
error and here we have our error like
this and then we can also toast.
error and say and error or code
here all right so this is the time that
we going to test it out this is our page
and we are calling this post request we
pass the data so checkin date check out
date adults children number of days
which are all these data checking the
check out the adult this children number
of days and here even though we not
making of um these properties yet
because we're not creating a booking we
are just um creating a payment and here
we're not making of the total price and
that that's because just here so in our
price data so after product data we are
going to add the unit amount so we
forgot to add the unit amount so the
unit amount we're going to pass
in like
this and we're going to have our total
price and multiply by 100 because it has
to be in sents and we can call to string
like this
and like this all right so let's try
this out I save open the terminal to be
sure everything is still up and running
I'll just quit and reload so that we are
just double double show I'll close this
panel and if we come back to the browser
here where we have our
application let's just reload so let's
see if our application is building so
it's compiling the slog so that page and
remember we have Middle where in place
so if a user is not authenticated or if
you're not authenticated maybe you're
clicking on the book Now button and
nothing is working you just have to
authenticate yourself so if you're not
authenticated you'll not be able to
visit the API route we don't have a way
to manually log in log out yet so you
know once we Implement log out
functionality you would see how this
works so our page is compiling
and I think it is ready
now all right so this is our page let's
choose a checkin date I'm going to
choose 12 and a checkout date I'll just
choose the next day you see the price is
92 because of the 8% discount and let's
click on book now so let's see if this
goes on to load
uh
stripe
okay okay Sims is loading up stripe so
great everything is working fine for now
we have 92 we have the product image you
can give this same name email I'll just
go with test test.com for card
information 42
424242 is the default that stripe gives
us and for the month I'll just say
1123 and and you see I'll just say test
name and click on
pay so wait for this to load up it's
successful and it should redirect us to
the user so 44 page and you know we
created this page here so if you come
over to the routes here you have the
success URL so it's origin which is for
now our Local Host SL users and the user
ID and that's how we get redirected to
this page so for now we say 44 page but
we'll be fixing that so if we come back
to our local host and let's also come to
our stripe and here if we click on
payments so that we see our payments we
should see this payment so this is it so
we just did this payment now and payment
is complete so a user is successfully
booking a hotel room so fine now we need
to create a booking so it's is paying
but you know we are not actually
creating a booking and that's where web
hooks come into play so if we come back
to home and here in home um where is it
you come over to web
hooks here you would see how web hook
web hooks work so you can click on this
link I'll just open this in a new tab
and over here you're going to see an API
documentation on how to go about using
web hooks so let's scroll down and let's
visit this it's going to give us uh a
way to go about this and in here you see
the first thing we need to do is to
identify the event to monitor I already
identified the event that we going to
monitor for this web Hook and the web
Hook is the checkout session completed
so the checkout session completed is the
web hook that I have identified or that
we need to call whenever a checkout
session is completed okay so we need to
identify the stripe event so you can
open this events in a new tab to see a
list of the different events that stripe
offers okay and here I'm going to search
for
stripe um sorry for
checkout do
session. completed like this and this is
it so this event here where is
it um where is it do
completed I thought it's to C there
let's
see so checkout. session.
completed okay checkout. session do yeah
so this this web hook here it occurs
when a checkout session has been
completed so this is the um event we are
going to be listening to like that and
now we need to create a web hook
endpoint function so this web hook
endpoint function stripe is going to
call for us okay so let's do this next
and come back to see the next
implementation and this gives us a
sample code if you go back to the nodejs
to see how it works injs so this/ web
hook and all these things so let's do
this um let's create this web hook
endpoint function and to create this
here so in our API route I'm going to
create a new route and this route I'm
going to call Web
hook like this and here we are going to
have sorry where is it we are going to
have the
route do TS file just inside the web
hook okay so how is this going to work
let's first of all have
a checkout session completed so checkout
underscore session underscore complete
and this is going to be equal to check
out
underscore check out the session.
completed we just saw this in the
documentation so this is the event we
are going to be listening to the
checkout. session. completed event and
we're going to get stripe again so I
just come back here and copy this so
here we are going to get stripe again
and we need to import Stripe from stripe
like this so after this let's we can now
go on to export our async
function async
function and this is going to be a post
request like
this and this post request is going to
be called with the request which is of
type
request
and here we have the response which is
going to be of
type response like
this and in here first we going to get
access to the request body so con
request body and request body is going
to be equal to
await like this request.
text and next we need to get the
signature and and this is going to be
equal to request.
headers do get and we're going to get
the
stripe
signature okay so where am I seeing all
of these from the documentation and if
you scroll down you will see best
practices where is it um I think that's
the last step so after number four let's
see
somewhere here we should have for Best
Practices let's
see um test your web hook function
register and secure your web hook okay
so here we have best
practices and you have um let's see SEC
web hooks yeah so the web hooks best
practices you can up this link and here
you're going to see best practices to to
integrate stripe inside of your project
and here you see only listen to event
types your integration requires that is
one best practice and here you see you
need to verify events that are sent from
SC stripe and here you see ways to go
about it having the signature getting
from the request headers and here having
the stripe web hooks construct event you
pass the request body you pass the
signature and you pass the end point
secret okay so we're going to be doing
all of this which is just best practices
for us to secure our event listeners
okay so for now we are still in the
second step to create a web hook
endpoint function all right so after the
signature we are going to have our web
hook
secret which we don't have yet okay so
we're going to get this when we
integrate the um web hook but for now
this is going to come from uh
process. EnV and here we can call it
stripe
uncore web
hook underscore
secret like this and I'm going to copy
this and have it in our EnV for now
which is going to be
empty and after getting our web hook
secret we're going to have our event and
this event is going to be of type
stripe.
event like this and after this we can
have our TR catch block so in the catch
Block in case of any error let's copy
this and use here so the next response
needs to be imported from next server
and the error we can just say web
hook error like like
this and this is going to make it of
back
tick and we are going to have uh error
do
message like
this and this is going to be of Type n
so in our Tri block let's get our let's
verify so if there's know signature or
there is no web hook Secrets then the go
on and return so if we have all these
properties we're going to assign our
event to be equal to
stripe. web hook like this and here we
have the construct event and this is
going to take the request
body and this also needs the
signature and it needs the web hook
secret so you see here need the secret
and we pass the web hook secret here all
right so we have
this we
can come over next after this try catch
and this is where we um load our
events load our event okay so in here
we're going to have a switch
case and we're going to switch by the
event.
type like
this and we're going to hand do this
case so this our case check out session
completed like this and we're going to
have our con session and this session is
going to be the event data so event do
data doob like this all right so for now
we just going to
console.log the session
here so we are just going to log this um
session to the console we can already
have um a default case so we can already
have a default and we we just con that
log you know on
handled event
type and here we're going
to send back the event do type like
this okay so what do we do next we Lo
the session to the console and after
which we can go on to create a
booking like this so we going to create
a booking and we need to return a
response so we're going to return a next
response that Json and this response is
just going to say
booking
successful and we set a status of
200 and a status text of booking
successful so this return is under this
case okay and this should be it
so so we are going to try um this
session type and let's come back to the
you know to the documentation we have
created a web hook endpoint so we have
done this and you see here you have this
switch and you have this case which is
what we did we handle this case for when
our session is
completed and you see here there's a
this default that we just log to the
console and this
response
okay so I think we have't forgetting
this so we need to return a response to
acknowledge the receipt are we doing
that we are not doing that okay so this
needs to
be copied and returned outside of of
this switch here we need to make sure we
return return this okay regardless and
we need to return this while this
whatever code we write inside here
whatever logic is being um worked on
okay we need to return return this which
is what we have done and everything
here um is fine we can change this
status text rather than booking
successful which isn't what happened you
can just
send event received like this okay so
let's come back and after this we need
to test our web hook function and how do
we test this um we need to use the CLI
so I'll just open this in a new tab and
come over here so here we need to first
of all install so I'm on the Mac and I
installed with Brew you see you have
different options for Windows in you
know this is the way you would go about
it you just need to download the file
and you know follow this to download the
stripe CLI so you can test this locally
or Linux if you're on Mac you can you
know have different ways to go about it
but I just use Homebrew to install I
advise if you're on Mac you should try
this out it's just very much
straightforward and when you install you
need to log into your stripe
dashboard and we should be doing this
already so we going to go to our
dashboard our terminal sorry and run
this stripe
login and where is it
um
okay so this is it okay so this is just
all we need to do we need to log in so
I'm going to open up my terminal and I
will zoom in quite a bit so I'll paste
this stripe login and this should be
after you have um installed the stripe
CLI all right the parent please enter
the browser or visit
this okay so I'm going to enter to open
the browser and this opens up in the
browser here and in here we should be
authenticated let's just wait for this
to
load okay so we need to verify so let's
come back to the IDE this s
Valor know text and we need to verify so
this is it so this is the pairing code
so Snappy follow and here you just allow
access like this and you
know okay so once you authenticate I'm
going to clear this and after that we
need to listen to event to a local
endpoint so I'm going to copy this
stripe listen and fold to to here and we
are going to add this Das Das skip
verify flag here like
this so inside here I'm going to paste
this and we need to change the first let
me add the D Dash
skip uh
verify flag let me be
sure uh skip hyphone verify as one word
like
this and the end point is going to be
Local Host
3000 slash API SL web hooks like
this this is our end point and I'm going
to enter this this is going to load and
we have our stripe secret so you can
copy your stripe secret and come in your
EnV and paste this secret here and save
okay since we have have changes in our
EnV we are going to restart our server
like
this and you see if we come to this web
hook section so this
route we take the request body we take
the signature from the header we have
our web hook
secret and we have our event and if
there is no web signature
or web hook secrets we return We assign
a event and here we switch the event
type and we just log to the console and
here we send this
response of events received so I'm going
to change this
to event received like
this and for now here we are just
logging this to the console so open up
the console in case we see any logs and
come back back to the browser and next
we are going to trigger the web hook so
if we come
down you see here to forward events you
know from the Endo you already reged on
stripe use the load from web hooks API
optional flag okay so if we come here
you see this is the web hook that we
have registered um and stripe so this
web hook over here this
endo and you see it's listening so if we
come here we are going
to
um run this from our command line so
where is it so listen to events I'm
going to copy
this um sorry this is what we just did
so we need to forward
and yeah so we need to trigger stripe
trigger and we need to trigger
the web hook so I'm going to copy this
and I would open up another terminal I'm
going to split um this terminal okay I
did go on to split the terminal and here
I'm going to paste this we're going to
trigger our
own we're going to trigger our own
event and the event is this so check out
session completed you can copy this
event and if we come back here I'm going
to paste in the event and send this so
we should keep an eye here okay you see
here we get this um
307 okay we get all of these and you see
here that this was actually called okay
so you see here we got trigger suceed
and if we come back here we don't see
our console.log to for the session which
we are logging to the console
here and we don't see this response
here okay so let's see we are switching
the event. type I'll do it again but
here I'm just going to
console.log the event going to save this
and so we can have a look here and to be
sure our application is still up and
running I am just going to reload this
page okay let's give it another shot I'm
going to come
here um I'm just waiting for this to
load
up
okay okay seems it's done and I am going
to come
here actually before this I'm going to
disable this middleware remember we have
this middleware for the you know API
route so I'm just going to duplicate
this and comment this out and also get
rid of this no because this go to the
API route so that we're not blocking
ourselves from that request even though
we
authenticated but we'll just end it and
here I'm going to trigger this again and
we should expect to
see this here we get
44 so we get
44 and why are we having 44 SL web hooks
okay so is it what we name it no that's
what we're getting for for is meant to
be web hook so that's the
route and we're going to quate this yeah
because we made a mistake in our
endpoint is meant to be slash web hook
like
this okay and we'll send this okay we
are going to get a new um I don't know
if it's new but we going to get this
secret we're going to copy it and use
that here so I'll quit this again
and paste this here in the
EnV our offense was we were targeting
this route but we added an S so it's
meant to be SL API SL web hook like
this and if we come back to our stripe
the end point should have updated see it
has updated as well and we can reload
our
application all right all right so
without all way let's
trigger this again so stripe trigger
checkout. session do
completed and let's see what happens
next we get 200 which is good news and
it means that we are sending back our
response and we get this so this is the
event that was triggered and now if we
come back here great we see our
console.log
okay so we see our cons. log we actually
logging two things to the console and
that's why we are
seeing quite a lot I'm going to get rid
of the event because I don't need the
event I'll save
this and this time around in this other
console. log I just want us to see this
session object so I'm going to have this
session name here so that we see that we
are calling um this is the console. log
for the actual session okay so let's try
this again so we come here and we are
going to trigger the event again we get
our
200 and if we come to uh conso log in
application now we should see
this
okay we see the session here which is
good so this is the session ID we get
the object and we got we get all these
information great so we have all this
information and I want you to take a
look at this metadata so you see this
metadata is going to be very much
important and for now you see it is an
empty object okay so we are successfully
calling this so next let's continue to
now create a booking the the question is
when we want to to create a booking we
are going to await our create
booking function that is going to come
from our lips okay so this um function
here and if we just visit this function
one last time you see this is it takes
an
argument and which is of this type and
it goes on to create this uh mutation
for us now the issue is stripe is the
one that is calling this endpoint point
so we need to pass this so the adults
and all other information to this end
points but how do we get it because
stripe is calling this Endo so how do we
get this information to create a booking
now it's very much
easy because I'll just remove this
remember I told you to take a look at
this metadata object this which is for
now an empty string okay so it's very
much useful for us to insert um metadata
so here when we are
creating this um payment so so when we
are creating this payment in this um I'm
just going to take this off in this um
create stripe payment we have access to
what stripe calls metadata and this
metadata is an object and in here we can
go to include metadata that we are going
to use here so we're going to be able to
destructure them here as you saw the
metadata is an empty object we want to
change it and we can have adults like
this which is the metadata that we need
so the checkin dates remember we have
created all of these
already and we can also pass the
checkout date you can also pass the
children can also pass the hotel room
slug I think it's just
um I think it's just
the hotel room so if we come here like
this to uh where is
it where do we have the function so this
create booking function if we come here
you see we need adults checking date
children hotel room user total priz and
all of these so this is hotel room which
is the ID and this is going to be our
room
ID and next it needs the number of days
and it needs
the what else it needs the user
ID and the user ID is going to point to
the user ID and it needs the
discount not the discount price it needs
the
discount okay and discount is going to
going to be the room do
discount let's be sure if this is user
ID or user actually I'm going to split
this to avoid mistakes and that would
also zoom out a bit and here where where
is it
um where do we have the create payment
function so create booking function so
we need the adults we need the checkin
date they check out date the children we
need a discount and the discount is the
room discount we need the hotel room we
need a number of days we also need a
user so this is meant to be user like
this and this is going to be pointing to
our user
ID we need
the we need a total price like
this so here we have total price and
this should be it so adults checking
dates children
discounts hotel room number of
days total price and user okay so we can
save this and I'll just get rid of
this and come back here so you see here
we have added all of these um metadata
here so we have added of these and if we
come back here and we trigger this again
so I'm going to trigger this again I'll
just cleck this and call this stripe
trigger and Trigger this we get out 200
but this time around if we come
here and we take a look at our
console.log our
metadata object is still empty now I
understand it's still empty and the
reason why is because
stripe is calling this for us and we are
not calling it ourselves so we're going
to call this ourselves in a second and
we should see our metadata populated I
think we can already call it by now call
the Endo by
ourself and to do that I will just try
to create a payment and watch the Endo
being triggered for us to buy stripe so
I'm going to click on this
room
and in here just wait for this to load
up I'm going to just choose a check-in
date and choose a checkout date and book
now so the idea is for this to call the
web hook function on our behalf and then
we can you know have this populated so
I'm just going
to quickly fill this all
out
say
1123 any cpv give a test name and this
time around once payment is
successful we should come back here and
this end point should be
triggered this Endo should be triggered
for us by
stripe and let's come here we see this
we don't know if it was the previous or
the latest but one way to know if we
come here and take a look at this
metadata now you see this metadata has
been populated so we have adults which
you you should take notice everything
here is a string so we would need to
convert this back to use an application
but we have um the adults the hotel room
the discount and every other property
that we need to create a booking great
so now in this web hook we are going to
have access to those properties
and I'll just get of this console.log
and it's in the session object so we are
going to have
this where we say this is going to be
equal to
session and here we want to go and get
the metad
data like this this metadata is also an
object now we're having this error okay
it's compa typescript comp ability
issues it doesn't know but we know it's
there so we can just TS ignore and we
don't have any errors and for this we
want to get all the properties we just
saw so the
adults and basically all these
properties that we added to our metadata
so I'm going to copy
this and bring them in here like
this we're going to get the hotel room
and we are also going to get the
discount like this is all from uh
metadata and we're also going to get the
user okay so now we have this we can now
call this um create
booking and the adult remember this is
going to be a string but we need to
store of type number so this is going to
be number adult like this we have the
check-in date and next we're going to
pass the checkout date we are also going
to pass the
children and this children also needs to
be a
number so we pass it like this we also
need to pass the hotel room and this
hotel room will just be like that we
need to pass the number of days and this
also needs to be a number and here we
have our number of days we also need to
pass our discount and discount is just
going to to be a number like this and we
have our discount and next we need to
pass our total price which also needs to
be a number and here we have our total
price and lastly we need to pass our
user so with all of these we are going
to come
here and we are going
to ref our next
responsejson okay which we have over
here so booking
successful and now we should go on to
create a
booking and not just creating a booking
we want to also update a hotel room and
change the status of that room to booked
so here we need to update um hotel room
and to do this we are going to come back
to our apis folder and apart from
creating a
booking I'm going to zoom out so we see
everything clearly and apart from
creating a booking this we are going to
be updating a hotel so you can export
this Con and we call this um update
hotel room like
this which is going to be
equal to this async
function you're going to make yourself a
our function like this and this is going
to take the hotel
room here and in here we are just going
to have our
mutation and our mutation is going to be
equal to this object where we have our
mutations and mutations is going to be
this AA and here we are going to be
using a patch mutation and this patch
mutation is going to be this object we
need to pass the ID and the ID is going
to be this hotel room so we can actually
call it hotel room ID which is going to
be of type string so here the ID is
going to be this hotel room ID and we
want to go on and set like this is
booked property to true so we want to go
and set this to be true and every other
thing we can copy from here so this data
and we're going to return the data so
I'm going to copy this and use this in
here so this goes on to send the request
and goes on to update our hotel room so
we can save this and here we are going
to call that function to update the
hotel room so here we're going to await
our update hotel room
function and this needs the room ID and
the room ID is our hotel room that we
get from
our metadata all right so now we are
going to try out this booking and see if
we have a booking here in uh just come
back to Local Host
3,000 and see if we're going to have
this booking in our sanity studio so I'm
going to reload our sanity studio and
wait for it to build okay so we can come
here so let's say we try
to book this featured room so I'm just
going to come into this room and wait
for it to
load and I know our server is
still if I bring this here you see it's
still compiling our CMS and it's not
done compiling our CMS and that's why
perhaps it's blocking you know uh hotel
management application that's why it's
blocking or some Local Host
3,000 so we'll just wait for the CMS for
the studio
to build up and then we can resit this
route here okay since it is now
compiled and in
here we are going to visit
the booking
section so in here we are going to
come over to
booking and here in Booking we don't
have any booking yet so we are going to
try and create one now so I'm going to
choose my check-in date and let's say my
checkout date here and number of adults
one I'll just increase this checkout
date and we see the price updates and
let's say two adults maybe one children
one child and and click on this book Now
function okay so with this it should
help us to connect to stripe and once we
are connected to stripe I'm going to fit
these details so test at
test.com and
uh
email and this is going to just say 23
2 and I'll just say test and click on
this now so with this we should create a
booking once it is
successful so everything successful like
this and one way to be sure everything
went well if we come here we should say
booked so this hotel room should show
booked and it should not show us the
book now on the CTA great so we see
booked because we see booked if we come
here you see that our booking was
successful and you you already see that
this hotel room was updated so if we
click on this booking let's see if it
has everything so it say it has a user
and has a checkin date everything is
fine except for our date now why do we
have issues with our date if
we we don't get any errors but you know
it was successful I don't know why we
have this error um with our date perhaps
is the
format so is the format maybe we need to
get rid of this and you
know format the date properly so if we
come back here to this web hook so our
check-in date and our checkout date so
we need to format it and I think we have
done that already in this uh application
I'm just going to look for where
we for where we formatted our check in
date and so so this is it we actually
needed to make use of this format
checkout date and checkin date which we
didn't use so that's why we having those
errors so for checkout date we are going
to use our formatted checkout date and
for checking date we are going to use
our
formatted uh check in date here so this
should solve our problem and everything
should be fine so for this we can get
rid of
this so we can you know delete this
booking I'll just come here and delete
this so that we try it um one more
time and we would update we shouldn't
forget to update the hotel room and
which room is this um this is this
Deluxe suit so here I'm going to come
here and change
the is booked property to false and
publish this so now we're going to come
over to our booking and we're going to
create our booking so we see the book
Now functionality here I'm going to
choose the checkin and the checkout date
and just say to adults and go on to book
now okay so we shouldn't forget to bring
in uh middleware after
this so I'm going to give the email so
test
test.com and give this
the
this and this
1123 CV and give it test name and going
to book this room again and once we're
done we're going to be redirected to the
user page which we don't have yet we're
going to go to the 4 four page come back
to Local Host 3000 we see our booking
here and everything should be fine so
everything is fine this time around we
get our total price and if we come back
to this room we should see that this
room has been booked so we just wait for
this
to upload and you see this room has been
booked so
great now with all of this done we can
come back to this page so the user
profile page and we are going to be
working on this page
next so let's come back here first if we
come back I'm just going to get rid of
this so everything seems to be fine here
so we have a web hook
here and when we host rather than listen
to Local Host 3000 we should don't
forget to add uh end point here so they
will end point for uh you know this URL
so we're going to add this URL and
everything should be fine but for now we
are just going to be using Local Host
and this should be up and running so
this here listening for the request
should always be up and running so now
we are done with all of these we can go
on to create the user slug page so
openness I will get rid of everything we
have here I'll just close all and here
let me get rid of everything we have
here and to have our page up and running
here where we have our web I'm going to
create a new page for our
users and here the ID so this is going
to be here where we have the ID like
this and here we are going to have the
page. TSX file and this is our component
and I'll just call this page um user
details all user Details page and get
rid of this so if we save this now we
shouldn't have a for for page
here this is our user Details page so in
this page we are going to be fetching
data that belongs to this user so here
let's come to our lebs and in our api.
TS let's have two new functions
so we're going to export a sync
function and this function we can call
get user bookings to fetch the user or
the bookings of the user this is going
to need the user ID which is of type
string and this we're going to get our
results which is going to be equal to
await we need to await our sanity
client. Fetch and this fetch is going to
return a booking type which we don't
have yet so we're going to have that and
here we're going to have our queries
dot get book user booking which we don't
also have yet and in here we need to
pass parms so let's create uh queries
because we are missing our queries so
here let me export this cons get
user get user bookings which is going to
be equal to this Gro like
this and want to fetch a user booking
rore type is equal to
booking like
this
and where the user
doore ref so the user ref is going to be
equal to a param we would receive and
that param we can call user ID so this
user ID is going to be used here as Pam
like this
okay so here let's take in this elements
where we have the underscore
ID we also want the hotel room and from
the hotel room we want to take these
properties like this from the hotel room
we want to take the hotel room ID we
also want to get the name we also want
to get the
slug and the
price okay and after this hotel room we
are going to take the check in
date and also the check out
dates the number of
days the
adults
children the total
price and uh
discounts Okay so so these are the
properties we are going to take from the
user so you know from the booking that
is pointing to this user and the booking
has all of these properties so now here
our queries is going to go to get user
bookings like this and we shouldn't
forget to follow Convention of adding
this query over here so get user booking
query here okay so here we also
let's we get our result I'm going to add
this cach No cach Object so here I'm
going to say
cash and I will say no cash like
this this is going to give us a result
and we shouldn't forget to return
return our
result and here we're going to have a
booking type so let's come over to our
models and have one for our booking dots
like this and we're going to export this
type we call it booking which is going
to be equal to this
function where we get all these
properties so all these properties from
our sanity query so I'm going to copy
them and use them
here soore ID is going to be of type
string so I'm going to copy this and our
hotel room we are getting all these
properties so it's going to be of type
object like this where the ID is a
string the
name is a string remember this log is an
object we have this current property
which is a string like this and the
price is going to be a
number the checkin date is going to be a
type string the check out out date is
also going to be a string the number of
days is going to be of type
number and I'll just copy this because
the rest of these is going to be of type
number so this is our booking type and
here in our API we can
reference this booking type like this
and apart from the user booking we also
want to get the user data so here con
export con export async
function and we can call this get
user data and the parms is going to just
be the user
ID and the type is going to be of type
string like this so in here we're going
to get our
results which is going to be equal to we
await sanity client and we call
Fetch and here I don't pass the type so
we have our queries and we don't have
the query yet and after this for the
parm we need to pass the user
ID so let's go write out this query so
here we're going to export const um get
user data
query let going to be equal to Gro like
this and we want to get the type so the
underscore type is equal to
user like
this so just user like this and this
will return on average so we need to
take the first matching element and here
we have the underscore ID we also need
the name we also need the email we also
need a is admin
property we also need uh about the user
we also need the created ad which
actually is going to be of type
underscore we're going to have this
image so these are the properties we are
going to be getting from the user and we
shouldn't forget so to add the ID so the
type is going to be user and the ID is
going to be equal
to we have this param user
ID like this all right so we can go
into to save this and in the api. TS so
get user where is it so get
user data query like this and then we
pass this and we can also say
cash no cash like this all right so we
have these two functions and now we are
going to call these um end points so
first if we come to the user page in
here we are going to send the request so
we're going to have this um I'm going to
first make this uh client component
making use of that use client hook like
this and now we can fetch our data
making of the use SW AR hook so this is
going to be equal to use s
WRR like this and it needs a key for key
I'm going to call this go to
slash API and slash user bookings like
this and here we are going to have this
fetcher so called Fetch user bookings
and this is going to be equal to async
Arrow function and here we are going to
call get user booking
it should be bookings like this I could
be
booking so get user bookings like this
coming from our
leaps and here we need to pass the user
ID and the user ID is what we will be
getting from the URL so here this is
going to be receiving props props is
going to be an object where we have a
parms key and parms is an object where
we have the ID and the ID is of type
string so we can come here and
destructure all of these from the props
we can destructure params and inside
prams we can D structure the user ID
like this so we can rename this to be
user ID so in here we are going to pass
the user ID property and we going to
pass this function over here to fetch
user
booking and here we are going to call
this uh
data we rename to user bookings like
this and we're going to have error and
is
loading so as we did in our rooms here
in our page. CSX I'm just going
to I'm just going to
sorry
I am just going to copy this so where do
we have it
again yeah so I'm just going to copy
this and we can use this over here like
this so the data we renamed it to user
bookings and if we l this to the console
so user bookings which should see the
bookings that belongs um to this user
user so if we open up the terminal here
we should see the user bookings here we
don't see here we see on the find and
here we see the user booking so this is
the booking that was created by this
user great so after this we want to F
the user data as
well so here I'm just going to have this
Con and this I'm going
to also make use of our use
S W hook and I'm going to call this/ Api
SL users because we are going to be
fetching this in our back
end and the
fetcher can be defined
here so con
fetch user
data and this is going to be equal to
this async
function
we're going to use XS because we're
going to send this to our API to Fred so
we're going to AIT
x.g and the URL is going to be
slash
API slash
users like
this and we have our data we are going
to
return this data here and we can already
pass this over here like
this and we can have data which will
rename to user
data and we can also get the is loading
which we can name to loading user
data and we can also get the error which
is say
error getting user data or
anything
like
this okay so here we can
still through if error so this
error
or we can just say if error or if you
know error getting user
data we would go to load
this all right so now we should go
to have this end points okay and we can
also use um configure the type of data
we are going to be receiving so if we
come back to our models here going to
create one for our user. TS like this we
can export this type user and this is
going to be called to this object theore
ID is going to be of type string we also
have the name which is going to be of
type string string we have the email
which is going to be of type string we
have the is admin which is also going to
be of type Bing we have the about and
about is going to be of type string or
null so you
know a user is not mandatory to have an
about and created that is going to be of
type string is have an
image which is going to be of type
string so this is us type we are going
to be using it here so we're going to
import this from our Models All right so
we can save this and now we need to have
this API route SL API SL users I think
we have that route
already so where is it in our
API no we don't so here going to have
this SL users and we're going to have
this
route. CS like this
okay so in here we're going to export a
sync function and this function we just
call get because say get request it's
going to take the request which is of
type
request like this I also get the
response which is of type response like
this and let's get the
session this is going to go to our get
server session and this needs the Earth
options like this
I will just rearrange these
inputs and we can say as always if there
is no session we are going to return
return a new next
response and this new next
response we are just going to say
authentication
required like this and pass a
status of
500 so if we have a session we are going
to continue we can get the user ID which
is going to Beal to our session. user.
ID and we can have our try
catch like this and in case of Errors
we're just going to return return a new
next response that says unable to
fetch
and here we're going to have a status of
let's say
400 and in the tri block we're going to
have our data which is going to be equal
to a get user
data coming from our leavs it needs the
user ID and we are going to pass the
user ID so this is going to
be con like this so if we have our data
we're going to return a
next
response and we're going to pass our
data we are going to have our
status we're going to have our object we
have our
status why are we having
error yeah because it needs to be next
response adjacent like this here we pass
the data and we have our object where we
set the status to 200 and we can
also set the status text
to successful like this all right so
let's try this out now we should have
everything working fine and let's log
user data to the conso so just after
here I'm going to conso log um user data
here
all right so if we come back
here um I'm just going to open this
up okay and reload this all right and
not forget to open the terminal and we
get user data on the F so we are not
actually able to fetch um user data and
we having
error
and if we just reload this we are having
errors fetching the user data all right
so let's fix
this
um we have this where is it so here we
have aing user
data and it goes to/ API SL users and we
come to this SL API SL users we have
this get request which get the user ID
and call this get user data so here we
are not
ronning our
results okay so that was the issue we
are not returning our results we have
this
queries do get user query we can just
visit it one last time so where the type
is
user and the ID is going to be user ID
like this okay so let's try this but now
so let's
reload and see if everything works fine
now we get on the find and we get null
okay this time around we are getting
null and if we update our query to be
sure that our query isn't the reason and
we save
this and we
reload
you see now we get this subject okay so
we get this object and it had to be
underscore ID not ID so here we need to
bring this back in and change this to
underscore ID okay so let's reload this
and let's see if everything is fine this
time around
yeah so you see we now successfully
fretch the user
data so I'm going to come back to the
page. TSX and here remove our
console.log so now we are sure we are
getting the user data we can have a jsx
so this div I'll give it the class name
of container MX
or2 give this PX of two
give this on medium devices a px of four
and a py of 10 like
this and inside here we are going to
have this other
div and we can display this as grid and
um medium devices grid
C 12 give this a gap of
10 and here we're going to have this
addtive and give it this class name of
hidden give this medium
devices block like this and the medium
devices go span
four and here on large devices go span
three like this give it Shadow
LG give it a height of feet give it
position sticky the top of
not 10% 10 give it this dark um grayish
background so e
ff0
F2 give it the test
black uh Rand dead LG A
px6 and A
py4 like
this okay so up next we are going to
have this div for the user image and we
can already import this image component
from next
image so here we are going to have this
class name and give this on medium
devices give this a width of let's say
pixels it is a width of
28 a height of
28 and on medium devices give us a
height of 143 PX
again give this MX
Auto imagine bottom of five uh rounded
full and an overflow of hidden like this
and inside here let's say just copy the
user
data uh and I'll duplicate this so if
type of user data is equal to onine and
loading user data like
this we're going to say cannot
Fetch and here I would also duplicate
this so if we
are sorry I'm going
[Music]
to say if you know we
are loading user data I would just
return return uh spinner so I loading
spinner
component and if we are also fetching
our user booking so if this is loading
is
true just going to return this and so
here our source is going to be your user
data do
image so where do we have this if there
is no user
data H so we don't have it so I'll just
say if there is
no user
data so if there is no user data I'm
going to draw a new
error cannot fetch data
here okay so here I'm going to get rid
of this and we also need
the and the alt is going to be uh user
data do
name give it the width of 143 pixels and
the height of 143 like
this and give it a class name so our
image class name our
scale animation class name get this
rounded full like this and if we save
this we should see this section over
here with the user details
so we see
this um session over here great and it's
quite large so 143
pixels it's quite
large okay and after this div we would
have another div here to display the
user details I'm going to give this a
class name of font
normal give it um py of four give this a
text left like
this and have this H6 here where we are
going to display about the user so I'll
give this a class name of text
XL so text extra large this is a font
bold and a pattern bottom of three like
this and here we can have the text
about so after this we would have this
paragraph and here give this a class
name of text SM like this and you know
the user about can be undefined so we
can just say
user data doab if it's there it's going
to use it
otherwise we can just perhaps with an
empty
string okay so after this div we are
going to have this other div and the
class name is going to be
front normal like this
and text left we just want to display
the user data do name so here we're
going to have this
H6 which would give text XL and
also
font
B and we'll also give it a padding
button of three and here we're going to
have our user data do name like
this and we can have our sign not
functionality we have this
div and this D we're going to give it a
class name of flex items
Center and here we are going to have
this pattern with the text of sign
out and just give this
uh margin to the right of two
and here we're going to have this fa
sign out out like
this and I'll get this a class
name that's equal to text 3
XL give this a CER
pointer and
here and click we want to call sign out
so we don't have this function yet we
are going to bring it in so here we are
going to call sign
out and just rearrange these inputs
here and going to
import sign
out which will be coming from next o
react so here we are going to call call
sign
out and this sign out we can give it the
call
back URL and the call back URL we are
going to point to slash like this so
let's save this and come back to the
browser and we should see all other
details about the user so we see about
we see the username and we have this
button to sign out the user so if we
click on this
we should sign out and go back to our
homepage great and that makes sense
because now we are going to bring in our
middleway so we come back to our
middleway I'm going to remove this that
we set when we testing stripe sorry I'll
bring it back in and I'll get rid of
this one here so that we cannot create a
booking unless we are you know
redirected so we can go on and
authenticate ourself
if we click here it should bring up the
authentication screen for
us and we should now authenticate I'll
just authenticate again with
Google
here and I would come back to the user
profile page so this page here so we
have about the user the name and the
ability to sign out now we are going to
have this section over here so remember
this section this section had this call
span 4 so this section here and this
other section is going to have these
class
names because on medium devices we want
this to call
span it like this and on large devices
SC span 9 like this because that's what
we did so this un large device SC Co
span three so in here we are going to
have
um different section so first we are
going to have this
div and this is going to have a class
name of
flex we are going to give this items
Center like this and here we're going to
have this H
five and we're going to give this a
class name of text to
XL we're going to give this font bold
and imagine right of
three and in here we can just say hello
and here have the user data. name so
user data or data set so your user data
do name like
this and we should see that here so this
other section so hello and we see the
username so after this we are going to
have this other
div and this div we want it to be hidden
on medium devices here so we are going
to have this other div and this div we
can give it this class
name and the class name is going to be
MD hidden sorry sorry class
name is going to be
MD
hidden uh with 14 a height of 14 red
full overflow
hiding and in here we're going to have
the image
components and here we can give this uh
a class name and the class name is going
to be IMG scale
animation like
this and
here you can give it a width of let's
say
56 and give it a height of let's say
56 and for the source property this is
going to go to slash
images
and here our hero
one.
JPEG and for the alt the alt is just
going to go with username like
this so This hero one. jpeg it says
hidden earn medium devices so if we come
to our public
folder and in our public folder if we
open images this image here so that's
the image we are displaying
here so let's come back to
application and if we toggle this on
mobile we have this image I'm just going
to reload
this rather than use
um rather than use this let not forget
to give this R Dead full just going to
save
this rather use this um image let's make
use of
the user data do IMG do image like this
and we should have the user image right
there okay so here we're going to have
more details so after this div we are
going to have this paragraph and this
we're going to display as block we're
going to give it a with fit uh medium
devices give it hidden like this and
text
SM and give it a py of two like
this
so
here we're going to have the user data
do about like this so we know it can be
null so if it's not there we can just
have this for empty string and after
this we are going to have this user this
par graph we just say join
in and here we can have the user data
doore created at and we're going to
split this this by T and we are going to
take that first element
here and we're going to give this a
class name of text extra small give this
a py of
two and we are going to give this um a
font media like this so we can save this
have a preview and we should be seeing
that
here great so after this paragraph We
are going
to have a
div like
this and we're going to give it this
class name of MD
hidden uh Flex items Center and a margin
y of
two so in here we want to keep have this
paragraph on medium devices or we tell
sorry yep on small to medium devices I
will give this um imagine right of two
so that the user can can sign out so the
same sign out functionality that we had
here I'm going to copy this and paste
this in here so inside of this div like
this so after this div so still inside
this uh where is it so inside this Cod
span 8 so here so still inside here and
first let's see if we you know show this
yeah so medium devices this is what the
user can see to use to sign out so after
this inside here we are going to have
this
nav which is going to have so many class
names so going to give a class name of
sticky a top of
zero give it um PX of two give this a
width fet like this give this MX
Auto here on medium devices give this a
WID
full and on medium devices get this a px
of five give this a
py3 a margin bottom
of 8
text Gray
700 give this border give this border
grade 200 like this get this red LG get
this LBG grade 50 like this and AAG top
of seven like this so in here we are
going to have an on that
list okay and the idea is to show
the current
bookings and also show the you know the
user spending so we're going to be
managing some
states and to manage the states here we
are going to come let's say somewhere
around
here and we can have this
property which is going to be called to
you
state and we're going to have this type
for for our use State and we're going to
have the default
value so here we can call this current
nav and here Set current nav like this
and inside this UST State we going to
have the type
bookings and we also going to have the
type amount like this and we're going to
have the type of
ratings
like this and by default we want to give
it bookings here so we can go back to
our H that list so inside of this nav
and for the class name we are going to
have this backck the last
sign so it's going to be
dynamic here like
this and in here we can say if current n
is equal
to and here we can check if it's equal
to
bookings then we are going to give this
a text blue
600 otherwise we are going to give it a
text Gray 700 so otherwise text
Gray 700 like this so this should be
text
and that's not the only class name
because we're going to give display this
in line Flex imagine to the right of one
and on medium devices and margin to the
right of five item Center space x one so
space X1 like
this and on medium devices we're going
to say space
x three like
this and now inside this on that list
we're going to have some list items
here and this list item let's give it
the class name remember it's inside this
nav and this class name is going to be
inline
Flex
here items Center and cursor pointer
like
this and on click we are going to set
our current
nav and we're going to set our current
nav to
bookings and here we are going to have
this
function inside this Ali we're going to
have an icon so this BS
Journal bookmark fi
icon and we're going to have this
a tag here and this a tag is going to
have this class name of inline
Flex we're going to give it items
Center like this and MX of one and then
medium devices MX of three like this
text extra
small
and medium devices text small like this
and font
medium and the text is just going to say
current bookings so we want to display
the current bookings you know of the
user and we should see our navigation
somewhere here so we see this uh current
bookings like this looking good so after
this
um after this under list we are going to
have another on that list so I'm just
going to bring this down again and here
now it's going to be if this is going to
be equal to amount we're going to give
this otherwise we would give this color
and then we're going to set our current
bookings to amount these class names
remain the same and for the this um icon
we are going to use this
GI money stack like this which we need
to import and this is going to have the
class name
of not the class name the text is going
to say amount spent like this so if we
come back we should see this other one
displayed here for the amount
spent so we don't see it yet
y so we see it and if we click it now
becomes the active one so I don't know
if we're going to make use of the
ratings so we're going to see if we need
to add another tab from the ratings or
if we just going to let the user book
directly from
here so just after this nav which you
can move to another component but I'll
just leave it in this component so after
this nav we are going to have a table
component that we only want to show if
it's um if the current bookings is going
to be the current nav is booking so here
if current nav is equal to
bookings like this if that's the
case we want to have our user bookings
so user bookings and want to check if it
is
true then if that's true for now we are
going to have a table
component could just say table like
this otherwise we are just going to have
an empty fragment so we check if current
T is bookings I will just check if the
user has some bookings then we are going
to render this um component over here so
this table component and we can go on to
create the table
component so I would come here and in
our components folder I'm going to
create a new component for table I'll
copy this and here I'll create this
table.
CSX file and here have a reactjs
component
so this table is going to be receiving
some props and it's going to be a client
component so I'm going to mark it as
such using the use client
directive and here let's have the type
props which is going to be equal to this
object and we want to get the booking
details like this which is going to be
of type booking so do we have the book
type yet if we come to a model this type
over here so we are going to be making
use of it so it's going to be of this
booking type coming from our
models like
this we're going to handle rating and we
would need to keep track of the room ID
so we can already have this set room ID
which is going to be of type thisp
and this patch needs to come
from um
react and this not this this dispatch
from react here and I'm just going to
rearrange this order of input and here
we have our set State action which is
going to return of type string or no
like this
and in here we can say this F uh this
table is going to be of type FC which we
import from react and it's going to take
in these props and
here we can destructure the booking
details and also the set room ID from
the
props so
here
we are going to have a div and this div
is going to have this class name of
overflow overflow X of Auto we going to
have this Max width and this Max width
is going to be
340 pixels we're going to have red LG MX
Auto U medium devices give it a Max
width of full
give it Shadow
MD and on small devices out go banded LG
like this so here we have a
table and for class
names I'm going to give this a with
full also give this a
text SM give this a text left
like this and give it a text grade
500 and inside this table we are going
to have t
head and give it a class name of text
extra small text Gray
700 upper case like this and a BG gray
of
50 and inside this T head we are going
to have the
TR and here we're going to have a CH for
table
headens and here let's give this some
class names of PX
um
six and give it a py of three like this
and we can have a room
name okay and I'm just going to bring
this down and here we have our unit
price and here we would have our
price we would have our discount and
display in number of
this
books and here we would have a days left
so that user can know um how many days
left so after this T head we are going
to have
um our table body so our T body
body and we want to map through our
booking details so here we have our
booking
details map and here we have each
booking and we are going to return a
table R so here we're going to return
this TR like this we have errors because
first we need to have our ID sorry our
key and the key is going to be the
booking do
_
ID and we can get this a BG
white give this a
border uh
B bottom width and on Hover can get this
a BG
gray of 50 like
this and inside here we can have this T
heading and I'll give this a class name
of PX six under line text blue
600 give is a cursor pointer like this a
py4 of font
medium and y space no WP like
this and this T heading we can have a
bin do hotel
room. name to display the name of the
hotel
room and here when the user clicks on
this we want to push the user to the
hotel room slug okay so here we can have
a
router so inside this component we can
have a router which is going to be
called to use router that comes from
next navigation so this use router hook
and we can take this up top so here when
the user clicks on this we're going to
have a callor router and we'll push the
user to these slash
rooms and here go to
slash and we are going to go to slash
um
booking do hotel room. slug do current
so this is going to take us to the hotel
room when the user clicks on this and
after this we are going to
have another table
data so this TD and this is going to
have this class name not class so this
class
name and this class name is going to be
px6 and py4 like
this and in here we are going to show
the booking
dot hotel room.
price and I'll just bring this down and
next is going to be booking do total
price I'll bring this down and next is
going to be booking do discount the next
is going to be booking do number of
days and this is going to be the
checkout date uh we don't have this yet
for now I'm just going to have this um
zero because we want to calculate the
number of days left so that the user can
you know have an idea and we are going
to have this
CD same with this class name of px6 and
py4 and this is going to have a
button now this is going to display the
text of rate room because we want these
to be able to rate a room and this is
going to have font medium and text blue
600 like this and on Hover we are going
to underline this
rate and inside this um this button we
are going to have this on
click and here we are going to do two
things but for now we are going to set
the room ID to the booking do hotel room
do ID so I'm going to save this and
import this table component if you
missed out anything please do check the
GitHub okay so inside this page here
rather than show return table like this
I'm going to bring in the table
component coming from our component
folder over
there and in here we are going to pass
the prop so booking details is going to
be equal to the user bookings like
this and where we have
error type
booking
is so user bookings is of type booking
okay and here let's not forget to also
pass the set room
ID and why are we having this
error if we have on user bookings so
where is
it um user
bookes it can be of type booking or
undefined so I think that's why we are
having the error but here we are
training a new error if we don't have a
user booking so I don't know why we
still having that error but let's do the
same here and see if we pass this do we
still have our error we do so type
booking is missing from type oh an array
of
booking okay so
this is meant to be an array of booking
and I'll just control Z this change we
did here and that's because if
we come
here we see we are returning booking
like this so this needs to be an array
of booking and that's where the error is
coming from so fetch user
booking so if we come here so get user
booking you know we are saying this is
going to just Reon a booking so actually
it's going to return the
bookings that belong to a user so that's
why we have this blue ra over here now
the error should be gone yep the error
is gone and we are getting this now for
the set room ID so we're going to have
this in state a state where we set the
room ID so
here where do we manage our state so
here I'm going to have this other state
we have our room ID and here set room ID
is going to be equal to you state which
by default is going to be
null and this can be of
type
string or null like this so let's save
this and go back here to see if we're
going to see our table component display
without any errors great so our table
component
displays and we are having this you know
if I go over to dark team you see we are
having this not look great and if we
come back to our table I'm just going to
have this
empty TR
here and this should be for rating get
rid of the class name or maybe I leave
the class name and if we come back now
it's fixed okay so I'll just rever back
to the white them so we have the unit
price of this 100 and the price is this
because the user got a discount of eight
so when the user booked this there was a
discount and that was why the total
price was you know
552 and the user had the number of days
booked so 6 days and for now we just
hardcoded this to be you know this left
to be
zero okay so after this we can go to
display the amount spent so we want to
have a graph where we can Now display
the amount spent so the user can also
keep track of the amount um spent so far
so I'm going to get rid of the table
components and and we are going to have
a new component that we can call chat so
here in the component folder I'm going
to create a chat component so I'll copy
this and paste this in here so our
chat.
TSX so I'm going to have
this components
here and here so if we come here I'm
going to get rid of the react input and
here I'm going to make this a client
component making use of the use client
directive and we need to install chat JS
so I'm going to quit our server and npm
install chat JS Library like this and
we'll need to import some things from
the library so all of these will be
coming from chat JS so we can
restart our application using npm run
Dev and I will just reload our browser
so here I'm going to import chat as chat
JS chat as chat JS like this I would
also import um to
tip import the category
scale bring in the linear scale as
well and bring in the bar
elements okay so all of these brought in
we need to register them so
here we are going
to say so our
chats so chats
Js like this and then we have just
register we want to register the tool
tip the category scale the linear scale
and the bar
elements so we want to register all of
these and now here I'm going to also
import so somewhere
here uh I'm going to import bar and this
bar is going to be coming
from this
another Library we don't have so it's
going to be coming
from react
hyphone chjs hyphone to like this so I'm
going to save this
and install this package so
npm install react chartjs to library
like this we're going to import the back
comp component from it so now it's done
I'm going to restart our application
using npm run Dev okay so let's have our
options so
export con
options and this options is going to be
this object we're going to set
responsive to true because we want the
graph to be
responsive and we can have this
plugins and this is going to be an
object where we say Legend and Legend is
going to be an object and here we say
position top at least as
con okay and next we're going to have
our
title and the title we just say
display display
true like this and we're going to have
this text and this text is going to say
charts.js
bar
chat so this is the title you know we
can change this if we don't want to
display we're going to change this
later and this is going to receive props
so we can say this is going to be of
type FC which we import from
react and the prop I'm just going to
Define it here so it's going to have
this user bookings which is going to
be a booking array and this booking will
be coming from
our models folder so going to import
this from our models
folder and here we can destructure the
user bookings
and this booking is going to need some
options and label so labels is going to
be equal to our user
bookings and here we can map through it
and we get each booking and we want the
r name to be the booking okay and we are
going to return return the booking do
hotel room. name so that's going to be
the label and to get the amount spent on
that room so we're going to have this
Con amount spent and amount spent is
going to be equal
to user bookings do map we get each
booking and we're going to return return
the booking do total price like this so
now we can have our bar so our bar chart
which is this from cha
js2 so we're going to have our bar and
make it uh self closing component the
options is going to be these options we
just defined up here so I'm going to
change this to options so these are the
options responsive true and all of these
to get Auto completion you can Define
them here so this
object and
here you can pass that's different so
you see these are your options okay so
for this case just have this options and
next it needs data so data is an object
like this and data need labels so we're
going to pass this labels that we just
defined here and here it means data set
and data set is an array so an array of
object and the label of that data set is
going to
be um amount
spent like this and and here we have
data and data is going to be amount
spent like this we can have our border
WID and this is going to be equal to one
I'll just say this to one and we can
have our backround color so this hasht
F2 not the last sign
hashtag
f27
45 like
this we can give this color on Hover so
on Hover background
color which is just going to be this # f
C6
41 so let's save this and we need to
make use of this chat component in our
page so in here we need to make use of
this chart component and give me a
second and want to display it if our
current
now if our current na is equal to
amount so if that is true then we want
to display our chart
component and our chart needs to be
imported from our components like
this and here we're going to pass the
user bookings which is going to be
the user bookings like this otherwise we
are just going to pass an
empty um string like this we having
having error because type user booking
or on the find okay so we can
check just as we did here so have this
extra check and if we have user
bookings then to go to show our user
booking components and this time
around when application reloads if we
come over to amount spend we should see
our chat component so we don't see it
yet okay our application is up and
running we are just going to reload our
application remember we installed some
packages and you see our application
just had to compile and once it's
done we should now um see our chat
component so here we have current
booking and we see the amount spent we
see that this was the amount the user
spent on this now we see this because
this is the you know only graph so here
we see the amount spent and we see this
theux suit here all right so this is
working fine and we have this sticky we
also have this sticky up here at the top
where the user can switch to the you
know current bookings and switch back to
the amount spent so this is working fine
and if we click on this we should go to
the room page sorry yeah to the hotel
room page so the
user can see the hotel room that he
booked okay so the hotel room that was
booked and just give this a second to
load and you see the user booked it
that's why it had the label of booked
and it's up to the admin to come back to
this hotel room when the booking is done
and update the is booked
property to false so that other um
customers can book this hotel room so
now with these two functionality done we
can go on to work on our rating
feature okay so now for us to set up
rating let's come back to our
application and I am going
to close all the these tabs and here in
our table component that is where we
have this button so this right button
and which is here so on click of this
button we are setting the room ID we
want to also do something we want to
toggle our rating model so here let's
have in state we don't have any rating
model yet we're going to create it in a
second and we can say is rating
visible like this and then set is
rating visible it's going to Beal to US
state and by default
false so somewhere here so let's write
it
um maybe we can write it here and here
comes toggle rating
model is going to be equal to this
function and here we are going to
return set is rating visible we have the
previous
state and we want to return the inverse
of this previous
state so we can pass this over as
prop to our table component so here we
can receive this prop and this is going
to be of type
function that returns nothing so that
returns
void and here we can bring the toggle
rating model from our
prop and whenever we click on this
button we are going to call this
function I'm going to save this and come
back here and over here I'm going to
pass this toggle rating model is equal
to toggle r in model like this so do go
on and save now it's time for us
to create the rating model so we're
going to create a new component for
that I we just collapse all of this so
here we can have the rating model
component and here we can have the type
script
definition so let's have our jsx I'm
going to get get rid of
this and obviously we are going to be
receiving props so type props is going
to be equal to this
object and it's open is going to be of
type bowling so this is one prop we need
to toggle the visibility of this um
model like this and we're going to pass
the
props here we receive
props um sorry this needs to be props
like this and so that we can dist
structure these properties from our
props so we can D structure is open like
this okay so this is going to be dynamic
here we're going to have this class
name and here we're going to give it a
position fixed give it a z index of
61 and then give it an inser of zero
give it Flex it temps Center justify
Center like
this and in here we are going to say is
open if this is true what do we have
here is so if open is is open is true we
are going to give this class names
otherwise we would give this other class
names so if this is open we want to give
this an
opacity of let's say
100 and P pointer event Auto like
this and I will just copy this class
name because it's similar so here the
opacity is going to be zero and the
pointer events is going to be known okay
so this is this wrapping div we have
here we can already um make use of
this in
uh page so somewhere
here you know it doesn't matter where we
place this so I'll just place this
somewhere
here and I would have the written model
like this then we'll go and UT and it
need is open prop which is going to be
equal to is what did you call it is
wrting visible like this so we can save
this and if we we come here and once we
click on the red button we expect to see
this
component so I'm going to come back here
and once we click on this great so we
see this rating model okay so it covers
the whole screen we need a backdrop
component for that so let's create it as
well um here in the components we can
have
a backdrop
components and here a backdrop. TSX
file so I'm going to have this here and
this also is going to be a functional
component and here we going to receive
props and props is going to be object
and here you can also have the is open
prop which is going to be of type
bowling and we pass this prop over here
this is the only prop this component we
need so I will just D structure from
here like
this so let's go on to style this um
backdrop in here I am just going to have
this check so I'll check and we don't
even need this um return return here so
we can just select this if it's open
it's
true
then we are going to show this div
otherwise we return an empty
fragment okay so let's starty this div
it can be self closing because we're not
going to have any um you know any word
in between the div and this will have a
class name of
fixed I need to have a z index of 60
because we gave a Model A Z index of 60
61 I want the model to be on top why
this deep is below I'm going to give
this a top of zero give this a left of
zero this is a width of screen a height
of
screen and give this background so this
BG R
GBA and here 0
z0
0.8 like
this all right so I'm going to uh that's
all for this um backdrop components and
we can make it of it already here so I
will just display the backdrop
components here like this and it's also
going to take this is open which is
going to be equal to is rating visible
like this so now we come back we should
see our backdrop so we see our Dr
backdrop show up here and we see our
rating model great so let's define our
rating model so let's continue
here and after this we are going to have
another div it is a class name of BG
white a width of 96 a pattern of
four and rounded LG Shadow LG like
this and here we can just have this H2
which is going to say um rate your
experi
and for the class theme I'm going to
give this a text XL so an extra large
and on dark team I'm going to give this
a text Gray
800 a font semi
bold a margin bottom of two like
this and then after this div this H2 we
are going to have another div
and this div we give it a margin bottom
of
four all right so this div is going to
have the label and it's also going to
have the input so if we save and we come
back to our application we see this Tex
experience so here we're going to have a
label and it's not going to have this
HTML 4 the class name is going to be
block text SM give this a f
medium and a text
Gray of 700 like this and we can have
the text
rating after this label we are going to
have this div and the class name is
going to be
Flex items Center like
this and inside this div we are going to
map through the different star values
because we want to show the star value
which is going to be um the rating so
here you can have this cost we call Star
values and star values is going to be
equal to 1 2 3 4 5 like
this this star values we are going to
map through it so inside here we are
going to have our star
values map which is going to be our
rating value like this and we're going
to get each value and we want to return
return a
button inside this button we are going
to show the BS St F like
this and because we are in a map we need
to give this a
key and the key is going to be equal to
the value we're just going to use the
value as the
key and what else we can give this uh
button a click event
so on
click of this
button we want to go and and call the
this function so here we want to have
this function I think we defined it
already so set written
value we don't have it so we want to set
the rating value which is the value that
are the Chooser chose for now I'll set
this to null we are going to come back
to this and let's give this some class
name and the class name is going to
width of six we're going to give this
uh height of six and we have this
so we need to use back tick here for the
class
name like
this okay so we're going to update some
value based on the rating value now if
the rating value so here I'm just going
to for now put um I'm just going to take
this off so we see if we come back to
the
browser we should see our rating value
update so these TS here so once we click
on one of these TS we want to give it a
color or something like that so here to
keep track of
the value which the user is clicking on
I'm going to have this Con here call it
um written
value and then set written value is
going to be called to US state and by
default it's going to be
zero so this is going to need a written
value
which is of type number and here set
written
value which is going to be of type
dispatch and we're going to dispatch a
set State
action like this and this is going to
dispatch of type
number all right so we're going to pass
this to this prop now so rating value is
going to be rating value and then set
written value is going to be equal to
set written value so we can save this
and now we can bring in these values so
the rting value and also the set written
value and in here we can now unclick
we're going to set the written
value to the value not value error to
this value so now we are sure we are
updating the value we can now update the
style and here we're just going to check
if the rating
value is equal to the value so the
current value we are looking at if that
is true we are going to give it this
text
yellow
500 otherwise we will just give it an
empty
string so this is our check here and if
we save this we come over to the
browser we don't see anything yet if we
click on rate this should
update and rather than give nothing by
default I'll just give it a
text grade
300 so text grade 300 and now if you
click on one of these you see the values
update
accordingly all right so that's what we
have going on for that and now after
this we are going to have another
div and this div we're just going to
give it a margin bottom of
four and here we're going to have the
label and I think the class names are
like before so we can just
copy these class names and reuse over
here and in here we are going to have
the text review
text like
this so this is going to be a text
area not template a text area like
this and I'm going to get rid of all
these properties for
now just leave rows and I'll set rows to
four okay so this also needs a value and
it needs um the unchange to set the
value so we can call this um rating text
so here in states where did we have the
previous so we can call this wrting
text and set
rating text but by default it's going to
be an empty
string so here we
can duplicate this and ask for the
rating text which is going to be of type
string and here set rating text which is
going to be this type but not a number
now it's going to be a
string and we can bring in the rating
text and the set rating text so here we
shouldn't forget to give this component
the props so the rating text is going to
be called to the rating text and then
set rating text is going to be call to
set rating text like this so now if we
come back
here and here so in the text area the
value is going to be equal to
the wrting
text
and we also need to
unchange we are going to call this
function which gets called automatically
with the
event and we can set rating text to the
event. target.
value okay so let's style this I'll give
you this class name of with
full uh PX of two uh py of three border
rounded MD and that should be it so here
let's save and let's have a quick
preview just click on this and we see
our text area so that's looking good and
after our text area so after this div we
are going to have this other
div and this div is going to have the
class name of flex and justify
end like this and here we going to have
this
button the class name is going to be
PX4 py
2 uh PG primary text white and rounded
MD so this button is going to have the
unclick and this unclick is going to be
the review submit Handler we don't have
this yet
but we can have this review sub MIT
Handler and here let's define it so we
can Define it somewhere on up here this
is going to be called to an async
function like
this
um yeah like this for now we don't do
anything what will be coming here and if
we over on this we can just copy this so
it's a promise that returns void
and we can assign it type here so review
submit Handler and we can already bring
this in like this so here we call this
uh review submit
Handler and we also want to disable this
button if we are submitting the review
so disabled is going to be equal
to submitting review and this also has
to come from the propes why are we
having an error because we haven't
passed that Pro it's fine so if we come
here we can have this other one for
submitting review and here is
set is submitting review like this which
is going to be
false okay so here are we expecting the
prop so here we should expect the prop
so is submitting
review which is going to be of type uh
Bing like this so here let's pass these
props so his submitting review is going
to be equal to
his um submitting
review set is submitting review so did
we make a mistake here so this should be
um okay we can go with submitting review
I just say is submitting since we are
working with that
already
so we'll pass this here and next it
needs the review submit Handler which is
going to be called to the review submit
Handler so everything should be fine and
we'll just bring in this is submitting
review from the props and we would
update this to be is submitting
review so inside this button if we have
submitting the review is submitting
review is true want to show the text of
submitting
otherwise we will show the text
of
submit and then we want to have another
button and this button is for
cancel cancellation of the model so when
we want to get rid of the model and this
is going to have this class name of ml2
PX4 give it a p y of two uh BG gray of
300 give us a text Gray of
700 rounded MD and on Hover I'll give
this a BG grade 400 like this and here
we will just have the text
cancel so for
the on
click we are going to call our toggle
rating
model I don't think we have that here so
toggle rtin
model we are going to call it do we have
it no so here we are going to bring this
from the props and this is going to be a
function that will return nothing so
that returns
void but here I'm sure we have the
toggle written model so this we are now
going to pass it as a prop here so to
model
is going to be called to toggle rating
model so if we come back to application
and everything um reloads correctly do
we have any
errors nope so I'm just going to reload
our
application and it should come
up okay
so let's wait for it so once we click on
rate we see this so we see our cancel
button which toles the model and we see
this um submit that does nothing for now
okay so we have uh created this and if
we click on
submit so where is the submit
button here we come over to our rating
model and we click on submit we call
submit review Handler so let's log
details to be to the console to be sure
that we we are getting the details so
we're going to look the
review the rating value and uh so the
rating text and the written value we're
going to L this to the
console and let's try it out to see if
we are getting the values okay so I'm
going to choose five
star and say
hello and click on submit great so we
are currently getting this value here
great and you see our application works
as fine also on mobile and on desktop
all right so next we are going
to create our API to be able to create
this review okay so to create this
review we are going to come to our API
folder and in here where we have users
um the user route. TS we already have
this get to get user data now we want to
create a review that belongs to a user
so we're going to export this async
function and this function we can call
it post it's going to be called with the
request which is of type
request and is also going to be called
with the response which is of type
response so again we are going to get
our session I think we have done this
here great so here we are just going to
copy these and use this here so we get
our session and then we check if there's
no session we return return like that so
we are going to request some properties
from the request Json so here we need to
await
request.
Json and what do we need to create a
review we need a room ID we need the
review text and we need a written value
so once again we can just quickly take a
look at our schemas and here our review
so you see this is of
type um has a name of review and it
needs this user ID the hotel room ID the
review text and the user rating so it
needs this and we're going to get the
user ID from our session okay so now we
have all of these we can go on
to get the user ID so Curr user ID is
going to be equal to
session do
user do
ID so this gives us the user ID you can
go to apply validation you know for all
of these values but just continue I'm
sure is pretty straightforward to you
know apply some validation we can just
copy this and use this here so we can
say if there is no you room ID or if
there is no review text or if there is
no rating value we can go and return
return this text so all
fields are
required like this and with a status of
400 so all of these and now we have our
user
ID great so let's have our try catch
block and before we create the review we
want to check first I think I should
just handle the error case I'll say this
error is of typee
any and I'll just cons that log the
error so error
updating and cons. log the error like
this and here how return a new not to
try return return a new next
response which will say um
unable so
creates
review
and give this a status of
400 okay so let's have have all Tri
block the first thing we want to do we
want to check so check
if um a review already exist so I want
to check if a user has already left a
review on that room so check if already
exist all right I need to check this we
we need to create um a
function in our API folder that is in
our lebs sanity TS so in our
API we have these two update hotel room
from previous we have this to get user
bookings to get user
data we are going to export an asnc
function and then we can call this check
VI
exist like
this and what do we need we need a user
ID which is going to be of type
string and we also need a hotel room ID
which is going to be of type
string so so in here we can also say
this um is going to return a
premise that is going to resolve to null
or it can resolve to an object where we
have the underscore ID property which is
going to be of type
string okay so for now we are not
returning anything that's why we're
having errors okay so this check is
going to return null or it can return
this object with the
found
um review so let's have our
query and this is going to be equal to
we can make it of back tick and we use
St like this underscore type is going to
be equal to
review
and the user doore R is going to be
equal to now we can use param to inject
the user
ID and we have here so for the hotel
room doore R this going to be equal to
the ReUse perm again to have the hotel
room ID and here we take the first
matching element and here we can request
for theore ID property so this is our
query where the type is equal to review
the user ref is going to be the user ID
and the hotel room ref is going be the
hotel room
ID okay so we have our query we can also
have our
params which is going to be equal to
this user ID and hotel room ID so here
we're going to have our user ID which
will get from this
function and also our hot
ID so we can get our results so con
results and result is going to be equal
to AWA our sanity client and we call
fetch we get the
query not
queries query and we pass our pars here
so this results for now we S type any
but our function knows is going to be of
type null
or an object to the ID so if result is
true we want to return return the result
which is going to be this ID object
otherwise you know we're just going to
return
null okay so now we have this function
to perform the check if we come back to
our route we can now check if uh a user
already exist so we can call this
already exist and this is going to be
equal to await check review exist and
here we pass the user
ID and we also pass the room ID like
this
okay so what are we going to do next
we're going to L to the console already
exist to be sure everything is working
fine at least up until this
point so in our page. TSX here we're no
longer going to be logging these values
to the console we are going to have this
check and check if there is no review
text like this where is
it uh rating text
so if there is no written text.
stream do length
or there is no rate um ritten
value like this in that case we are
going to wron a
toast do error and the error is going to
say please provide uh review or WR test
X and a string and the
rating okay so why are we having this
error review submit
Handler okay because we are not string
undefined is notable to type void okay
it's because of the return type okay
that's what rning so we are rning a
string and that's why it is
um complaining if we have on this now it
can return string or undefined so copy
this and if we come back to our rating
model I'm just going to update this
right than say return void we'll say
return return promise or on the find
like that okay so now we also going to
check if there is no room
ID we also want to toast an error so so
we're going to copy this and tost an
error if the user doesn't or if in some
case there is no room ID we can just
say ID not provided like this and now we
sure we have our properties we can have
uh try
catch okay so in case of any error we
can just log it to the
console and have it toast so
toast. and say
you
failed like this and in the tri block we
can get
our we can get our
data by
ating xs.
poost and this is going to go to/
API slash
users like this and it needs the
data so it needs the
data so let's verify if we come here
what do we need we need the room
ID the review text and the written value
so copy
this and here have the review
text and we are going to have the
written
value I would also paste this in here
and we also need the
room
ID and I will paste it in
here we're having a um because this is
rating test so revie test is going to be
rating text like
this okay so here we just going to log
our data to the
console and we going to toast do
success let's say review
submitted and and we need to do some
clean up so in the finally
block we are going to set a
review where is it is it set our rating
text I'm going to set it to an empty
string to reset the values and then
we're going to set written
value to
null we're also going to we have an
error I'll will come back to that also
set the room ID to
n and also need to set the
is set
is is submitting review to
false and what else we're going to set
our rate close
our backdrop and also uh model so we
will set this to false like this so
while having an error in set ready model
because this can be of type number or
no the error is gone but we have new
errors here because you know if we hover
on
this so this can be number or null and
this same can be number or null so let's
quickly update here where is
it so set written
value can be number or null and written
value can be number or
null okay so now we can come back to our
route and if we send this I just want to
be sure that already exist is been
printed so now remember this is going to
be called on the server side so let's
look out for for this on the server so
I'm going to save
this and I'm going to try to submit a
review view I'll click on this and we
already have this from
previous and I'll just say hello again
and
submit and if we come here you see the
review failed and the you know we see
here the form got reset and everything
which works fine we have an error which
is okay but now you see already exist is
null so you see the user hasn't left uh
a rating on this great so since already
exist is there I will just get rid of
this and we show our logic is working we
can have data so let data like this and
now we want to be sure so if already
exist is
truthy we are going to do something so
we want to go on in that case and update
a review otherwise we want to create a
new
review so here we don't have these
functions to update a review and to also
create create a review now we are going
to create them so backing our leaves
api. TS here so after check review exist
we're going to export another con to
update review and this is going to be
equal to a
sync we're going to have
the properties that we are going to need
here so the
review
the review ID so also going to have the
text and we also need a user rating like
this and this is going to be of type so
a type that we don't have yet but we can
already call this update um
review
dto so we don't have this type yet let's
go on and Define it but before before we
do let's complete our function
body so let's define this update review
dto here in our
models we would have this review.
TS and here I'm going to export this
type and this is going to be update
review
dto this is going to be C to object we
have the review
ID which is going to be type
string we also need a review
text which is also going to be of type
string and we need a user rating which
is going to be of type number so now we
are here let's also export on type
create review
D this is equal to this object so we
have the hotel room
ID this of type type
string we need to review
text which is also of type string the
user rating which is of type
number and we also need the user
ID which is of type string so now we
have all these values we can come back
here and we can just
import this from our models
great so now we have these values let's
have our mutation con
mutation and mutation is going to be
this object and in here we're going to
have
mutations which is an array of objects
and here we want to have a patch
operation and this patch is an object
where we provide the ID and the ID needs
to be the review
ID and we're going to
set the text to be the review
text and we are also going to set the
user rating which is going to be the
user um rating so we don't actually need
this like this okay so this is our
mutation and I am just going to copy one
of
these uh where do we yeah this create
booking I'll just copy one of these that
we have here uh we collapse this and
here just after this
mutation I'm going to paste it in here
so we have our x. post where we target
our Endo every other Thing Remains the
Same and we go on to with on our data so
this is for you know updating every view
so let's also have for
creating um a review so here I'm going
to export
AC call this create review which is
going to be equal to this async
function like this which is going to be
of type uh create review
dto and we can have our function body so
here we're going to get the hot room ID
the review text the user ID and the user
rating so all these typ type should
match here so if we come to our
schema and in our review schema it needs
this so the
user and if we come here we are going to
have it as
um um user okay where the ID so the ref
is going to be pointing where is it the
ref is going to be pointing to this to
the user
ID and same for for the hotel room which
is of type reference and here we are
going to have this um text so it's not
going to be review text it's going to be
of this name text and this is going to
be of the name um user rating okay so we
should make sure here we are using this
um and this should be create
review this should be user rating just
as here and we're going to use text
okay so let's create this we're going to
have a
mutation and mutation in this object so
we have
mutations mutations is an array of
object and here we want to create um a
create mutation which takes in thisor
type and the type is going to be
review and it needs the user which is
going to have this underscore
type which is of type reference
and it needs the ref so where is it
pointing to or what is it pointing to
it's pointing to this user ID and after
this user we also need a hotel
room and the hotel room is going to be
this object where we have the underscore
type and the type is going to
be reference like this and we also need
the underscore ref and this is going to
be pointing to the hotel room ID and
after this we'll pass the user
rating and we're going to pass the text
and the text is going to be the
review text like this so we have our
mutation and we are just going to use
this thing so this Remains the Same so
after our
mutation just here we are going to call
this and return our data so so let's
save this and then let's come back to
our route and in here so if it already
exist then we want to update we're going
to assign data to be equal to our weight
and then we call update
review and update review need this
object where will pass the review
ID and this review ID is going to be
already exist doore
ID we are also going to pass the review
text and we also need a user
rating so this user rating what did we
call
it not get
here written text do we have written
text so written value like this so user
rating is going to be written
value okay but if it doesn't exist then
we need to create we're going to assign
data to await create
review and create review we take this
object so we have the hotel room ID
which is going to be the room ID like
this so this room ID is coming from our
query parameter and we need a review
text we need the user ID which is going
from our session and the user rating
which is a rating value you like
this so after all of this we shouldn't
forget
to you know return return a response so
we're going to return return uh next
response do
Json and this is going to be the
data and we can have a status of
200 and the status text
of successful like this
okay so let's hit this and see if
everything is working fine up until now
so let's try to create this
review okay so I will just um reload the
application and I'll reload uh sanity
studio so our review you see we don't
have any review yet so we are going to
try to create one review so in here
I'm going to click on rate and let's say
give this three star and say um normal
experience and I submit so let's see
what happens I don't see the text it's
is submitting but we get review
submitted so let's quickly take a look
at that logic so here where we have our
page um the we set is submitting to true
we done
so here we need to set is submitting to
True okay so maybe somewhere here set is
submit review to true and here we should
set it to false okay so that will fix it
for next time and we come back
here and you know we left a review let's
come back here and see if this updates
great so we see this here and let's see
if it's three St and everything that we
defined so let's wait for it to load
up okay so it's actually taking time I
don't know okay so this is it uh this is
the user this is the hotel room and this
is our review text and we give it a
three star rating so this is working
fine as we expect so now let's rate
again and see if our update is working
I'll give this five star and say great
like this and if I submit now we see
it's submitting and if it's done it's
cleared and if we come here we see great
and we see five star so fantastic we are
now able to write a review and if we
come here to this um to the room so this
room that the user just left a rating on
let's see if we are able
to um obviously we cannot see the review
because we haven't wired up that
connection but now we should be able to
fetch the review so let's work on that
I'm going to remove all of these so that
I have some space and
just easy for my eyes to know where I am
looking at I'm just going to collapse
all of these and next we are going to be
working in our web our rooms this log
and the page.
TS so here what do we need we have this
um reviews component so we actually need
to work in that um review component so
I'm going to create a new components so
in the components folder I'm going to
call this room
review like this and I'll create this
file so let's wire this up now I'm going
to get rid of
this and this is going to be of type FC
because we are going to request for prop
and that prop is going to be single we
want to fetch the data the review that
belongs to a particular room so here
we're going to have room ID which is of
type
string and here we are going to maybe
just D structure the room ID from the
props like this so we are going to use
our ex to fetch our room
review so we can have this Con fetch
room reviews and this is going to be
equal to this
async
function like
this and in here we're going to get our
data from ating X
dog and we are going to be going to SL
API slash room review we don't have this
yet we're going to create this and here
slash Let's uh pass the room ID and once
we're done we return data so here we are
going to return data and data will be
coming from
here all right so after this we're going
to be fetching our data making use of
the US s SW Arrow
hook and this is going to need a key so
the key will be/ API SLR
Infuse and now we're going to pass the
fetch room
reviews so here we're going to get data
which we can rename
to room
reviews and also error and also is
loading like
this so for all these properties I will
copy what we had in our web rooms in
know room here I will copy
this and make use of this here so if
there's an error we try error if type of
room
reviews is undefined and it's not
loading or also through this
error okay so we haven't set up this API
end points and then here we can cons
that log data we don't have any data we
actually named it um room
reviews so here we log to the console so
this is going to fail because we haven't
set up this Endo so let's set it up now
here in
our API
folder I'm going to create a new folder
and this folder will we call room
reviews so this room reviews to match
with this not this sorry so to match
with this is actually room reviews so
here we shouldn't forget our
s okay so here we are going to have our
route. TS file and here is going to be
pretty much straightforward we're going
to have this async
function we call it get
and
here we are going to have our request
which is going to be of
type
request and we want to take the ID from
the
param okay so I want to take the ID from
the param and to do that first this room
review we need to have this uh ID
here and have the route defined inside
here like this so we're going to have
the route inside this
ID okay so I'll take this off and here
we can have
parms I think T script will comp play
but we can say this is of type object so
would have PMS and BMS is also going to
be an object so have ID and ID is going
to be of type
string so now in here we can have a room
ID which is going to be equal to params
do
ID and we can have our TR catch
block and in case of error just L it to
the
console and say get
in revie
fi and here have the
error and we a new next response not
next request
next
response say
unable to
fetch and with State status of 400 like
this so now in our Tri block we want to
call a function to get a review so we
can have here con
reviews andews is going to be a function
we are going to Define in our sity
studio and we're going to return our
next response. Json we return return the
reviews can call it room
reviews so here we are going to return
return our room reviews and here we can
set the status of
200 and we can also set the status text
of let's
um
successful okay so let's go on to Define
this function to get um the room review
and if we come over to our leavs and in
our api. TS it's going to be pretty much
straightforward we're going to have this
um export this async
function we can call it get uh
room
reviews and this is going to take in the
ID which is of type
string and
here we can have a
result and our result is going to be AWA
our sanity client.
fretch and we don't have the review type
yet
I'll come back to that in a second and
here we are going to pass the
query and we don't also have the query
so we need to define the query and we
also need to define
the we also need to define the type so
let's come over to our queries so our
sanity queries
here and we are going to export con
get
room
reviews and this is going to be called
to this Gro query we have our backtick
and here we have the star where we set
the called type so the type is going to
be equal to
review
and the
hotel room room doore R is
the and here we
have our room ID like this and in here
we can take theore created
at you can take the
ID the
text and the user who created this
review and the user we just need a name
you just need a name to display uh in
our UI and after this we just need the
user rating so the value so this is what
we need and if we come back
to our apis. Ts for the query we can
have our queries dot um since we forgot
to add query so get room
reviews query like
this so I will save this and here I'm
going to have our reviews. get room
reviews
query and after that it's going to need
this object for par so if we come back
here you see we are having this
par where is it yeah for the room ID
okay so here we are going to pass the
room ID as a param and after that we are
going to pass another object for cache
and here we say no cash like like this
and once we're done we should go and
return return the results so very much
straightforward but for this we haven't
defined the type of review so here we
come to our models so in our models
folder and here for our
review we're going to export another
type and this is going to be a type
review and the you would have a text
which is of type
string we also have a user which is an
object with a name property and the name
is going to be a string we'll need a
user rating the user rating is going to
be a number we're going to need the
underscore created at which is going to
be of type dates and we need the
underscore ID that's the review
ID which is going to to be of type
string so here we are going to say this
is going
to return like this an array of
rating and we can come back to our
route.
TS so in our route here where we have
our room
reviews we are going to
await uh get room reviews that's we just
defined now in our
lebs and it needs the room ID we just
pass in the room
ID okay so we are fetching the review so
now we should see data because if we
come to/ API SL room reviews SL ID we
are going to be hitting this end point
so SL API um room
reviews and you know the ID in here we
are going to to hit this
route and here is going to get the
params so the room ID and it's going to
pass it to our get room
reviews it receives the ID here and it
passes it here as a par and we have no
cash here so if you feel if you visit
this get room review sare you see here
we have the room ID so now if we come
back to our
application and I would open up the
browser we see this object and if we
open up this object we see we have
results and this so we need to fetch
data so are we loging this to the
console I'm just going to reload and why
does
reloading I will come back to the room
review and I don't expect it to work and
why don't I expect it to work we are not
mounting this in our page so if we come
over to
our web our rooms slog page we are not
mounting it here so we need to have our
room review
components and now it should work what
does it need it needs a room ID and the
room ID is going to be the room no let's
see here so let's see here so we are
fetching the data from the room and here
we'll just give it the room ID so room
doore ID property so now we we save this
and we come back to
application we see an empt
array okay so we see Mt let's just um
let's go on to reload this to be sure
you know everything works
fine because we saw in our sanity Studio
that this room you know the deluxe suit
that's if the room if that's the room we
are looking at let's verify yeah so we
verify and we see our review so with is
the user so now we are sure we are
fetching our review we just need to
display it here okay so what are we
going to do we are displaying it
here we have the text room review and
that's because in the review component
that's what we're showing room review so
we need to go on and map okay so what
we're going to do here I'm going to
return fragment like this and in here
I'm going to say if
um room reviews so if this is true we
going to have our room
reviews and we're going to map through
the
review and this is going to give us each
review and we are going to return
return we are going to return this
div okay so whatever is this um it has
type
any now if we over here we can come over
here and say this is going to give
us an array of room so a room area like
this and I will just bring this down so
if we come back here it should be fine
yeah so it's fine and we can just need
we just need to pass a
key and we can say the key is going to
be the review doore
ID so let's stle this div let's give it
some class names we're going to give
this a
BG
um a BG G gray of let's say
100 I'm also going to give this on dark
mode uh PG gray of
900 just give us some padding and lastly
rounded LG like this and inside this div
we have a H2 where we display the
username so we can style it and say this
is going to be font semi
bold and mag bottom of
two and display Flex like
this so here we can have this
um paragraph So having a paragraph
inside the H2 I'll change this to a div
and inside this paragraph I'm going to
display
the review do
name like this
um no so it's meant to be the
username so why are we having this so
you do user that name so what type did
we set here we set room sorry it wasn't
meant to be room it was meant to
be
review okay so it was meant to be review
and now everything should be fine yep
everything is fine and after this we're
going to have another
div and here we want to display the
actual rating so
here we're going to get this margin left
of
four
Flex item
Center text the sh
lights um
text sh lights and text LG like this and
here we want to display the user rating
we're going to display that in uh
another component which we are going to
create but for now we can just display
the outright rating and after this div
we are going to have this div and here
we are just going to display the review
text so now let's save this and let's
come back to
the
browser and over here we see this so we
see the username and we see the rating
number okay so we don't see the text I
think it's actually loading up so we can
reload this and we should be
seeing um the user
text so we can just wait for this to
load and here we should see the user
text we don't see the user text so why
don't we see the user text I'm just
going to log this
um console. log
this room reviews I just log it to the
console so that we will be sure of what
property we used so this we sted it as
um let's see so
review
dot text so this
isn't this is text so we have an error
here okay and did we what did we use
here so we use if we inspect
this so this is text okay so that's why
we are having the issue to fix this I
don't know where we made this issue
where we had that typo maybe you noticed
I will just search for it here and this
should help so here we made a mistake
this should be
text and now we save it we should see
the
user we should see the user text I'm
actually going to close all to have more
room and this time around great we see
the text which is also great so let's
have this review component the rating
components and if we come back to
our just leave this open if we come back
to our where is it leaves no our
component we can have this
rating and in here we can have this
rating. TSX
file okay so I will rename
this and here we can have our react
components I will get rid of this so
This react component we'll need some
props so I say this is of type
FC and the prop is going to need
even though is one you can still Define
it here so type props is going to be
this object so we take
rating and rating is of type number so
here we can bring in props and we can D
structure rating like
this and we need to know when to show a
half star and when to show a fulla okay
so before we return return we actually
going to return return
empty
fragment here we are going to have this
full
Stars
constants uh and this is going to be
called to math.
FL and rting like
this and here we can have the
decimal part this decimal part is going
to be the rating we get minus full star
so in casee there's any you know
remainder so here we can have our full
star
elements and this is going to be an
array so this array we are going to have
our full stars and we want to fill it so
what are we going to fill it with we're
going to fill it with um a component so
fa
star where is it f star like this we
going to import
that so now we have our full
element here I'm just going to render it
so here full star
elements like that and we can already
have
a half star
elements and this is going to be equal
to
null and we can check if decimal if
decimal part is greater than
zero then our halfer element is no
longer going to be n it's going to be
our fa star half like
this and here after this we are going to
render
uh half star element just in here all
right so let's save this and now we're
going to use this rating in uh room
review component here where we just have
this review. user rating we are going to
have our
own rating component and here we're
going to pass the rating which is going
to be equal to
review dot user rating so now if we save
this and we come back we should see five
stars
here so we just wait for this and we
should see five Stars great so we see
our five stars and everything is looking
good both on our white and our dark team
so this is the functionality we can go
on to notbook this hotel and everything
is working as expected and if we come
back here and let's say we want to
update
the we want to update the review and
actually this is quite loud why is it
that big if we come back to
the web users and page so where is it we
have this and this should be 28 looking
too big and there should be some padding
button here so we save this and we come
back we have our space and this is now
little smaller so if we try to rate the
room I'll just switch back to the light
team and let's say we go back to two and
then we say not so
great and we click on submit it
submits and once we come back to our
room we should see this update
automatically so not so great and we see
this so that's it for this um
functionality so this is the application
we're building and congratulations if
you've made it th far and now with this
time we can go on to build to publish
our application to the Internet so that
we can share with our friends so far we
have been working on our local machine
on Local Host 3000 so let's go and
publish our application and to do this
I'm going to quate our terminal and we
need to initialize git in our project so
here let's just open this up we need to
initialize get in our project we do that
making of git in it so now git is
initialized in our project and you see
over here we have 76 changes okay but
you see our EnV is not grade out the
cach is grade out node modules this is
grade out we want to also grade out gr
out our EnV and that is or that means so
that git is not tracking this file so to
do that we can come to our G ignore and
just somewhere here you can add en EnV
like this and Save
so take a look here you see that EnV is
now grade out and git will not be
tracking these files for changes and
then we will not have all these our
secret code pushed out all right so
without out of the way let's configure
our email so get config user. email I
will put my email address
here and get
config user.name and and I will put my
username okay so with this next we are
going to add everything to staging so
get add and Dot means add
everything okay and after we need to
commit our changes with take commit
message and I'll just call this final
build like this and now you see all our
code file has been committed now we want
to push this over to GitHub and to do
that you see this doesn't mean anything
actually if we reload you see our server
is actually shut down we need to create
uh new repository so here I will click
on repositories like this and I'll click
on new to create a new repo and I'll
call this
hotel management like this I'll make
this public and
create okay so once this is created we
can come here so we have an already
existing in repo from the command line
we just need to get remote ad and push
our changes so this we have done get in
it get add but we added all so we added
all our files we committed and this is
where we at now and then we
push so I'm going to come back here and
paste this in so get remote add origin
and then get push
origin Master like this it access for my
password I'll provide my password and
this should push all our files to
GitHub so once this is done if we come
over to
GitHub and we reload we should see all
our files here all right we don't see
yet so it's still right in and once it
is done we should see all our files so
it's done and now if we reload this we
should see our file
great now we have this we need to come
over to Vel and here to go to log in or
create a new project a new Vel um no
sign up and here I'll click on add new I
want to add a new project and I want to
import this project so here you already
see the project here if you don't see it
you can configure Vel to sech for the
product so here I'm just going to click
on import I'll leave the name as
theault and let's see what do we have
here um do we have nextjs I would just
choose
nextjs as a framework and here I need to
add environment variables so I would
just come
here and in the EnV I will copy
everything we have here so I will just
copy everything we have here so from
here to here like this and if you copy
this and you come back here and you just
paste it here everything has been added
automatically so that's great and next
you can just click on deploy please take
um a note of this stripe web hook okay
because this is the this is the one we
use for development and when we add this
to our stripe we're going to get a new
one so we need to come back and update
but that's fine we can already go on to
deploy our application and now you see
our application is building and if you
expand this we see the steps that the
vasel CLI is
running and first it went on to clone
our project from GitHub so here you see
it went to clone our project which is
the master branch that was automatically
synced to this Vel project that we
created so this
one and after cloning you it's now
installing the dependencies by running
Vel build this vasel build command goes
on to install our
dependencies and now you see it's
running npm run build so next is running
npm run
build and now it's running next build so
this mpm run build goes on to run the
next build command and here we have
couple of warning totally fine and once
it is done we should see our application
so we can just ignore this warning we
see here and now it is finalizing page
optimization and now it has successfully
built our application and we should see
the deployment summary so build
completed here all right so we s our
summary everything is fine and it's just
completing the checks and it redirects
us to this page okay so we see our
application that we built so now we can
continue to our
dashboard and here in our dashboard we
can visit our application this is
definitely going to break because we
need to add some things some files here
so we can't even authenticate if we try
to authenticate with Google we should
have an error so if we try to
authenticate with Google it should fail
so you see this fail this fails
all right so let's fix it I will copy
this
URL and come back here so where do we
have let's start with uh sanity studio
so I'll just open up a new tab and I'll
p in this
URL and I'll go to/ Studio which is
where our CMS Lees so in the studio URL
and this is going to open up next year
so that we can add this to course else
we're going to have issues and not
working with this so I'll click on
continue this will redirect us and here
we are going to add course origin so
once we do this we are going to have our
project configured and you see we have
all our hotel room and we can visit our
application this is one we need to do
more if we come over to Google so this
is where we had our web client we can
click here and if we do we need to add
this authorized callback URL which for
now just has Local Host so we're going
to paste in our URL and we go to/ API
slof SL callback SLG
Google this so please do make sure you
add this so this will be the domain you
get from Vel and do attach API sl/
callback SLG gooogle and go on to save
this so once you have this saved you're
done with Google and next we can go on
to our
stripe so here we need to add an
endpoint okay we need to add an endpoint
here and the endpoint URL is going to be
this and then slash API slash web
hook so these endpoints we have here if
you come over here we are pointing to
this so in our source in our app API SL
web hook this route here which is our
web hook route okay so make sure you
don't have any typle here else is not
going to work you can add a description
and here we're not going to select all
of event we're going to click on event
and let's see the event we are listening
to so we are listening to this checkout
session completed I'll copy this and
search here and I'll paste it here and
you know check this checkbox here okay
and this just gives an example which we
have done all through this uh project so
I'm going to add this event and that
should be it so here we click on ADD
endpoint great now we have added
endpoint you see here where we have this
sign in secret I'll click on review and
now we need to copy this so we're going
to copy this and come back to
Vel so where do we have our Vel here
okay so here we will come over to the
settings tab
and in settings tab where do we have um
environment
variables here if we come over to where
is it our stripe web hook secret so this
we can view this web hook secret and
I'll just come here and click on edit so
I'm going to remove this value and paste
in this new value that comes from stripe
and click on save so now once we have
saved this we need to redeploy so come
back to redeploy um deployments tab here
and click here click on
redeploy all right we're not going to
use existing build cache we're just
going to redeploy this like this and now
we're going to wait for this to build
all fast forward and I'll be back once
this is done building because we have
already gone through the different steps
that Vel goes through to build our
project so I'll see you once this build
is completed
or maybe I would I wouldn't fast forward
because we are actually leaving out one
thing so remember we have um GitHub
authentication so if you come here where
do we have our project so if we come
here and we come over to the settings
tab and we come over
to whether we have a developer settings
whether we have the developer settings
have I missed it
somewhere all right so let's come here
and let's come
to
settings and here we can come over to
developer
settings and developer settings you come
over to O apps and here hotel
management you choose your project we
need to update this so This points to
Local Host that means gith up
authentication real definitely fail I
will update this but not to this I will
copy this URL that we get from Vel and
paste it in here and also paste the
Callback URL like this and update this
application great so now we are going to
be pointing to the correct URL and I
will just remove this and if we come
back here and let's see how application
is
doing it's it is done and we'll just
wait for the deployment output to be
done so that we can now revisit our
application and test our flow one last
time so it is done we can click on
visit and this is going to take us to
our
application so let me go back and look
for this I think I would still work with
this URL we have here so I would copy
this URL and work with it rather than
this um new URL that we get okay so you
see this
here I would work with this actually and
let's come here and let's try it out
we're going to try our web hook and be
sure that everything is working fine so
I'll paste in this URL and let's try to
shop a hotel room let's try to book
actually so we'll come
here this was one we booked from
previously and now I will come over to
book this
room and next something went wrong so
what happened because we are not
authenticated okay I think so so let's
authenticate I will click here and click
here our authenticates with
Google and wait for this so that's one
logic you can handle if you're not
authenticated and trying to protect
those routes so now I'm going to click
here again and you see doesn't crash so
it works just as fine so in this room
you can update the logic to make sure if
you're not at you cannot visit this this
route and I think this issue is um
coming from here so I think it's coming
from our middleway so what we just
noticed I think it's coming from here
but no worries we would keep an eye on
this middleway as we test out our
application and let's choose a check-in
date and also a checkout date I'll just
choose the next day so the price is 400
for the total price as we have a 20%
discount okay and it's now 400 so if we
choose to this it should be 800 great so
the logic is working fine and if we
choose um let's say if we come here and
we choose you know a date that is way
higher than the checkout date we should
have this great so this is working fine
and let's try to book now and we should
be redirected over to stripe which we
are and we have this eror check out
session could not be found the error is
usually caused by using the wrong API
key so perhaps we using the wrong API
key as tripe has told us so let's update
our API key so to do that I will come
back here and here if I come to
developers and I come to API keys I'll
copy this publishable key and I would
have to edit this again and click here
and where do I have to edit so I'll come
here and here I'll click on settings
click on environment
variables and this is the publishable
key so where do we have the stri
publishable key this key over here if we
visit this so publishable key I'm going
to click on this click on edit and
update this publishable key all right so
I will save this and next we need to
update the secret key to be sure we are
using the correct Keys here so this is
the stripe secret key I'll click here
click on
edit and I will also update that secret
key and click on Save okay so if you
didn't have the errors it's fine for
some reason I got it so maybe I use the
wrong keys and now I'll have to redeploy
so come back to um
deployment and in here I will redeploy
and here click on redeploy all right so
this is going to redeploy again so is
totally fine when you're building
application for production and you get
one of these errors um you know missing
keys and stuff like that so I would wait
for this to build and once the build is
complete I'll be back all right so our
build is completed and now we can you
know revisit our application so so this
is the domain I'm going to copy this
domain and let's try it out again so
here so this is where we had error I'm
just going to paste this back in and now
let's see if everything works I'll come
back to
rooms
and here I'll choose this room again and
I'll try to book it like this and click
on book now so we should be redirected
back to stripe
and now you see stripe doesn't crash so
it was a case of using the wrong API
keys I'll just provide a test
email
and this card
information and give it this CVV and
give it this test
name and click on pay so let's keep an
eye on where is it on web Hooks and see
if if we have an event here that gets
triggered so let's wait for this to
process
successfully and for now we don't have
this yet let's see so this is done and
we don't see the hotel that we booked
all right so we see this is actually
failing if we click on
this and here I'm just going to reload
this so that we you know we see if this
was actually called and if we come over
to our domain for/
Studio here I think is this no so if we
come to our domain and we come over to
bookings do we have an extra booking no
we don't and if we come here we have
this so we have this 307 temporary
redirect and I think this has to do with
the issue that we had initially where we
were blocked from here because 307 is
usually every Direct
and that should be this Middle Way
causing the issue so we need to update
this I'm going to duplicate this and
here I'm going to change this I'm going
to get rid of the API because we are
actually authenticating our API Pages we
don't we're not going to be doing it
here so we just going to be blocking the
user route so this might have some
effect on the API folder which it
definitely does but I'll just leave this
here or maybe I take it off so you know
you don't see was not working and now
I'm going to rebuild rep push our
application so I'm going to save
this and get add dot again get commit
iPhone M I will say fix Middle Way error
like this and now we're going to push
get push origin Master like this and
once we have this change
pushed Vel should build autom ially
because it's connected to our current
branch which is our Master Branch so
let's see if that's the case okay so I'm
going to come back to Vel and I'll come
to
deployment and I will come back to our
function first and you see it's building
so automatically it's just deploying our
application and I'm going to click here
so we can inspect the build to be sure
everything works just as fine fine and
if you click here it's just doing what
it did before so you know running mpm
run build which NE runs the next build
command and we have this warning from
our rooms page regarding use effect it's
just a
warning and now it's generating our
static pages and it's done so I don't
know it was super fast so perhaps it
used cash to build or it just builds the
middle way the section it found out that
needed to be fixed which is this so fix
middleware error so just this change and
that's why it's super fast all right so
it's done already and let's
retry so I'll come here to the
application and I'll copy this because I
want to load it again and I'm going to
update our URL like
this so let's try to build um we can
come to our rooms we
take a look at this room again and here
I'm going to choose this and choose this
as a checkout dates and book this again
so now we should still keep an eye on
this U middleway so we have these two
failing and I'm going to provide this
test at test.com and
provide this card
information
three CVV and give this set
name I would just say code
with lbrary like this and I'll click on
pay and this time around let's see if
everything works and we don't get the
301 redirect now this works and we don't
see it here which might be bad news but
let's check here good news actually so
we see our booking so it means it works
this time around and this is the hotel
room we booked and if it had this
discount and everything here great and
we see it here it just needed to reload
all right so if we come back here and we
reload our
stripe and let's wait for it to reload
and let's see if our web Hook is
actually working in
production and this was successful this
time around great and that's why we had
a booking so users are not able to book
um a hotel room unless a payment is
successful and that's why we have this
code this code here running in the
background and let's leave a rating on
this room so we have this log V if we
visit the room now we don't see any
rating all right so let's try to leave a
rating I would come back here click on
rate I'll give this a five star and say
great
experience and click on submit so once
it's successful you see review submitted
we are going to come here and great
experience we see our review and we see
that this is booked and we can you know
try again and again so here I'll click
on rate it'll give it a five star I'll
give four star and say um androoid my
stay androoid my
stay like this and click on submit now
this is going to update and if we come
back here we should check take a look at
this we don't see any review yet so
let's just reload perhaps it hasn't
updated and here we see it so enjoyed my
stay and we see this so great our
application is working fantastic and
this is the build and you see everything
works as we you know we coded it out
fine in um production and also in
development so everything has been fine
uh and everything is working great so
this is the build if you enjoyed it
please to go on and subscribe and you
know I look forward to building more of
these projects with you you can try out
these filters and everything is working
fine and try to remove the console.log
that we have here all right great so see
you in the next one and take care until
then iind your boy Cod it Larry do take
care and bye-bye